Hello, Sleepy Bird is back again.
Two days in a row.
I'm here.
I'm here and I'm alive.
Well, physically, yes, mentally, no.
But good morning, good morning, everyone.
not on the schedule but if you guys remember I am got I yeah
it's okay the drafting is 30 for 30 minutes long so I have
30 minutes to to get ready um but yeah I know I sound like
I'm fucking dying I know I do not sound okay right now I I
do not sound my my throat my throat is having a wild time
now um any anyway i i am awake and um for those who don't
know we got last minute invited to super tfs 200k
invitational uh where every team must have a deadpool on
their team what team are you gonna be on dokeybird i don't
know um because they are they are drafting the team right
now um but The team captains are Super, Tyler 1, Necroz,
Flats, E-Rob, and XQC.
And it's like a round robin.
It's going to be round robin at first.
And then after that is best of one.
After everyone round robins, it's best of one.
And then we'll see how that goes.
We could end super early or we could go all the way to the
end.
I honestly, at this point in my life, either works for me.
At this, at this point of time, of how I feel right now, if
we get eliminated, like, eliminated first, that's okay for
me.
If we get eliminated less, I'm also okay with that.
They're both, they're both positives for me at this point.
as long as I get to have fun with my team that's all I care
about because like okay so you know how during the early
access I was like oh support Deadpool's like she's not that
great it's so confusing so apparently it's crazy you know
after people played Deadpool for like because apparently the
season launched like a couple of hours ago and people
already figured out that support Deadpool actually really
strong so i'm like oh shit okay well fuck um i don't
understand how to play this character fuck like support i
knew tank deadpool was really strong i thought dps deadpool
was pretty sick too but apparently if you know how to play
support deadpool he's actually a pretty good character and
i'm like bro i don't even know what the fuck i was doing i
was just mashing
Yeah, so it already took people, like, I don't know, three
to four hours to be like, no, I support Deadpool is actually
one of the strongest Deadpool's, and I'm like, oh, shit,
well, fuck, I guess one of the support players got to learn
Deadpool now during this tournament.
And also, more supports is now meta.
I, oh, no.
What else can I say about that?
oh no it's like two tanks for supports welcome back goats um
people apparently are winning games with two tanks for
supports with Deadpool as one of the supports and I was like
oh that's not good
I'm like that's that's not that's not good that seems very
wrong
it's not like hard hard meta but people have been winning
games with four supports um in rank so we'll see how that
goes as well i don't know if people are gonna be playing
that in the tournament but we'll see i'm nervous because
there's a lot of big content creators in this tournament i'm
like a small fish compared to these people so so oh wow okay
uh um oh let me let me open my eyes let me don't worry guys
let me open my eyes
I don't know if I should play this is how I actually feel
but like
but like I feel like you'll see more emotions from me if I
open my eyes uh let me get yeah let me get some eye yeah let
me get some eye drops real quick plop plop oh
okay all right when our games begin when our games begin
i'll open up my eyes um what else oh did you guys see the
fuck they're being back the fat Pikachu he's coming back Fat
Pikachu can finally leave the diet He don't need a diet no
more Yeah lay off that Ozenpik Pikachu Uh but they're
bringing back fat Pikachu Like the classic fat Pikachu Um in
In plushie back then I'm so I actually want to order it like
after the stream I have to figure out how to order it
because apparently it's like You can order it on Amazon I
think you can order it on like proxy sites right want to
figure that shit out maybe not after this stream i'll figure
it later um but i'm gonna yeah he's like he's like he
basically doesn't have to do modeling work anymore and then
he's like yum yum yum yum and now he's fat again he's my fat
little pikachu um anyway so i'm that's an important life
update fat pikachu is back that's very important um all
right are they drafting all right let's see i also i did not
you know ever since the early access that's all i of that's
all i uh that's all i i did i didn't touch him since because
i literally i personally thought i was just like there's no
i i personally just thought that support deadpool was not
gonna be it but then silly me oh yeah also here's a little
fun tip for those who don't want to read an essay i i
discovered this recently so um look at this i saw this on
twitter so because i I was like, bro, this is like a, I feel
like I fucking need a PhD.
So look at this.
Do you guys notice a very significant difference in text
now?
And how, like a switch to a dual pistol.
So, you know, if you want to read less, it's a lot.
Yeah, it's a lot less now.
Because apparently there is a setting for Deadpool.
It's like crazy.
any of the Deadpool's.
I know you have to do this for all three Deadpool's, by the
way.
And then you scroll down.
There is Deadpool style ability descriptions.
So the reason why it was so fucking long and so confusing is
because Deadpool himself wrote the descriptions of the
ability.
So the more I turn this on.
I turn this on.
What is this?
This is the tank Deadpool.
And then let me go this would and then it's a that's like 20
like slice and dice anyone trying to get near my team gets
the business at both katanas the mood's so good my teammates
will never forget my dazzling and then i go here i go here
swap to dual katanas
i'm like oh my god okay i think i can understand this
character now So here's a little fun little tip for those
who are like, what the fuck is he saying?
Yeah, so now, now his ability, his like tutorial thing is
much more readable now.
I bro, it's 12 p.m.
I cannot, I cannot fucking, I need to figure this out
because I, I don't know if I'm playing Deadpool or whoever
or my other support is.
playing Deadpool.
Like I gotta figure this because apparently Deadpool is,
support Deadpool is very strong guys.
Like I need to know what's going on.
I know I did an early access but I already forgot.
I already forgot what's going on.
Yeah.
Everyone else has been fucking practicing him.
Okay.
So let's see.
before I'm a remove okay so support it'll be like I assume
like I have to use my E a lot but they're dead so it's not
my fault I assume like I have to use this and I knew that a
lot too and then when I have to I swap
yeah but it's so I do so little damage with my katanas
though Yeah, and then and then I do the Q All right, I need
to remember I definitely need to remember to um Why is she
or can I okay
Okay I can't how the fuck do I get that full combo?
How?
I guess I have to like, it has to be like everybody in front
of me.
Yeah.
So, I don't know.
We'll figure it out live.
Well, we'll figure it out live, I guess.
Well, we can figure it out.
Yeah.
I need to use both E's and the head jumps.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I was going to say how to fuck.
Do I get both combos?
Alright.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Oh my god.
I'm only at five.
That's as furthest as I can get.
Whatever.
Our team dies.
Our team dies when I play Deadpool.
That's fine.
I've accepted it.
Penny's strong.
But like, it is what it is.
It is.
It is what it is.
More bounce.
I'm not used to just randomly bouncing.
Oh, wait.
Let me see if I can bounce on them.
God, bounce on their heads.
All right.
Well, let me kill him.
Let me see.
Boing, boing, boing.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
All right.
I got this.
I figured it out.
Guys, I figured it out.
Okay, let me fucking queue.
How come sometimes I can't...
Okay, I have to get an S.
Oh my god, I already fucked up the bounce.
Alright, so whatever.
Our team dies.
Okay, guys, whatever.
That's the...
I accepted it.
Let's leave.
Oh my god.
I need to learn a new support.
It's okay.
Maybe everyone else wants to play Deadpool, so I never have
to play Deadpool.
I'm just going on with that.
That belief.
I'm going to go in and with my people.
Oh, look at all these Deadpools.
Oh my god.
That's a big-ass deadpaw.
Hey, guys.
Oh, my God.
Hey, don't worry, everyone.
I know what my job is.
All right, well, he dances.
Let me look at.
Oh, they're drafting now.
They're drafting.
They're drafting now.
Wait, am I on a team already?
Wait, who's team am I on?
Oh, I'm with Moxie and Tyler one.
let's go wait another one drafted me oh my god oh my god
sorry i wasn't paying attention i was trying to figure out
deadpool wait when did i got picked oh that's sick oh and
moxie too that's sick Okay, yeah
We're on Tyler What?
Doki was like Wait, Tyler What?
He was like Doki Ben Oh, he remembers me Wait Tyler
remembers Guys, no, they're just gonna target Ben Tyler 1,
guys, it was just gonna be A repeat He Wait, that's cool He
remembers me like that he was like don't he was like don't
did he was he actually like that way i'm gonna watch the
stream oh my god this is a celebration dance now all right
let me check where's me really oh that's sweet that's cute
that makes me happy
playing everything but rivals.
I do not think he got stronger.
I do not think he got stronger, guys.
All right.
That's cute.
That's what makes me happy.
That makes me happy.
All right.
It's all right.
It's fine.
If we lose, at least I'm on the fight.
fun team bro it's gonna even with lose at least i know with
moxie and tyler it's gonna be a fun team yeah but we
definitely need an actual tank player that can like um i'm
sorry but like tyler one can only play venom and we sort of
need a shield tank we sort of need a shield tank guys well
moxie plays captain america technically it's a shield take
too but we need moxie on dps guys he needs to be on dps i
think that's the only way bro i'm pulling up the draft now i
didn't know who's on whose team all right bro brum bro i
mean he was carrying as venom for the longest time and then
and then And then, um, the one, then one, we faced the,
like, during the, um, sorry, I'm tired, my brain, my, I
still, I'm looking for a hamster to run on the wheel, so
there's no hamster right now in my brain, it's just empty,
but, and then he got target banned, and then we got knocked
out instantly.
We got, guys, the last time, he was carrying on venom, and
then he got target banned, and then it was, a g g yeah oh
wait we don't have the gale that's true gale and i are not
on a team together so we don't have the negative chemistry
that's true our curse if you put dokeybird and gale on the
same team together it activates the curse we're good like
individual wise But when we put us two to get it, we have we
it's surprising that we have a zero 0% 0% score on
tournaments together as a team
The negative team up exactly it is actually the negative
team up right now
Yeah I don't even know that Who's they don't even they have
I've not displayed like the overall team now.
It's just watching people pick and it's disappearing.
I'm trying to see who's on my team other than me and Moxie.
Does anyone know who else is on my team other than me and
Moxie?
Also, I'm pretty sure Tyler did not research all the other
players.
I think he's picking off my vibes guys I'm yeah I'm pretty
sure he picked on vibes I don't even think he knows who
plays what role I
he's got the sea but it's really weird guys we might guys we
might have a short stream today but at least we'll have fun
We got to see Tyler won again.
I'm so happy.
I never died actually doing stuff with Tyler.
But we did in the last XQC tournament.
And now he picked me.
And it makes me...
I'm like, yeah!
He remembers me.
Yeah.
Guys, if he's picking out Vives, we would be lucky if we
even have 2-2-2.
we'd be at and then but most likely we might have four
supports and then it's tyler one and moxie cool wait who i
don't know who these people okay um
um who okay i'm gonna see who these people are and what they
play okay i finally i found the spot where um where they i
can actually see my teammates now yeah i need i'm gonna
check there's a rank check thing here okay we have a two
supports okay um oh okay we have another tank player
technically this other guy also plays support but like he's
like or tank or take okay we just need tyler one to not pick
another support and then we should be good we should be If
all else fails, we can always play triple support or we play
triple support or we play triple support One of them only
has 13 hours played, but that's okay Most likely it's either
me or me playing Deadpool most likely
Okay, either he picks a third support or Actually, I play a
few of their support actually might be the plan actually, it
actually might be a play, guys.
Plaking a third support.
Who is?
Okay, they do have a, okay.
Oh, they have it.
Wait, E-Rob's team is actually stacked.
Because E-Rob's team has space and apparently a one above
all DPS player.
So, like, that's a little but they do have three oh they
have three supports though all
right who else is left
but who's left all right I believe I believe in the vibes I
believe in the vibes guys we can do this off of vibes alone
There's still two, four, six more players to go.
Where is Amalie, like, on the board twice?
Because her name isn't removed.
But it says, like, it says she's, like, on XQC's team.
But her name isn't removed from the board.
So I'm confused.
Yeah, like, I think they put her twice.
on the board because it's like because she's still on like
oh wait sorry I'm sorry for not dancing for you guys I'm so
sorry don't worry cheek to cheek wait cheek to cheek there
we go alright now I can go back yeah no I just think I'm
pretty sure like she's on it twice okay Because that...
Wait, actually, here.
That's a better perspective.
I'll tab out.
Yeah.
I was gonna say...
Who's gonna be our sixth player?
Our sixth player is gonna definitely be a support player.
Looking at this.
Yeah, our last...
The last three.
And then...
Yeah!
Moxie just messaged me.
He's like, fucking god!
Yeah!
As long as no one target bends, Tyler, we should be good.
There we go.
Who's gonna be our sixth guy?
Yeah!
I told him.
Oh, Moxie was...
Oh!
Oh, Moxie was the one that told him to pick me!
Oh, that's sweet.
Yeah, Moxie messaged me.
He's like, I told him.
I told him to pick me.
Yeah!
Alright, everyone's picked.
Our goat.
He's got our backs.
And before we lose every game.
But it's okay, he's got my back.
he's got he's got our backs but
together we fall
together we fall mr.
row waffles I have mr.
mr or well oh waft what does he play i got waffles man oh oh
he plays he plays uh dps or can support okay unranked 20
hours in this game that's okay everyone else also has not a
lot of hours so we should be good we are equal all right
we're oh my gosh i'm so nervous oh my gosh wait i gotta But
I gotta restart my discord real quick, guys, because I have
to set up Oh, no, I stopped dancing with the crew I'm so
sorry my fellow venom.
Oh my god, we created a venom Oh my god, it's a venom Mosh
pit Let's go My venom mosh pit Okay
You're spying!
Wait a minute, that's why we're going now!
Oh, fuck out of our chat!
Yeah, what the hell, dude?
Fucking cheater?
He cheats all times.
No, he's acting.
Yeah.
Okay, guys, so let me explain something.
I play two characters, so I play Fiddup only, pretty much.
And then if that gets banned, I play Groot.
That is all I can do.
That's good.
So, so I got three characters under the belt here, right?
I got Invisible Woman, and then Hella and Luna.
that's my okay perfect are you gonna be that's my in
business meta are you gonna be I've been practicing my
invisible woman lately so I'm ready for that I wonder if
you're gonna be on support I think we could do triple
support and just PvP or scum hey guys how do you get
overlays on discord yeah I'm cooking one up right now stream
kit yeah I'm cooking one up it's Google stream kit discord I
I put one in the
Yeah, stall for OPS That a half my shit is it?
I put one in the team Tyler one chat.
I've already clicked first Moxie You're too late.
Okay.
All right.
So he doesn't need your help
He's a strong independent man.
Okay, so I got it downloaded and what do I do?
And then that has a browser source voice.
Yeah
Yeah, I think we actually have a fucking good shot.
No cap guys.
I like this.
I think we do too.
I think some people definitely fuck control the draft.
Ruffle waffles.
What do you play man?
If you don't mind me asking.
Yeah, no worries.
I, in the last tournament I was support because I had like
10 hours in the game.
In the last two days, I've been learning DPS.
So I can play Squirrel Girl, Heller, No More.
I'm pretty good with No More.
uh if you force me onto bucky i can play bucky but i'm less
consistent with bucky so i'd say no more is probably a
better option i can moon night and then i can also flex onto
rocket or uh lunar if you need me to but probably would
prefer dps but i can i can do whatever you guys think would
be best for the team guys fire fire i like that i like that
team player i like that somebody help me okay so maybe you
should use Moxie's thing that he provided.
Okay, you see the thing in the Tyler one chat?
You just copy that and add it as a source.
That entire link?
Yeah, yeah, you add it as a source and then you should be
good as a browser source.
And it's the URL.
Oh, it works!
Yay!
Are we all supposed to do that?
Are you trolling me, Doki?
Bro, what?
I just want to talk to you too!
Bro, you had me download some third-party program and now
it's just all my PCs somewhere.
yeah but now if you want to if you want to do it yourself
you could do it in the future all right okay now i'm locked
in i'm locked in wait is that something other other things
already has your data i kind of like that actually i might
i'm gonna add that i like that yeah oh is it for names yeah
yeah so shows when people are talking there's no offense
guys i don't know who any of the you people are respect what
the heck man will that will the same link work for all the
of us could i just yeah yeah yeah yeah if you want to
customize it i can give you i can send like the css for a
better version i trust your and then you just paste it in
the custom css i'll push it uh you just copy that and paste
in the custom css and it does like a little bouncy thing
sorry which channel are you posting it in either one chat
just right click it and then do open chat oh I see I see it
oh yeah that's sick I like that it's on it looks nice
everyone scream at the same time so we can perfect hello
look wait don't you what do you play I play support so I can
I can flex any other supports I feel like we might I need a
Deadpool support or a tank Deadpool because Deadpool that uh
I haven't really watched too much good at support or tank so
it depends on who either the tank player plays it or the
support player plays it i have no time on deadpool okay you
had early access just like me zero time you wasn't giving it
a shot i saw you on deadpool for a minute okay so i guess
i'm on deadpool okay unless tyler do you want to do you want
to play deadpool okay i'm actually playing the win it's
actually Okay, I'm going to the middle or I'm going to the
group guy.
But you could be a prodigy on Deadpool.
You don't know that until you try.
Oh, I'm not first-timing.
Stop rage-baiting me.
You don't fucking listen.
Guys, we didn't sound like that.
You need to listen.
Okay?
I don't like people to fucking listen.
Hear me?
Okay, let's go.
Okay, I'm playing Deadpool.
I'm playing Deadpool.
Okay, guys.
I guess I'm on Deadpool, guys.
these guys are fucked uh so not us like i'm looking at our i
mean based on what we said we had am i tank i followed him
as well i don't know if sound guy is here i might be tank i
don't know i saw you play gambit and tank dude you're the
goat you got this i mean you play tank right i like our team
yeah i do i put in for i've been playing support more
recently but uh i can play any tank and i could play pretty
much any i literally if we need anything i can play a
perfect slot you're perfect slot.
I mean, we could play Loki.
Gambit, Loki, and Deadpool.
That should be fine.
That would abuse people in this badly.
Like, the people who don't play this game often, if we found
a way to play that well.
Loki plays Loki, right?
Yeah, but we need a Deadpool, and apparently it's either me
or someone else.
Wait, do we actually have to have a Deadpool?
Is that what we have to do?
Yeah, because it's the Deadpool turn.
I didn't see that in the rules.
Am I tweeting?
I figured that might be the case.
but I have no time on them either so did I learn them right
now yeah you might as like why don't we get like a ruffle
waffles on them on Deadpool okay so okay I'll give you a
quick rundown don't worry I'm just as confused as you okay
so here's the first tip you go to settings I don't know I
think looks pretty good you go no you go on settings and
then you go a keyboard and then go all heroes change it to
Deadpool or like Deadpool support you scroll down it says to
hero and it says to pick Deadpool support yeah yeah okay and
then you scroll down you click on here you see hero Deadpool
style ability description turn that shit off so you can
actually understand what your abilities are I'll turn it off
and anything else anything else I got it off just read just
read I can't do that oh god just read your abilities okay he
just yaps the whole game doesn't he oh my my first time i
i've i've like intentionally not watched any um guys they're
actually asking everybody to leave their games now so that
you can invite okay how am i supposed to learn deadpool yeah
i guess you just can't oh well if i'm out of the game good
luck to what wait who are we fighting bro yeah there's only
no there's only four people in here you can go in the
practice range while you're in the lobby yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah sure sure sure sure we're playing against necros first
okay wait let me let me see what they have i don't know
necros is good necros is really good he just plays the most
annoying characters like i think there's people that are
probably just as good as him in here but he just i believe
he plays people that are so obnoxious you can dip him yeah
just play bucky and then hook him uh why is a ruffle hunter
pink i'm in the uk brother oh my god why did anybody tell me
that you picked me you should have regents next to him next
to the list
Oh.
Open Tony's on Moon Knight.
On this side I got.
I don't need an M, but...
Oh, shit.
Who is my...
Who is in...
Okay, so am I...
Am I trying to Deadpool or not?
I've zero hours on Deadpool, so...
Well, someone's trying Deadpool.
If we actually have to have one, then it might be worth it.
I did.
We have to have one, I'm pretty sure.
What up, Morrison?
What up?
Thank you for joining today and participating.
uh just need everyone to leave the practice area or time
square or the games they're in uh most of you should be
getting your invites right now but if not that might be why
um but good luck today thank you very much check check check
do we have to have a deadpool no oh yeah i didn't think so
okay okay that's huge that's massive that's good okay thank
you no problem we're saved right it's all good yeah yeah we
win now gg yeah nice okay then we can play gambit loki we
could it'll probably get banned they'll probably someone
someone on every like they're gonna ban it damn it at least
that's funny though the Deadpool invitational and Deadpool's
not required yeah that's I thought there was a chance and
then no one plays Deadpool I don't know because probably
support just because it seems like mr.
raffle waffle said he pretty much has all his time in DPS
and Doki's in support.
And some support.
You're right.
We could run a triple and then we could do double tank and
Moxie could be our solo DPS if you want to do that.
I'm going to write my heroes in our team chat so that you
can like refer to those in case you want to make some calls
on what you want to play.
Alright, Moxie, you go cook the comp.
Yeah, I'm trying to see here, dude.
I definitely want Tyler on the venom or the grude.
He's that guy.
He could go dive.
I'm playing Hawkeye.
I don't know.
Okay, we don't go dab.
I feel like I could cook on that the most.
Okay.
I like that.
But I could flex as well.
What?
I forgot these bands right now.
Fan Fan only plays Cloak, but I feel like I kind of want her
on Cloak.
I mean, the thing is we need a mag if she's going to be on
Cloak because then they'll just, they just get free Cloak
all.
True, true.
Or you can headshot here, I guess.
yeah he's on hawk guy yeah true i mean but then she might
just run into a cubby hole or some i can do mag for us every
game if uh if tyler's on uh grude or even or venom yeah my
ag will help be good because then that just fully counters
cloak and if all else fails we can go triple support
wow i like this i like this guys i'm feeling good i'm
serious it's round robin too so it's like and these are all
domination games as well yeah i mean we win it like if we're
top two we get a free buy okay those are my those are my
heroes in the chat okay let me look all right i'm back
welcome back we good guys yeah yeah yeah moxie's cooking
right now he's cooking us the perfect cop yeah this is crazy
i like the gambit loki i mean we could just ban spider-man
so he doesn't bully the back line well you guys are the back
line yeah that's me yeah you guys got it wait am i well am i
gonna be i don't think i i mean i will i can be but i'm
thinking i'm going to have another tank outside of tyler i
mean i could tank as well yes you can take as well but you
have to i think you have to play uh dps loki i think you're
our only actual yeah everyone everyone can do um i mean if
you do have to tank if you think you're like super super
good at certain ones i can also dps but you're definitely
better than me at dps bro raffle dude i've seen your your
rocket stats it's kind of insane isn't it zero zero i don't
know you got time on hours yeah i'm looking at it you got
time on rocket and you got some time on mantis some oh that
was yeah that was that was a long time ago that's okay it's
like riding a bicycle mantis i should not play but rocket
rocket i can definitely play like the one I'm least
consistent on definitely out of that list is Bucky but
everyone else there I'm like I I know how to play them kind
of thing yeah yeah I was like what the fuck was that yeah
also we're they're missing a player yeah Ruffle if you don't
mind me asking what game do you come from I call it call of
jury call of jury oh then it works oh he's gonna be an aamer
yeah but well call of jury zombies so I'm PVE he's not a
namer he's not Deadpool wait for him your main game is Call
of Duty zombies that pays the bills that pays the but it
does it does pay the bills I was what's the best which was
the best uh zombies game no we're no we're not going that my
chance was not screaming you don't have a you don't have a
thought what you think about a lot of zombies yeah there
have been like 20 at this point it's definitely best one
yeah what do you think the most time in black ops 3 okay
black ops 3 that's a that's a i think that's a standard yeah
we're now on black ops 7 so it's like they've played it out
a bit is the zombies in black ops 7 good uh it's all right
i've not played it yeah that's the same for most people to
be honest the game is sold really badly this year so
everyone stopped all right stopped watching right now okay
go down a little records no i'm not like a i i do the guides
up a little that's if you've ever done an easter egg in cod
zombies you've probably used my guide for it all right and
then uh moxie down a little same with waffle okay moxie yeah
i'm the guy from tutorials yeah all right let me know if
it's better i've definitely seen your name so i've probably
watched multiple videos like almost no realize it's better
cool yeah well i hope to live up to the name as oh you will
whatever reputation has preceded me uh click some heads yeah
absolutely if we i do think if we're trying i guess we
should probably work on what we want to play but i do think
if we're trying to play like gambit loki then i probably
will have to be on I'm also thinking about banning Loki.
This the Rob CD guy only plays it.
Oh, okay Then we could just wait, but is he good at is he
good at Loki though?
He's level eight.
Okay, so are you like it's the only character he knows like
he's probably gonna be even worse That's true.
I mean, that is true.
Yeah, that's wait, don't you play you play all support.
Yeah, I play all support Okay, also okay, perfect.
You know what last time I joined and I only played venom and
they banned it and we literally lost instantly after I think
banning noobs is OP.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember that.
It's like PTSD.
Sure, sure.
Lock it, lock the fucking lock.
Lock it in.
Wait, but Moxie has to figure out bans though.
He's on bans for us.
I don't even see it.
Oh yeah, who is it?
Oh, it's me.
Okay, okay.
That's good.
See him, baby.
Okay.
What if they target ban you, Tyler?
They could.
But he's got a group.
He's got a group too.
I don't think that's how it works.
Wait.
We can ban.
Wait wait, I hope he don't ban me.
Wait, wait, we can protect Venom.
Yeah, we can protect them.
Yeah, yeah.
He said he can play you, how good are you at GRUT, Tyler?
GRUT's about the same.
The same skill.
Because GRUT's like a top tank, and he's like the best.
Okay, well, I like Venom.
Yeah, you play Venom, God damn it.
Oh, the lucky Ben.
We just absolutely banned their noob.
Oh, yeah, we did.
We did ban Hawkeye.
We should say for you, right?
Yeah, Venom.
Yeah, whatever you want to play.
We're safe.
Yeah, we're safe.
I'm not.
We're not getting a repeat.
You're right.
And they've been in the Hawkeye, so that kind of sinks.
I'm sorry, we have mags.
Like we can just mag, play mag.
They're going to protect it like crazy, though.
They're going to tell her to like come back.
What's your second bad, Moxie?
I don't know.
I'm thinking who like Hawkeye is.
Spider-Man.
I don't think he's going to play Spider-Man.
He's not?
I mean, he probably is going to play Deadpool.
Yeah, he's probably going to play Deadpool or DPS Deadpool
or like...
Daredevil.
It's up to you.
Or Deadpool.
I don't care.
Oh, shit.
Whatever.
No, that's something.
It's more than nothing.
And then we bang Tank Deadpool.
Thing is, I could play Spider-Man, too.
Kind of.
Yeah, senior Spider-Man.
Oh, we did just bang Tank Deadpool.
Yeah, I mean, I see he plays Tank Deadpool.
Okay.
why are you protecting oh protect your own dps whoever you
want to play shit yep okay that's good i think this can peel
i can definitely peel yeah huh
i mean we want a kid um i don't know what they play that's
the biggest problem like bogey i mean should we ban strange
is that crazy he's like probably gonna be really good right
now yeah but he's like isn't he like uh like he loves
strange and strange has got a huge buff it's on i don't know
if he's like been playing them or not but i feel like he'd
be the type of person that's like dr strange is back and
like a hundred youtube videos and is like he's gonna do
he'll do a portal though and i hate dealing with that
against like uh but we ban strange we don't get strange or
daredevil oh daredevil actually he's not that strong though
it's just been rob birru strange but i we're yeah maybe i
should have been strange too we got buffed okay that's what
i'm feeling like he's gonna be like the strange we have
gambit uh we can do gambit in this okay ruffle waffle yep
shall i i could no more or moon knight for the alt synergy
oh i like a moon knight i like a crazy like really crazy
okay uh do you they saved i could do mag i'm gonna fuck up
their healers i was gonna say the only thing we have to
worry about is the cloak up the then yeah because we don't
have a mag to count into cloak up okay dude i can do mag uh
guys i'm gonna be pure disruptive i love that you do that
did uh did group get a nerf or anything no what are your
guys just paying okay uh like a hundred something i'm pretty
sure i mean we're on we're on eu shit on eu doesn't matter
on this game or not sort of game one baby showtime this is
what we get paid the big bucks Moxie, if you hook their
cloak out of old at the end of something, I'll try to focus
over there.
By the way, those who don't know what Gambit ult does, when
Doki has an ult...
We don't heal, though, anymore.
Oh, listen, we run.
Oh, we don't.
We don't understand.
I don't...
I think they got rid of self-heal, right?
Yeah, but like everyone...
Everyone stand in front of...
Shako!
Moxie, it's up to you!
You're in front when we're doing it.
Oh, God.
It's Doki Shako helped do it.
Well, okay, okay.
Where are we going?
Okay, we're going to point.
We're going to point.
For me, I'll...
They use the portal.
No, Ty, look out.
Over here.
Come main.
They portal.
They portal on.
They're going to portal on.
They're going forward.
Yeah.
I'm going for the healers.
Go, Tyler.
I'm going.
Uh, Stringer's anti.
They've deadpool or not?
Yeah, deadpool.
Heels back here.
Oh, no.
Luna, Luna one.
Luna one HP.
On the left.
Back left.
What?
Heels.
Oh.
You know what I'm doing a lot of damage to the backline.
Oh, that's unlucky.
The backline's low!
They're low?
Yeah, they are.
Swing to our backline, to our backline, they can heal you.
Yeah.
Back sitting me, please.
Oh, we almost got Epic Wheels Invisal.
We almost have Invisal.
Go back in.
We have Invisal.
We have Invisal next.
Oh, no.
Epic.
Playing it, playing it, guys.
Playing it, playing it.
I can't do anything here.
Oh, I think they one shot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have combo, we have combo.
Yeah, we combo and I'm going to swap.
So when they cloak up, just mirror it and mirror it on
point.
Yeah.
Hello, FBS.
I'm going to, it's going to be, it might be kind of hard to
hit this ult.
They have two shield things, but I'm going to throw it.
You hit your ult and I'm swapping mag after for their
punish.
I can, I can alt this too.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I'm holding their back line.
Run in, run in, run in.
Run in, run in.
That's huge.
I am ready to put on a Ice they loon, right?
They use loon often.
Yeah.
You're gonna have Punisher Ult, as well, so we have to do...
Right.
Yeah.
maybe is it map gonna move in a second yeah and I'm gonna
move in 22 seconds too I have a careful map's gonna move
here yeah you can kind of use the walk back walk back walk
back here yeah watch out it's coming you just dead called
the earth not that well you you venom all them whatever well
Tyler Tyler come back to point do they have strength no they
don't have strength no no but we don't have lots for that I
can't get to you, Moxie.
I'm dead on the right, yeah, yeah.
That's why we have to die on point.
And now we have individual assault next.
Regroup, regroup.
I'm trying to die, they're not really killing me.
Oh, it's very equal.
I mean, I could stay Groot and just play for another combo.
I'm at 60%.
Yeah, yeah, the combo is good.
They don't have a counter for it.
Like, nothing.
Yeah, they're Punisher.
Yeah, yeah.
i'll try playing next to you marks you oh i'm far more we
already you're gonna have strange yeah you can go over here
yeah i'm gonna try to griddle them earlier like before they
change all can we break that turn maybe yeah turn turn slow
oh they use the lot they use the lot just reset reset reset
they use three oh this is gonna be a last fight look that
pool strange yeah uh i'm they use yeah these oh i think i i
need to die Okay, it's fine.
Wait for me, wait for me, wait for me.
I'm respawning.
Yeah, you're just gonna have to push away.
I'll just get there as fast as I can.
They're okay, we can go.
We need a gambit on here too.
You can hold whenever you see Fade, just try to use your arm
with it at the same time.
I have all here.
I'm ulted.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Punisher, Punisher.
I'm with you, Ty.
I'm with you.
Kill.
.
Thanks, guys, nice, nice.
Then pull on the judiciary.
I'm trying to get you.
I'll do my absolute best to live here.
Nice, huge.
Luna, fly, land, land, land, creative.
She's one.
That end.
Nice, nice.
Just close.
We don't need an alts.
No, bubble.
We can, turrets.
Strange.
Nice, nice.
We can maybe kill that.
I need.
Let me farm it, let me farm.
Let me farm.
Yeah.
Let Doki go.
Let Doki.
Come back.
Tyler.
Oh, no.
I'll try.
Farmer here as much as you can.
Just shoot down the clock plane and do everything.
Because if you get it, we just win.
Let me farm the, let me farm my ult here.
Yeah, try not to heal too much unless we're going to die,
Epoch.
Back up.
We're okay.
Just keep getting your ult, Rob, when we win.
If you get it.
Yeah.
Use your ult.
I don't marry your ult of another support ult or use it
defensively.
Yeah.
Whatever you get it, just let me know.
I know you're close.
Does that make sense?
I can't.
Oh Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa Use it, use it, use it, use it,
use it Oh, that's a What happened?
I quoted, we have to use the invis If you hear the sound
cue, you just use it It's fine, it's fine We have to, can we
portal?
Oh, they're counter portaling Yeah, never mind, never mind
Nice team, Moxie, nice try Nice try, I try, what?
Nice team, Moxie?
Okay, it's fine.
Yeah, this is okay.
So like when you hear the sound cue, just throw the
invisible out there.
The Deadpool sound cue?
No, the, no, not the Deadpool, just strange.
Cause he had, uh, we had time to throw it.
I know that one's tough too.
That one's like the toughest one of the harder ones to do.
Or just push it.
Just have a push up.
Uh, you want to play?
We could do Groot Mag.
It's like, like, do you feel like you're doing better on
Venom or what?
I think I think.
I just want to win.
Yeah, it's up to you.
Yeah, I think get Tyler on group.
Get Tyler on group.
Yeah, they're going to have a better champ.
Go mag and then just counter the cloak with mag out.
Yeah, I can.
Do you rather that or I should do that over Punisher,
honestly?
Yeah, swap group.
I'll go first.
And then we'll just try one first fight.
He's, what's his name?
Hard to deal with back there?
Like the, uh, whatever.
I don't think I should just go.
I might just go storm.
Who is?
I don't know.
Um, thanks.
Okay, so here's my walls.
Alright, I'm gonna, I'm gonna alt early, okay?
We're gonna go all the way down below.
Basically your shift makes it so you do damage.
Three, three, two, one.
Watch out on the left.
Watch out, go, go, go.
Oh, I'm dead, I'm dead.
Oh, well.
Of course they have an Angela that's so annoying.
I'm trying to help you.
I'm trying to heal you, Moxie.
Oh, he's off the map.
He's off the map.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
way too far boxing you're gonna walk up they didn't get to
pull it oh they can't now they did they didn't uh for
something probably for punish i think maybe oh can we go
we're good all right we use invis for defense here the yo
epic you know your pull like ability oh my god bro oh you
have to push you need to push them when angela it's so it's
so tough yeah whenever whenever angela grabs just save your
pull for that only the entire game and just pull or push uh
angela off every time I know it's hard I clean it but it is
like one of the counters and it's such a ridiculously far
full but all groups yeah I vote for the cloak we're not
fully six by the way so careful yeah I'm waiting back in the
second I have all the top help our help our black line going
in we're backland itself we're backland I'm here I'm here I
have a lot again I mean can we kill the Andrew in the
backline and then I think we full reset we're literally just
we're dying one by one final fight oh
no No.
Yeah, we have to full reset here.
Just wait.
And then I can ult this.
We're going to get him.
Aval.
Ival.
All right.
We can go up.
Walk up.
Walk up now.
Let's go.
Yeah.
All right.
Three, two, one.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
Counter this if you can.
Punish it, Dad.
There's no way I can.
Find the cloak.
We can have a ammo.
Nice.
They're down two.
Yeah, yeah.
We win this.
We should win this.
Careful of a punter.
Careful of Angela.
Yeah, yeah.
Save the push for Angela.
Okay.
We got cloak.
Angela, focus on Angela.
Angela one.
Got her.
All right.
Nice.
Did you tap it?
Yeah, we did.
Yeah.
So save your, just make sure you save your pull and push for
Angela.
Just don't push anything else.
I got someone's on.
You can.
I'm going on dead.
okay probably you can play like a weird angle and try to
honk and just like deal with supports like earlier okay
they're going top they're going top careful tyler i missed
it my i'm coming over to you guys i hear angela yeah angel
gun yeah i just want to grab me i'm playing like he's on
point angela's on point i'm just looking for a pull of
you're you're so far yeah that's so unfortunate
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
Look at that Chris.
That was dead.
I bowed my stomach.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Angelo, Angelo, one.
Angelo, one.
Oh, he's still low.
It's fine.
Bro, I'm disrupting the fuck out of their back one.
No, no, no, you're not.
No, you're not.
Yeah, close.
Yeah, close, close.
That's the same point.
Oh, I'm probably dead.
I'm dead.
I'm trying to help you, Moxy, but you're so far up.
Oh, yeah.
I'm gonna see you.
more play i'm back i'm back i i'm gonna dive one here yeah
we have tp we have tp yeah i can tp i can all of them you
guys you can just chill you can just chill they're capping
they're coming you are saying yeah we have to touch keep
fighting until we have a winner i feel it oh yeah hold on my
go first care nice we have all here
come on i got a pleasure no we see nine oh i got grabbed and
kicked off my man which five low key that's the most fucked
ass map for them they have all good for them bro could it
swing I got ace though you did get ace
yeah everything could be caught to the lava yeah that's the
only like map in the game they can like run this cheesy ass
shit I think if they run Angela I can I can play in this for
us because i'm more used i'm i'm i'm more like muscle change
very pushes yeah it's all right it's just round robin so
it's like damage dokey you kidding me what okay look i was
healing are you kidding me i was 23k healing though epic bro
are you kidding me yeah four final hits yeah tyler did more
damage than you dokey um i have four final hits final hits
than tyler guys honestly i feel like low key we're getting
the groove i think we're disrupting figuring it out a quick
warm-up game bro that was tough yeah the whole thing is so
huge and it's just so tough uh yeah you're not like used to
it like she just gets she just i mean dude i was pulled off
the map three different times from as far right as i could
possibly be on like the against the wall basically and we're
just trying to figure out our comps right now anyway Yeah,
100%.
We could try triple support.
Like, what do we plan next?
We just do round robin against all the teams.
So we play four more best of ones against everyone.
But honestly, like, I mean, it doesn't really matter how we
do.
I feel like we are on paper one of the stronger teams.
So like we could win like even with a- It doesn't matter how
we do.
Well, I'm saying even if we do bad, even if we do bad, which
I don't think we will in the rest of the game.
So what does it matter if we win or lose these games?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
we do underdog you know it's an underdog run yeah guys i
don't know the format of this i don't it's it's gonna be
like our record at the end of the five games that we play is
how you how they seed us so if we have a good record we
basically guarantee play a team that like did really bad
like if we were to get top two we'd play against five or six
probably and then if we were to knock them out we'd
guarantee get top three four so we automatically make 20
grand instead of 10.
gotcha i think that's how that works check check after we
win it all does anybody want to play rock paper scissors for
their split hmm rock paper scissors for their split yep okay
i'm gonna adjust oh i am way too broke to be gambling like
that g all right um i up well a bit um i okay i brought
moxie down a little bit it's tough though because oh oh wait
they whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait they add on ping to us by
the way yeah i see that i don't know what that means that
means they have people with 150 ping or 140 ping and they're
like you know what it's unfair they're too low ping we have
to add on lag to them wow this is a dallas server bro that's
actually messed up i'd be flying bro you would be flying bro
i play on like nine ping or less every game what the does
anyone does anyone think that's crazy artificial ping that
is i mean i think we put in a formal complaint i think we uh
balance latency that's i think of the majority necros is a
billionaire and he i think if the majority is na they should
tank it i'm with you i'm with you they should tank it why
give equality to them i'm saying he's a billionaire he could
he could literally put a house in in texas and just move for
this turn i did not realize official thing that's crazy yeah
that's what i just figured out right now where are we
playing next that's what it was either because then we can
figure out bands really screw i don't know who we're playing
next is that anywhere usually there's like a there's like a
sheet like a bingo board almost looking thing think xqc next
where do you see that well uh we band grew if you go general
and then scroll up a little what man tyler you ever played
thing oh i see no i tried it last time he's Oh, I was in
their backline on the healers.
No, no, you did good.
I'm just saying.
Thing would be good.
Theoretically into that comp.
It would have just been good.
We got solid healers, so you're going to get healed.
Tell me one bit wrong, guys.
Be honest.
I'll be honest.
I legit think we win if it's any other map.
Hellshaven is the one thing that has all those pits and
shit, which they play those characters that are cheesy.
I'm having a good Angela.
messing up so bad no it was the strange alts too like we
that too yeah we had just had to push to strange or have a
defensive off for the strange yeah i understand strange now
i'll be bad i'm ready i'm ready for the old system let's go
that's true you're locked he's locked in because like it was
literally we lost if you guys want me to hold because i
already have like 10 hours on this game just yeah yeah i'll
try to use it myself yeah the worst thing is that it's just
so fast like things come so like the strange old you have
like one second to react yeah that's like my bad because
like i think you were cooking epic i'm not gonna lie yeah i
think you're fine there's like no you're seriously fine just
like if if i guess like when they engage if they engage with
the defensive alt just mirror alt it or if they use like an
offensive alt just i'll just rip it honestly send it i'll
just send it yeah yeah even if you feel threatened just just
all as well just yeah like we'll tell you before like the
dps characters you should like watch out for specifically to
all four so if you hear their voice line just go but see i
don't really know the voice lines like i can kind of figure
it out but like i don't really know the voice lines like
that no i got you have you ever played gambit or no no okay
um wait why are supports do you play i have loki hella
Invis.
Oh, not Loki.
Not Loki.
Just Invis.
Okay.
Bro, that's a good three.
I'm not gonna lie.
That's a really good three.
That's a core three.
I think you'd be really, really good at Luna.
You're an aimer.
Like, I could do Luna.
I think you'd be fine with him on Luna.
Yeah.
Because the alts for her is more reflex too.
Yeah, yeah.
So that you don't have to like place it anywhere.
Yeah.
Well, you really got no time.
You actually only have time on those three.
Yes, literally.
That's a good three.
That's a really solid three.
I have, like, friends who are, like, good.
And I told them, I was like, bro, I got two days.
I lowered Moxie a little bit again.
So, like, they just gave me those.
Moxie, figure out the bans for XQC's team.
Okay.
All right.
Who did they play last?
Let's see who they played last match.
I'll try to pull it up as well.
All right.
They have XQC, Aimbot, Calvin, Warren, Sweden.
I know like it plays a mean rocket I mean could just ban
rocket I don't know if she still does or not she played that
in the last journey I feel like she would just play rocket
if that's like her comfort pick I think she plays Emma and
Squirrel Girl like she has time on this game so hmm but but
did they put on support that's the thing for her last game
that is that is true if they put on support then she'll just
be playing rocket and then we can just ban Rocket.
I can watch their game right now.
That's what I'm doing.
I need him to pull the scoreboard up real quick.
Let me see their bans.
Oh, I see.
They played solo tank triple support.
We might have to play triple.
Or not, sorry.
Who's iPhone 8 user?
I don't know.
That's Calvin.
Inbound Calvin.
Because he was on Deadpool.
they had they had yeah he was solo tanking strange like xuc
solo tank strange and then they played rocket like gambit we
could ban both we just ban both of their supports because i
know amali is most comfortable on cloak so we ban cloak and
rocket that leaves if they're running triple support that
gives them less support less supports to uh to play around
with true who is um who's aspen is that dude is that person
of support is it okay yeah yeah yeah So if we just ban
Rocket, I mean, we could literally just do a full support
ban line, too, honestly.
I'd be down for that, because I think those are the
strongest players.
Because if they're going to abuse support, then we just ban
the strongest support.
So we ban Cloak, Rocket.
I mean, they're running Mantis.
Mantis is fucking strong with Triple.
I just see, I don't know, I see Warn's playing Lord Squirrel
Girl.
Yeah, I'm looking at that as well.
It's a little freaky.
That's why I said who is that?
Are you scared of Squirrel Girl, Moxie?
No, but it's like...
Lord, I don't know.
If Aspen is, I don't know, is Aspen support main?
Because then they'll have more like pool depth, like hero
pool.
So it might not be worth just trying to ban out.
Because what I feel like that would be doing is it would be
banning for their worst player.
Right?
Like their least experienced player.
For triple support, Mantis is very strong in triple support.
Because of the damage boost.
And she can just damage boost the Squirrel Grill.
which would be even did they do that yeah mantis does damage
boost and uh and they can just damage boost their dps player
which is what makes them her super and he uh mantis controls
the temple of the game because her all basically is like a
speed boost and speed boost plus heals gotcha i didn't even
see that they play oh so he did play mantis okay so are we
banning for him or we and just kind of or are we banning for
the worst the two other ones that are like um we're allowed
to do let us do three support ban i would pick first uh
rocket then mantis and then cloak okay because i don't think
we have to have a uh i guess we could do yeah we could do
the same thing then because i personally don't think they'll
protect mantis but that's just in my i don't think might
actually protect mantis because mantis is very strong this
one guy looks like he's only playing squirrel girl you want
to ban squirrel girl i want to ban cloak in rocket and
squirrel girl that's how i don't know but i'm down ban in
mantis as well i mean we could substitute we could
substitute the cloak with mantis because i rather ban mantis
than um because because then we have to mirror mantis i play
if we ban mantis or a decent mantis i should say if we ban
mantis immediately does that instantly signal to them that
we're buying the like we're doing support bands no no it
would probably just signal to them that we watched they also
well the enemy the enemy team also banned grout and hella
versus them xuc plays grew right yeah yeah he plays other
takes too he plays grout and strange okay i think moxie what
are you first banning are you banning first banning rocket
or squirrel girl because they might did they protect
squirrel girl i feel like it depends on the map like some of
shit for squirrel girl but like the day the day protects
squirrel yeah they protected squirrel girl so we'll just
that was an intentional thing we'll first ban squirrel girl
then is that worn person like uh like do they play the game
like a lot or they just scroll girl man i don't think so
they're an overwatch player overwatch player okay who just
ripped squirrel girl love it just for rivals just for rivals
yeah i mean that could be worth banning that if that's like
their their thing my chat is saying that warn is an he is
okay but the thing is he if he spent most of his time on
squirrel girl then like it's just we're just like capping
him yeah yeah it doesn't really matter okay apparently he he
like mains sniper and overwatch it's okay widow maker isn't
different game yeah i mean you could try widow in this but
we're playing different from widow here yo tyler i don't
like the quietness bro what's happening over there and he
and he comes i'll get my mind right i was saying To my guys,
I am the Hoorah guy.
I'm the Hoorah guy.
Wait, give us a Hoorah.
Hoorah starts right before the game.
Not now.
But what if we need motivation now?
Because we lost our first game.
We need you to motivate us.
It is what it is.
You guys need to speak up.
There's nobody shot calling.
There's no one like headless chicken.
Moxie, why aren't you shot calling?
I didn't know what to do.
I'm a nude.
You got to tell me what to do, by the way.
Doki, you see the whole fight from the back.
I'm like trying to shoot my gun.
but you're shoot your gun so you know who's low right right
yeah so you should be tar i'll do shot you do target guys
okay yes okay yeah so you get target color i need you to
step up as well guys we three play this game i was commonly
crazy but i can only kill i'm like guys their luna's one hp
and tyler's like guys their luna is one hp and i killed her
yeah yeah wait are you blaming tyler for doing his job
that's why yeah yeah it was dude their punisher set up the
funniest turrets he'd just be in the middle of like in their
spawn shooting me well he did their punishment had like 20
accuracy so i'm like i kind of felt like the loki ban was
good well we we're protecting tyler right we're just
protecting venom oh do we think they ban his i mean they
might yes no they will this team specifically probably will
ban his because i think moxie remembers because you we were
against you and then you target ben tyler's venom yeah yeah
so he will do it again you know have you uh you haven't
played thing Tyler ever no I played thing no we do not you i
mean our best protect each game needs to be venom just for
the safety for him to guarantee play it but worse comes to
worse tyler can always hit a rocket yeah yeah yeah what's
you can you hit the thing then all right so you're you're an
aimer it's so bad about venom what do i do what do i do
nothing's wrong with the fact that they're gonna ban you i
can't no as long as we oh we did my first bad thing my first
bad him you're right yeah okay we just got protect it's fine
just got protect guys do we ban actually sees grute though
um he'll just play strange then oh and then i would have to
play a hulk or thing okay now we'll get what you're saying
okay wait you want to you want to ban grute i can play emma
if we bang grute or something and just bully their bully x
if he's a solo tank like loki i think if i'm on hawkeye can
cook yeah yeah yeah yeah like i believe they either banned
hawkeye or or venom if they first banned venom if they first
banned venom we protect hawkeye okay okay yeah yeah yeah
because they have to either target you moxie or or tyler so
we have like a plan i feel like you were cooking on the moon
night raffle yeah you were cooking on the moon night i feel
like that just damage is good he's strong right now so one
one thing it all of these round robin games going to be
domination so i could also name more just for squids on
point because he got buffed this patch as well right he did
get buffed right like he's stronger i'll be i'll be honest
name more is pretty mid of a character but like the thing is
he's mid but he doesn't require me to to aim the squid's aim
for me so like there is a there is an inherent buff on auto
aiming squids but i can do either that's fine that's all
good i feel like the damage output in this type of tourney
with a lot of people who don't play the game on moon knight
could just be overwhelming for people especially in
domination where you're just like shooting in a straight
line through their whole team fair fair fair plus your old
obviously like if you throw your old on someone who doesn't
play this game that much they're gonna die every time yeah i
guess the the moon knight is gonna just have everyone like
more generally weaker i guess when playing it at least so if
that means that you can then just get like one hit headshots
because they're already squishy then yeah if you're like if
you're like playing front line and then you occasionally
like take a off angle and just throw an onk behind their
support's feet you'll probably just kill them every time
especially if you know who you're we should like tell we
should look at who their supports are and tell you give you
a name like go for this person honestly if you ping them
like one time i'll just tunnel them the rest of the game i
mean i'll i'll just say it when we see their comp i'll try
to give you a name yeah that sounds good we can run triple
support true yes that is the trump card if we if we do run
triple sub am i the one that's flexing to support or is that
someone else probably think it would be you probably yeah
okay okay okay just bear in mind i can only rocket luna
that's fine that's that's fine support is triple support
doesn't matter what support you play okay okay cool it's
just mantis is the strong like one Let's go!
Let's go!
Oh, wait.
Their double is good.
I'm not...
Oh, yeah, I could.
Okay.
I can play thing, guys.
If their comp's, if their comp's like really bad for it, I
think we should.
Like last game could have been really good.
But we didn't even think of it.
Oh, okay.
Then we can protect Venom.
Yeah.
Okay.
Ben Cloak.
Not...
Oh, okay, sure.
Cloak or crap.
Uh...
It wasn't not...
It wasn't not Squirrel Girl.
Remember, they protected Squirrel Girl.
Squirrel Girl.
do do that squirrel girl yeah because they protected
squirrel girl okay we could do we could do support bands
after this though i think yeah yeah so and then protect
venom okay which heroes will get my cosmic favor today
because if we're not playing mag then minus just ban cloak
we're protecting venom right yeah yep yep venom x's whole
chat spam and ban hawk eye a bunch of snitches bro it's
because he plays with moxie all the time so he knows that's
weird it's weird yeah not cool i thought we're boys i
thought he gets friends he actually doesn't want you to win
this money oh they're actually so stunlocked look how long
you're taking them look at them oh yeah oh they're like what
do we do okay group protected wait this is great for you
though on moon yeah but i could also play wolverine yeah
either cloak or rocket or mantis you can pick one those
three um and we're not playing bad double and i could
probably go i could probably ban cloak yeah we're probably
not gonna play mag because i'll probably be on yeah so then
we have to ban cloak then and then after that we bad we can
ban mantis no way they're this is weird they're actually
banning you maxi oh i think at this point you protect
whatever the you want yeah what do we what do we want to
play specifically anything for us i think we i mean i think
loki we're good with loki too is wolverine or punish or
punisher for the yeah next he's not gonna be happy about
wolverine no i absolutely love that out of you i'm serious
and then either rocket or mantis i think anita only plays
rocket so you can just do a rocket been but we have to be
aware of the mantis damage boost probably you know about
like the group big wall right me is his his big wall like he
has like the small walls but his big red wall puts him in a
circle and he can't be grabbed by wolverine so like wow they
didn't ban anything so like if you see that big like dark
larger wall you have to break it so then moxy can grab him
yeah okay and you're like the only damn yeah i mean you're
like our only damage so i'll be breaking it too the walls
the majority of the time okay we should be good say and
again the big one specifically because then do we want me on
something i could i could switch to like punish or something
then and just mow walls down the whole time uh you could my
rush is pretty good i i like the moon night too because if
we're gonna be playing root moon night yeah you can combo
with me and you agree okay uh you can play which one which
one can you play in visray or a luna um you can do a I feel
like we should do low keys.
I would go low keys.
Invis low keys.
Yeah.
Invis.
I think you're going to evolve throughout this turn.
You're a fast learner, I believe.
Like this Invis, if we got something, yeah, if they have,
you hit the ults, if you give, if we give you something to
pull and you pull it, this is us.
All right, guys.
I am disrupting their healers.
We need somebody to shot, call, and lead.
Please.
We need some organization.
Marksy, your target battle.
How are you calling?
Jump back.
Give me, someone go rock it.
We bad rocket.
You bad rocket.
Oh, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's like, what do you mean?
If the walls are a problem, let me know and I'll switch to
Punisher because I feel like Moonite has very good wall
break.
Moonite's really good again.
He might actually have more wall break than Punisher like
statistically in this game.
Like if you just focus his walls and like if you see that
big wall focus it, Moxie will get free kills.
Look up guys.
Look up.
I'm looking up.
Oh, there you are.
What the?
I'm here.
Beautiful.
Hey, you see me?
Yeah.
like a lovely star you might get banned watch out lock in
team let's go yeah yeah wolverines already across the
universe but trust me that could change the heartbeat okay
they're on mantis name or hella oh name or hella oh they're
going out how brave is yeah yeah okay okay support you gotta
walk through and walk through it i'm not like the way i mean
yeah i need heels up Yeah, guys.
Maybe we drop down maybe we drop down.
Hey, I know one on the left side Kat.
Hi there.
Drew dropped Yeah, I dropped as well.
Anyone willing to help?
I rolled up three.
I watched them with a few more kills.
Yeah, Come here.
bye!
We're healing.
Oh my god, I'm so worried.
I have a nice, nice, nice, nice.
push up, push up, push up, push up.
You have kills.
push up just push up oh my there is a name or up top name or
up top got out let's go nice we'll play uh good i'm about to
i'm about to brutal yo uh ruffle come to make it come to me
up here and just farm down this lane and we just root moon
night early potentially yeah you can get caught here up here
yeah yeah i'm up here don't don't like heartbeat just shoot
down that lane and get your ult and tell me when you have it
i'll i'm gonna go with them okay i'll try i'm so many I
think you'll get it super fast here.
What up?
I'm what up!
I have inv- I have- Out of it, I've already.
Nice, nice, nice.
Do you have it?
No, no, no, no.
Nellie, Nellie.
Where's my invo- Oh, I got eaten.
Here's like- Oh, I got- Fighting- if I can.
I felt- come down, come down, come down.
They're groups down on me.
Good heals.
Really good heals.
You have to use your all-if-if-if you keep doing this fight,
so use your-if-if.
Use it here, use it, use it!
Use it!
Oh, this is here.
Good ol' good ol'51.
Good job!
Look at their invid's.
Look at their invid's in the back.
Invid's in Memphis.
I'm back, I'm back!
I'm softening off the wolverines.
If you wanna come down, I have In sentence bomb here.
Hey, Burn-Hella, Burn-Hella.
Shoot it.
I don't know if we're gonna be able to.
We can keep going with this fight if we have to.
Oh, just down point.
Just down point, just down point.
Yeah.
Just down point.
I have many faces.
that's right we have we can do a combo soon okay we're
resetting oh my god he just solved for like eight more
seconds that's crazy i have all uh did they have hello name
right beautiful love that they might get screwed all again
uh yeah they're probably gonna have it a little bit before
me i can get my old pretty quick if you want to save for me
raffle yeah just save your own just give me like yell when
you want me to use that i'll go left i will all right i'm
ready they're gonna probably pull me off here i'm trying to
wait for this to open up
I'm on the left.
I walled them off the top.
Walled them off the top.
We can name one.
They'll bubble.
It's fine.
I'm fine.
Supports are fine.
I just don't have Invol in here.
I'm just chill.
Just chill.
Just wait.
It's even by the way.
It's even.
Wait out.
I'm gonna kill their hella from spawn again.
I'm gonna kill their hella.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're ready.
It's fine, it's fine.
We just died the first time as an adult.
Yeah.
I think we're even.
We're even right now.
I'm with you.
Yep.
Group, group, group, group.
I have Neymar on me.
Neymar on me.
Neymar one.
That's a kill.
Nice.
It's beautiful, bro.
I will here.
Nice.
We'll play it.
So do this to come up here.
I know you were struggling to come up.
Click it, hit it.
Hit it, hit it.
Can we all come up?
Yeah, what do you do?
Keep it up top, yeah.
It's up top.
Your power is up top.
I ult it.
Ult it point, ult it point.
Okay, focus in.
These guys under their side, under their side.
Thank you, thank you.
I want off, water off, mantis, mantis, mantis.
He's like, oh!
I'm walling off the mantis again.
I'm on her, I'm on her.
Killer, killer, killer, killer.
I'm in ball here.
Mantis, one HP.
Mantis one HP.
That did.
They just got me the two.
Oh my god, I'm in the, I'm in the grill.
I mean, Jeff up.
Yeah, me too.
You have to resume this one.
Invis one on the right.
I'm calling it out.
Oh, you got that.
Jeff low, Jeff low, Jeff low.
Jeff low, Jeff and Bucky low.
We're all one.
Whoa!
Beautiful.
How far in this?
I don't know.
It's like reset, reset, reset, reset, reset.
Yeah, we have combo.
What are we wanting?
A bot, Calvin.
And you destroyed them.
We don't have support ults, but they have...
They might have support ults, though.
They used mid.
They might have invis.
Did they use invis, didn't they?
Strange on the left, he could have ults.
They used invis when I used invis.
I have a lot coming up soon.
I didn't get a chance to farm mine a lot.
Well, me on the side, on the side.
I will try and get something.
Got you, we got you.
Farmer, Rafa, we flew in.
Going in!
Oh, never mind.
Watch out.
Strange ults!
I can't.
I got you.
That's fine.
It's fine.
We have old, right?
We have 97%.
Yeah, we are.
I'm about to.
99.
Yeah, yeah, let's go.
Go, go, go.
Get the rip.
Oh, I can't see.
I'm just hitting it.
Oh, I got killed as I was trying to use it.
I'm coming.
I'm TP back.
I'm clear.
We have a TP.
I can't make it.
What do you mean?
It's just I died.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I think you just rip it.
it yeah if i smile you have to assault them because it'll
kill them no matter what pretty much yeah they had a i think
they they invisible if ralph is like close to his alt just
rip your grudel because then he can just build it in the
grudel yeah and he doesn't because he's like is it like five
seconds i thought i even did it a little early too like
because i thought that when you were like what 90s your
timing was good i was i was just i wasn't quite ready but
like that was mental debuff on my part i'll i'll be better
next time you're good you're good Do you want me to like
initiate with all her like just like alt and I can hope to
Yeah, yeah, yeah just alter into yeah.
Okay, because literally throw it on the most supports You
can or put a support in the middle and then just on then
basically and you So I'll try and like just hit that back
line as much as possible Yeah, take like a side take like an
early side angle Maybe and just try to like like maybe go
far right here and just don't let me see you When you hold
up your far left here should throw your onk after and they
get yes you got it i think you're gonna just aim for one of
the supports call who you're aiming for and we'll just try
to focus on yeah
it's all trains watching
i'm doing it on jeff i'm doing it on jeff behind the wall
yeah hey this is in it man oh wait they have got a pick got
a pick got a pick Jeff can die.
Jeff can die.
Good old.
Huge old.
She's super low.
Straight in the air.
Yeah, we're to your left.
Moon Knight.
To your left, he's the one.
I don't see him.
It's fine.
We got point.
How many Moxie kill that?
I have my ult.
I might have to swap off Loki because they're on Bucky.
So let's swap.
Yeah.
All right.
Try to build your Moon Knight over again.
Wait, we can just combo Moxie.
Yeah, yeah.
Just combo.
Like I should be able to get a good, uh...
I think I'm meant to slow probably.
We do.
Oh yeah, we won't go through that.
We can, uh...
Can you win a vault soon?
I'm ready, I'm ready.
Guys, get ready, push up.
Yeah, okay, no man, no man.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, on top.
Nice, nice, good old.
Oh, chill, chill, another combo.
I got hit, I got hit, I got hit.
I got hit, I got hit.
I'm ready, I'm ready.
After.
I got so low, too.
We're just going to open that way.
We got to move you.
Go, go, go.
That's right.
Ultimates and Jeff.
How'd it taste?
Invis, invis, invis, invis, invis.
Right next to you, right next to you.
Bucky low, bucky low, buck, buck, buck, buck.
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on, I'm on.
Nice, nice, nice.
They're gonna up.
They're gonna up Bucky up.
i have many faces let's stop that walk up if we can yep i'm
going just for a little bit i am true yeah you i think you
just do that early old again and i'll just keep combo with
my they're tipping oh oh what oh someone disconnected yeah
they're installing axe they're terrified they're killing
that momentum bro yeah i just checked and icing is like a
three game ban what is this okay he's ready look in get
ready get ready yeah okay um you could restart in a sec yeah
hit that hit that side angle whenever you build ult and just
do 18 i'm 85 percent yeah yeah you got it same exact thing
can you we just rip up rip it earlier oh absolutely i'm not
close to old i think you just the second you get it look
just remember don't see you and yeah or all the jeff also
you could also eat the jeff old that could also be good
would you guys rather him do that um i'm less likely to be
able to see that just because okay just just go with your
heart then don't you don't know yeah if they jeff old before
you do it they're gonna portal they're They're portaling,
they're portaling.
Watch out for a strange old.
They're going to strangle portal.
They're going to portal strangle.
Hey, no button.
Yeah, buckle up.
Kill strange.
I got you.
Jefflow, Jefflow.
Okay, jump in the air.
I've got a killer.
Neymar's coming to you.
Beautiful.
Neymar one.
Oh!
Let's go.
All right.
That's round.
those guys one more wait that mood that moon at all was
elite yeah that's good yeah sorry that was all you guys they
still have jeff halt right uh yeah i think so they have jeff
halt strange dog and lucky uh let's go they actually have
all their points if you wish your ults were really good the
invis ults are ever over really solid like save me a few
times yeah those were really good i'm working on they're
good i like it's better in this type of turny bro to just do
it early and like off something you think you might need to
hold for then to hold it and just everyone dies fair enough
so they've been super solid uh we can get moxie and i again
the combo yeah they're gonna they have all they're all we
can here i thought the second world war was a nightmare i'm
not gonna make any clones just because the bucky might
initiate with his ult so i'm just gonna yeah how do we how
do we want to play sing is that probably just gonna pop
everything right away like should we up and we have a copy
yeah and then we'll see how it goes if you build old fast
rob play play front line this time and just build all as
fast as you can okay if you get it before i get my old
somehow which you might on moon knight like we can just he's
probably there's only have one tank so it might be yeah true
i'll try my i'm trying to go in i'm trying to break shield
uh break shield yeah tyler's diving in are they also
invisible i mean i can't no more on the side on my body
Kappa Naeemal is on the rock.
In is, in is, in is.
Nice, nice, nice.
Naeemal's on the rock still.
Use my shield to help.
One's in the back, by the way.
I'm just gone now.
Good, good.
I'm on Naeemal in the back.
There is Naeemal.
I did it, thank you.
Great old Tyler.
They still have, uh, oh they don't, they don't want Bucky
anymore.
Oh, Helper Groot, Helper Groot, Helper Groot.
Okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
What, build, okay.
Let me build all of them?
Yo, I think I'm just gonna Groot, like when they walk up
here, probably.
Yeah, that's fine.
all right i'm gonna look for a big one we have no luna clap
what hell is on the left by the way yeah i'm trying to mark
her or someone else terrible tower we're good i'm gonna
reload i'm sorry i don't know i've lost oh no that's fine
as huge as huge oh i need heals on your load any hills up
front if you guys can i got you i got you they're down three
they're down Yeah, I'm on him.
I'm going on him in three, two, one.
Back up.
Back up group.
Yeah.
I got you.
We're okay.
I'm looking for a hook.
One of them's weak right now.
I need a string.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
I want him in.
Good pull.
We're gonna heal you.
Swing out, swing out.
Need heals, thank you, thank you, thank you.
It's this, it's not.
We're down two, we're down, Bucky and Tyus.
I'm not gonna, we actually, yeah, I'm not, I'm not ulting
this, I'm not ulting this.
We're seeing this.
Yeah, you're good, you're good, that's good.
I have old again, Moxie and I combo right away.
That's fine.
I can, I can, in this too.
They only have Jeff ult for support.
Nice, okay, this is perfectly.
She might try to ult for me here and try to like save her
team, i think we're fine i'm gonna all right away moxy
whenever i see it dude yeah let's play top right let's
play top right let's walk up i'm gonna i'm looking for this
hole stranger's top left i don't know what i'm thinking i'm
i'm about to do it i'm about to do it yeah it's fine the ult
they did every your i don't even you're a little little
little They've held still?
Which of the Nemo left side?
Nemo weak.
He heals on the right.
He has skin.
There's a trade.
I'm fighting a jet right now.
We capped.
Do cap.
Yeah.
Oh, you're coming.
Come here.
Kill him.
He's getting healed by both.
That's fine.
We have cap though.
Not for long.
I mean, hurry.
They TP.
swing out swing out swing out i don't think they would build
in this like that fast i didn't know yeah because she had
she married mine that's good though namo's going right side
nice maybe try to save for me this time uh proper we'll see
yeah i'm 18 we're good we're all here we're all here fight
from left yeah 90 might be looking for a little strange
careful namo up left range up top I'm like, I'm in a bubble.
I'm in a bubble.
I'm in on the right.
I couldn't get to yours so far.
I have all, by the way.
You can also see, oh, never mind.
Don't say shit.
We just reset.
Yeah, reset, reset.
Everyone out.
We still have another fight.
We have another fight.
No, no, no.
Don't worry about TP.
We have to.
Full reset.
We actually might have to CP.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm just going to kill you.
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
We have to get that 9%.
I'm TP out.
I'm going.
Touchpoint, touchpoint, touchpoint, Tyler.
Are you gonna get hit?
I can't, I can't!
I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it!
That is very good.
Invent's one.
I'm full focusing in this.
I need heals on points I'm up.
Thank you.
Hello's on the side.
Everyone you see hello.
that to me it's all right though yeah we did i i get it but
it was like i started walking out and then we died and i was
like oh no we really try team yeah we try that's brutal ggs
it's just around we're figuring it out we're getting better
the improvements there
damn dude i think like definitely for sure like no
hesitation with tp because we're like hesitating with like
what do we die or do we fight and then we just kept getting
staggered there that's brutal too because if we had any if
anyone else cp we could have literally come up the tp and
rude moonlight bucky combo to everything that's the only
reason i was like sort of hesitant i think we should try we
should try triple support i think yeah i think so yeah maybe
it's just so good yeah we're playing next
who's his team validity, Aramori I think the hardest part is
just that there's a lot of hesitation with my team so we
have to me and Moxie have to micromanage a lot because
there's like a lot of hesitation and I'm trying to like tell
them what to do but I also have to know what I have to do as
well you guys are tall if I'm Lunar but like Moxie is busy
getting killed so that I have to micromanage my so it just
depends on our support coverage in this type of turn would
probably be fun
can we teach tyler to tp real quick just in case it's just
that's two games in a row if i think me and moxie's brain
are exploding oh wait wait what do you know no no it's not
it's not that you're not on the point but but like we had
the double triple combo like we had group moon night i know
moxie's head is like overwhelmed right now too and i had to
give up group to tp there Go go practice.
Yeah, go to the practice.
It's so it's like the easiest thing in the world.
Everyone's like second guessing.
On the right, on the right, on the right of the lobby,
there's a practice.
What we have to do.
In practice.
Are you in the lobby?
Okay.
Okay, so then.
But we're getting better.
People are getting more confident.
Because like my co-support is getting more confident.
Yeah, go Dr. Strange, walk out.
is you press f yeah and then you just run all the way to the
point that's it and then you press left click and once
you're at the point but don't do it in the air just do it on
the ground yeah you just don't play don't press the
reposition button and wherever you put that second portal is
where you are gonna jump through i'm trying i probably i
just i people do people messing up well with everything
going on because like it's so it's not hard it's It's hard
to actually know players who are newer at the game because I
have to change the way I talk.
I'd like do some crazy sequence of events and shit.
No, you're good.
But it's good that you see, it's good you came in here and
did that because if you do, if we need it, you could
literally save our whole game.
It's a lot harder because the way, because I didn't realize
my code support did not know alt lines because I was like,
just all when they hear the when you hear the strange alt
line and then he didn't say anything and I later found out.
didn't even know what the strange alt line is so i was like
oh um just just alt when you just just rip it yeah that's
good to know you can place it like too high and then not i'm
not used to idealing players who haven't played much of the
game because i have to change the way i talk i'm wait oh is
that what i did yeah i think when you like when you press uh
the portal when you press f or whatever to open the portal
you just put your you just literally move your second one
you reposition your first one that's where like people mess
themselves up yeah yeah i think i think it's also if you i'm
just gonna check it again to see if this is what i did i
think like i was aiming yeah so it's like we have the micro
macro and ideas that's why it's like i'm like that's why i'm
not talking a lot in aim down i guess a little bit i'm like
i'm just overwhelmed right now let's see but like we're
getting better as a team though we get we are getting better
as a team and then i don't know i don't remember people's
names i don't remember people's name except necros is team
robs running triple support i'll just be like just that
because i don't know no people's names uh you guys want me
to support say it go on say you if you want to hit the
rocket
i'll play rocket okay it's up to you i mean we do have uh no
it's always like oh i always forget everyone i don't
remember i don't know people half the people's name maybe
we'll see based on the comp and what our bands are to say
you would be a monster rocket though i won't lie positioning
god yep we need a bands we need a first band mag oh who's
the mag oh yeah yeah no we do we do yeah the space yeah
definitely okay so i'm gonna go i'm gonna do a practice tool
of rocket real quick right i'm playing rocket are we doing
rock are we doing trip support with tyler on rocket well
we'll see how the bands go because i think we could just but
yeah hit the rocket real quick hey don't say it like that
say hey don't say hit the rocket wait let's say are they
also playing triple support moxie they're running triple
support so do we just ban triple support and well let's see
the people who they first they banned they banned mag they
banned rocket they banned squirrel girl i just shoot though
you just right click what does right click do right click is
the healing hell do you have to aim them at you guys and it
heals you yeah and they'll like slow down when they're near
a person that needs healing so you can also heal yourself
with them wait this shit's so easy you have res too you make
sure you throw your res in a in a corner a res beacon so
when we when we load in tyler throw your e down the the
little machine inside the spawn uh we'll all get armor packs
from it and then uh while we're in the spawn if you press e
again it will like you'll take it back and then that way you
can place it nearer the point because it needs to be within
i think it's 50 meters of the point for it to be able to
revive us so place it we'll get our armor packs take it back
then we run to point place it again where are you solo
tanking then um i guess so i mean we're banning uh it seems
like it i'm like the only i mean moxie could tank as well
yeah then we don't have a dps player i'm just trying to
fucking win here guys okay i'm doing what it takes to win
who's with me i'm i'm right there with you i think oh okay
so probably don't ban rocket because i think erob can play
cloak decent so just well we ban cloak so then we can have
uh hello hello you guys are a rock if we start the next
match yeah yep started we're ready bro we just we just ban
cloak because we don't have i don't know overplay mag or not
so we should just get rid of cloak now i'm not for that okay
they we don't blank ban cloak we might have to mirror cloak
no i don't i don't think erob is going to run cloak if if
rocket's not banned yeah okay so he's gonna run rocket true
But what were the other two supports playing?
The other two supports play Invis and Mantis.
Then we bad Mantis.
Mantis does the temple too much.
Okay.
And we need Invis anyway.
Because Epic plays Invis.
True.
Guys, we can't lose D-Rob.
Come on.
Oh my gosh, just a hard target, man.
damn every time we need an alias for moxie bro he's gotta be
wait do we think we need a bad strange where's uh space i
mean you probably play emba yeah i mean he's gonna play he's
gonna be good at probably anything was the one that got buff
right yeah but he's gonna play an emba though oh okay um
save
venom yeah yeah yeah just in case just the case that also
might make them think we're not going triple support if
we're protecting it well everyone else is going triple
support so yeah literally they want as many supports as
possible they're just target banning you all the time yeah
okay now do we want to ban man lulu plays a lot of invis um
i mean we can do she's also I already banned Mantis then.
Yeah, I could ban Mantis too.
So at least they don't, at least like, they don't get a
damage boost.
And then we can either ban Loki, we could ban Loki so they
can't run Gambit Loki.
I don't think they'll play Gambit.
Well, if they're running Loki, my Moon Knight is going to
crush them.
Yeah.
Oh, that's true.
So we don't have to ban Loki.
Then we just ban Invis.
And then we can run Luna Gambit or Luna.
Loki.
I could also ban spaces, Emma.
If you want to.
Okay, so now they're going to be solo tanking because Dean's
going to play Squirrel Girl.
Okay.
Do we want to solo tank Emma or Strange for them?
What do you think?
Are you thinking of banning Emma, you said?
I'll do it with Gavin Scott.
Emma or Invis.
like do we want space to play strange or emma or do we bend
invis i think i'd rather have him on emma just because i
feel like strange ults in this are really strong but there's
no portal okay yeah i'll bend i'll bend invis then because i
think he'll pick emma anyways oh yeah you're probably right
then we can run loki luna rocket wait they're not running
mag right they can't run mag so we can do cloak as well all
right i just go cloak then because i feel like you carry
harder on loki though yeah i was gonna say we might need you
on loki yeah all right just because like cloaks cloaks alt
is much stronger yes no moxie's gonna be dps with you yeah
you want me to still on moonlight probably i could do would
you guys rather have grude or emma uh if you have grew i can
i can come to alt show time yeah you can combo either bucky
or but yeah yeah i mean it's up to you guys i can i can go
group and try group and then swap later if it doesn't work
is this the map that's is it like a pub map is this the old
one yeah wait this got banned this is back in the game no
this map is bad ben father give us some moral support hype
us up oh that's not good you should check this out your
closet takes the jump back probably
is lagging right now guys oh i use the jump out we have
another are you good are you good we can pause do we pause
do we pause we got caught up good guys come down okay okay
remove your beacon let's see you don't have to run you all
you got to do is stay all the way behind everyone and just
press right click and then i think yeah ty i'm gonna ping it
throw your throw your thing like around here somewhere so
they don't break it and then okay We walk up on that.
There.
Phase is one.
I want off this brother.
Oh my god, they instantly destroyed the fucking in bomb so
fast.
Luna one.
Nice, nice, nice.
Luna weak.
Slowest.
They're just leaving my uncle.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma.
Emma low.
Emma won.
Emma still won.
Oh, no.
That's fine.
No, we don't.
Punisher right side on me.
Punisher on me.
Punisher on.
I'm dying.
Punisher dead.
I should be right.
We lost our tank.
Stay on point.
I stood on point for as long as I could.
Nice ult.
Good job.
The Lunar's on midpoint.
I'm one.
Kill you.
They're low.
Nice.
You should be even.
Space.
Focus.
Punisher left side.
I'm about to be here.
I'm here with you guys.
Our tank's here.
us against the world the punisher has got one shot yeah you
got grab and i have old we don't have any combo though
yeah i need to like we might have to swap through it because
of the punisher yeah i can yeah uh i have old should i just
use it on the back line details details details yeah i'm
gonna ready i think i'm just gonna i'll i'll copy oh i'm
gonna copy rocket i'm going in i'm going he's just gonna oh
and then smokey i have i have i'm risked too okay you should
get rest from here hey it's just a oh i did not get rest
i think oh it's i'm gonna swap out yeah we have to swap off
group because of the punisher i'm actually i think cloak is
actually better for this go for it so we at least have the
cloak They used their rocket up there, right?
Or no?
They didn't.
I used rocket.
You can engage with the other rocket up.
So you just chuck it in there.
Do you want me to ult?
Not yet.
I might die.
If he breaks that, I'm going to die.
All right.
You might have to walk in and ult here.
Okay.
I'm ready.
Yeah.
Just throw it.
Chuck it in.
Touch point.
There goes.
Maybe you can ult.
Yeah, you can ult this.
Walk in, walk in, walk in, walk in, walk in.
Walk in, walk in.
I don't know we should put Tyler on rocket I think
I didn't play venom the same shit happen I'm a menace back
there I'll be telling you guys switch your back yeah we
saved him for you just in case yeah he's available all right
who told tyler to go rocket i think tyler was a question it
was a no i was getting disrespected it's the thing fucking
moxie yeah yeah listen triple support is what they're
running we could we could see i mean i'm 90 i could use my
alt and then i could switch next life if you want to still
i'm down for that that's probably probably worth it'll be
worth it yeah yeah i just use it earlier something or combo
with me and then yeah how close are you 69 i mean i'll get
like let's go let's win this i'll get there but if you see a
good opportunity just use it yep i'm doing a pretty wide
angle here i'm gonna see if i can get the back line hey go
for it oh this map bro doesn't want to play height i haven't
i don't know uh been too long yeah can we go in the puncher
might put his turret down again oh my god i missed my right
click whoops i have to drop tell me i'm gonna drop i'm gonna
die maybe i'm on i'm on the front line luna one luna one
luna one hp that dead nice helper yeah i'm good i'm good
A little cloak, cloak, cloak.
Yeah, I was forced to walk out.
I was like, oh, it's 2%.
I thought it was bad to punish you anyway.
Okay, we'll die, we'll die, we'll die, let's group.
I can go engage with my cloak.
Yeah, they're using their old super well.
That was good timing from them too.
Yeah, you should.
We should just win with your cloak.
Ready?
I suppose not.
I don't know.
They shouldn't have invades.
I mean, they shouldn't have luna.
How close are they?
They're very close.
I'm pushing.
I'm pushing up then.
Kill them all.
That's good.
Again!
Nice!
I'm with you on this.
I'm on cloak.
Yeah, I am too.
Cloak is low.
Wait, I have a Punisher beside me.
Punisher low!
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Good fucking cloak.
Okay.
Let our Luna...
build all again come here come here luna yeah just let i'll
let our luna build all here i will as well yes feel free to
take damage tyler because we need support don't take too
much don't take too much he might go super in i just got
moved bro someone just moved me to the like bogers voice
chat what yeah we have luna we have luna here nice nice Get
him, Tyler.
Get him.
All the way we have to.
Kill kill everyone.
boxing on.
Punisher.
Yeah.
Everyone.
Oh, no we should have one, we need to.
Oh, I don't have one right now.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Get up, get up, get up, do I.
I'm trying, bodylock him.
I'm trying to stay in front of you.
I might need help.
I need help here.
It is.
It is down point.
Oh, someone moved me to the other team's call.
Um, wait, what?
I was in Bougar in their call.
Why are you in here?
I'm like, I don't, I was like, I don't know.
I'm playing the game.
Grab armor as you come, pause.
Yeah, yeah.
There's a jump back there.
I have ult here.
So I'll use my first.
We do the same way.
I have ult now as well.
We use my ult to engage.
You guys ready?
Yeah.
Are they pushed up or no?
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay, ready?
Three, two, one, go.
Go, go deep, go deep, go, deep, deep, deep, deep.
Rocket alting.
Rocket alting down on point.
Careful, careful, rocket.
Run back up, yeah, they Broke are alt.
And run, run, run, run, run.
Kill it, kill it, kill it!
I did.
You try helping me, only, only, only, only.
I'm trying.
Good.
We're done.
You're the DPS.
Yeah, we at Portal.
We need Portal.
Someone swapped this game.
You got it?
Back up, back up, back up.
Epic, come back, come back, come back.
Everyone out.
All the way to spawn.
Just run all the way.
Okay, it's on their back line.
It's on their back line.
You can't, you're gonna have to throw the rocket thing out
or we're not gonna...
Yep, yeah, yeah, I know.
Punish, punish, punish, punish, kill.
We'll play inside the portal if you need to.
I'm on the back.
I'm on the point.
I'm on point.
Don't worry about it.
Hi, Squirtle.
Squirtle.
Yeah, yeah.
I didn't see that.
Come on.
Just chill, just chill.
We have no support.
Oh, guys, chill, chill, chill.
Chill, chill.
We have nothing.
Clearly just you and Tyler.
Yeah.
Oh, we did get sabotage, though.
So it's not on us.
We did get, dude.
I literally was like, yeah, I was telling you, I was going
to really ammo, and I'm like, they're like, you're going to
ammo.
I'm like, what?
What?
Is that weird?
Like, oh, why is closet article?
That's so weird.
What the?
Who moved you?
Who even has permission to do that?
Mid game?
Yeah.
I didn't love you It's okay It's the underdog art And then
in the After round robin We go back up God I think we need
to win these next two games bad Alright Moxie Have you
figured out the comp for us Well fuck Don't talk in game
Moxie You're not saying a word to anybody You're just
playing bro How can anybody be the best player But you don't
fucking speak We don't know shit I don't know what to do
You're not telling me about what to do bro doing a great job
same with donkey with the comms it's tough dude like i gotta
shoot the gun and shit i have a 200 hp and abandoned me out
for a while yeah but it's not you're not saying a single
word it's kind of weird i it's i don't know he's just locked
in he's got his tongue out yeah carry god damn it i'm just
trying moxie you were first pick for him you gotta carry you
were his first pick you gotta carry
Dude, these guys are fucking pussies.
This is all I gotta say.
God damn.
I guess, Moxie, you might have to expand your hero pool.
Wait, metaphor was one above all?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
What a steal for the second round pick.
You got one above all plus a space.
Two one above alls.
Hmm.
What was he playing?
What was metaphor playing there?
Punisher, I think, right?
Punisher.
yeah gotcha god that ult in these types of things is just so
crazy you know what comp is best for us because i think we
do well with two two and i don't know if triple support is
good for us yeah it's maybe we should just we should back to
two two maybe that yeah but maybe we should focus on like
having a support kill combo like just like a punisher in in
this type of thing because like they punish her out there
and there's nothing i mean there's literally nothing we
could do like with their rocket alt down or whatever or just
getting walked we just let everyone play their comfort pick
maybe yeah also we could if there's anything we want to like
experiment with these next two games are perfect because
we're like we're not going to be top seed anyway so we might
as well use the games to like gather as much data as we can
yeah well do we do we even move on to for the last two seeds
no no it's round and after that it's just uh best of one
with the uh with whoever's first or second uh or third or
fourth we still go into quarters like everyone will go into
quarters after these two matches so we can use the two
matches to just like figure out any comps that we want to
run in the actual like 20 matches themselves yeah winning
these games would be huge too because we probably won't be
like we definitely don't want to be last seed because then
we're versus someone who probably went like five and five
So we can mess around and like figure it out, but we
definitely want to, uh, we, if we win these next two games,
that'd be huge.
Otherwise we're kind of putting ourselves in a bad spot.
I'm not trying to be that guy, guys, but we've won one
round.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, we have.
I mean, we could have won the next C1.
That was real close.
We should have won that too.
Like that was, I think, yeah, I think maybe we, didn't you
want to try Naimore?
Wait, someone said they wanted to try Naimore.
I can.
that out i think we should try to switch off moon knight we
didn't play like comfort picks i think name where is fine
because the turrets would be really good especially against
like lower elo players so you don't know how to shoot
turrets there's also kind of hard because they're we have
moon knight into triple support and they're just like giving
them a lot of damage we're giving them all support else yeah
yeah that's true so just go name where and then don't let
tyler play anything but venom well the squids do the same
thing fuck off i could dude if my raccoon was i 5k hilly no
it's just it just wasn't it it was just not for the comp or
you were your record was great it was just your venom was so
good you know that it just is a game changer yeah you're
right yeah yeah so it's like we have to put you on your best
character tyler effects yeah me out there's also isn't that
also a venom hella team up right yes so we could and i think
that gives doesn't that give venom like more health i think
like 100 more health or something no no no no no just no he
has that just for having yeah he just has that for just
existing with the team up yeah that's what i mean so like
without the team up as well he has it oh oh okay speech one
500.
because we could rather than because i'm thinking if we're
worried about the supports on their team just getting fed
ult charged by like chip damage from the moon night the kind
of same thing is going to happen with the square turrets
kind of so if I was to try in Hella, that might be more
burst damage, and then it also means that I benefit from the
venom being on the team, maybe?
But maybe I'm overcooking it.
I don't know.
I don't really play Hella.
Sounds like that was not a cook.
You're like, what the fuck is this guy saying?
He might be overestimating how big the team up is for Hella
in the Bene.
I think it's fine to try a team up only because everyone's
teams are so like like some people have bronze players some
people have like like you know plat players so i think your
hell is fine we just try it just try i'm happy i think i i
think it's better he plays like phoenix or something's more
comfortable and we just don't have the team up if if if
what's his name's if robin waffle is comfortable and yeah on
namor i don't think the team up is like why put why put
moxie on like someone who he's not he doesn't play i've seen
this hella his hell sure it's good i mean you are you are
over hyping guys i know my own abilities i'm i do it with
moxie and i've just don't put him on like spider-man or
something i was really about to suggest spider-man i'm not
even kidding for this map we would have to we'd have to put
money in the other team's pocket if we want moxie on the
long guy yeah okay the only i'm the only person who plays
the character that counters the triple support i know dude
yeah i mean that's why they ban you because they first ban
it every time is that hulk right yeah uh yeah because they
can use just headshots yeah and they're just scared they
don't want to deal with it i mean they've banned like
captain america too so it's crazy i think wait what were we
banning for class that's your like second best yeah i mean
yeah i could just like Yeah, probably.
But gosh, what does Flats team play?
Is it triple support?
Let's see.
Yeah, we'll figure it out.
Daltush is going to be probably DPS, and I think he's
controller.
Guys, also have I been lagging or not, or not, because I
just realized I was playing just the entire tab.
So was I lagging?
The whole team is like looking weird.
Wait, R4 is not even playing support.
Wait, really?
I think they just have too many support players.
it was is frogger good he's frog road oh w right or probably
it's probably okay is he not is it what he's playing he's he
played deadpool um oh boy interesting dps deadpool support
deadpool or tank deadpool tank deadpool okay so it's what
triple tank are they going they're going triple tank then we
have to run i guess we do have to run moon night i was gonna
say we can yeah the moon night can be perfect yeah okay
adult two she apparently plays jeff and hella and they
banned hella they banned jeff and hella so do we just ban
jeff and hella and then they banned someone's iron fist i
might assume oh wait yeah we had wait i think that's
frogger's iron fist so we just Daltush do if both his chance
to ban him.
He goes Punisher and it looked like he did the best on the
team.
Wait, but did they win or lose?
They're still did they win or lose?
They're still playing.
Oh, okay.
What are their previous games?
Going to lose though, it looks like.
Oh, no.
Oh, Moxie, figure out the bans.
Guys, come on, Doki, help me out here as well with the ban.
I've been helping out.
You give me a baseline ban and then I'll if it's good or not
that's what i've been doing okay um you have more hours of
rivals than me is there more just playing she dps the whole
time or i thought she was tank she's on dps right now i need
to just swap between yeah i think they just have not i think
they might have too many supporter like i think yeah worse
they are running triple support right yeah they try to we're
back just like I don't even know what Deadpool's old does
like I'm watching him um why around and like it depends on
if he's on his katanas or guns if he's on guns he can target
one single person and that person doesn't hit him they take
damage and also your team gets healed and if he's on the
katanas if he's on katanas um he has to make combos and
stuff on like the enemy team and that'll heal and damage
boost your team okay got you it's interesting every time i i
every time i've watched them all in any of these games i'm i
don't know what if i should be like looking back at them or
if i should just ignore them
yeah i try to i try to peel the deadpool sometimes but i'm
like it's kind of some that deadpool has three different
bands do we it is yeah but isn't it like he's not people
don't know how to play him yet so it's like we don't have to
worry for now until that was kind of moving on them how many
hours do you have in on them already yeah but he had early
access though so that early access has been spamming that
all day yeah if he has 20 i mean he could be really good is
we can't ban it because it's three different roles yeah we
can ban tank and dps pool but and then there's support pool
left um wait so are we banning hella jeff and iron fist Is
that our band line?
Uh.
I guess so.
I think so.
Then you just have to deal with.
Hella.
Seems like a Lindy's playing Jeff.
And there's Hella, Jeff.
Yeah.
If, if a little Rock gets.
I don't know.
This is so.
This is very hard.
I mean, what do you want first band?
Hella or Jeff?
Are you more scared of a Hella?
players play Jeff, right?
Then we first ban Jeff.
But Hella is the playmaker.
I'm surprised they had Daltush on Jeff.
Like he literally, that would be like a such a random This
first ban Hella because she's a playmaker.
They first ban Iron Fist.
People first banned Iron Fist.
They banned Hella after.
They banned Jeff after.
Oh.
Then we just follow that.
Yeah, I think that's fine.
That's fine.
We'll just steal their ban line.
Did they lose or win?
they've lost so far okay we'll just we'll just follow their
band line then iron fist and then helen and jeff okay i like
that they're joining now buys i'm back sorry also we have a
hundred ping because they added ping on us oh yeah yeah bad
i don't buy an iron fist so then he can't he has to play
like not super aim intensive heroes Yeah, I think they
should actually move everyone's ping down to the best ping
in the lobby That is true if it's only one person whose ping
is that high It should be majority rules like this dude's
playing on 182 so we're all playing on 182 is what I mean is
like Basically, that's crazy, bro, like we all got greens
and this guy's red
Did we decide anything while I was gone any new?
Yeah I'll first tell out Jeff and then we protect venom
first And then second protect is whatever Moxie feels
comfortable.
And they're triple tanking, we said.
I think you can play Namor because they weren't actually
triple tanking.
They were swapping.
They were just playing around with cops.
Okay.
Yeah, I'll try the Namor out then and see how it feels.
Guys, don't jinx us.
Guys, don't bully us.
We have...
We are trying our best.
I was just like, don't bully us.
What am I going to play?
Yeah.
You can play Alkaid because it's not going to get bad.
I mean, if it's open, we should first protect Hawkeye for
sure.
If they don't, I stopped myself, I was like, fuck it.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, I think that would be the most valuable for that.
Bro, he's a pro, yes.
I believe.
Yeah, I believe.
Guys, if you don't believe, we lose.
Bucky or Cap or...
Yes.
I need you to believe.
in us look i know i'm doing my part is that anything i need
to do like to help me doing my job i'm trying to keep them
squishy for you what are you playing name more yeah this
this game name more unless they triple tank if they triple
tank i'll go back to moonlight but i was gonna give the name
more a try i feel like you have time on bucky too bucky's
like pretty all right i i have some time on bucky but i'm
much he's just more comfortable on name where we should put
him on his comfort i'm less consistent on bucky basically so
like i'm i will either have a good game or i will do very
little um yeah then putting his comfort pick and then he'll
he'll surprise us all with how good he is listen i thought i
thought that first ult got all five of them that first game
i was like oh i'm good at the game all of a sudden hell yeah
yeah it's warm up guys it's warm up until we round.
Yeah.
This all warm up.
We make them, we give them like low expectations and then
change it around.
I like that.
I mean, it's happening.
Yeah.
They're like, oh, look at this team.
It was so easy to beat them.
And then we like pull out our Trump card.
We were like fucking around.
Right, guys?
We're all not playing our best, right?
Yeah.
I've been, yeah.
We were sad bagging, right, guys?
I think so.
I think we were.
I'm a Mr. Fantastic man.
Yeah.
We're going to win.
Lock the fuck in.
I'm eating Fine.
I'm getting all my energy back.
Okay, he's powering up.
Yeah, I need some calories, too.
Yeah.
Everybody right now, get a snack, please.
I'm drinking more.
I have a snack.
Granola bar, like a...
What do you mean you don't have a snack?
I already had my snack.
Oh.
What'd you eat?
I...
A katsu sandwich.
What the hell?
Yeah.
Oh, we're guaranteed to win now.
I'm getting me.
I'm ready to eat.
game i'm kind of jealous what are you eating tyler steak for
you steak steak meat torile rice and for dessert have a kick
cat bar good oh my god the feast of kings i expect at least
10 finals this game bro colossal you played four dude no
i'll expect you to get i mean i did in like the last one of
these turnies but haven't played him like since then okay
okay check check check what are you waiting for but he's way
better than he wasn't the last time i played him he was bad
yeah i feel like he could go crazy if i if i played him
again maybe i was just trying to play him back then to get
lord on him and i i remember my uh my win rate percentage or
whatever was like 75 on him when he sucks so i was like i'm
gonna keep playing him in the turni if they want it i'm it
was good but yeah yeah yeah reset literally the new season
just started season six just i it's so funny that they like
advertise this as a deadpool invitational and like no one's
playing dead i know they just lost that right i think
they're over loss hello hello sorry for the delay here uh
while we let the other games finish uh you guys ready rock
yeah um i mean the enemy team is missing one player i'm
missing a person she's afk she'll back in one second and
then then as soon as she's here we'll get rolling
yeah there's that it doesn't make much sense to me let's
actually actually teams three zero down your team is stacked
i'm not gonna lie he screamed he was screaming they're
chasing after me like that whole game that whole entire game
was i have maybe that i don't really wait yeah go ahead go
ahead no no no Yeah, I was going to say, if they're 3-0, we
had a really tight match against them.
Yeah, I mean, we should have won that one.
Yeah, but maybe he hasn't versed the best teams yet.
Oh.
They have played us, though.
Sorry.
Yeah, but he hasn't played us when we were trying, though.
Yeah, that's true.
It wasn't after the warm-up.
Yeah, we were not warmed up when we played them, and we were
also throwing on purpose.
Yeah, but that's, wait, so then that might be the best comp,
the one we did against.
2-2 might be the best for us, then.
Yeah, we could do it.
If they go triple and we're just getting smoked by ults, we
can swap but i'm down to do 222 let's start on it at least
yeah i know what were you gonna say mr raffle raffle yeah my
my chat's telling me that we would be winning if tyler
stopped abusing brand exhaust top is that true what are you
what does that even mean i don't know what that means who
the fuck told you that man is tyler is that is that true i
also heard tyler that you were putting up my youtube channel
and asking if it was possible that someone could Oh my
goodness!
I did!
I got spies in the chat.
I did, I did!
Watch yourself.
Eyes in the back of your head, the rest of the tournament
you hear.
I was, bro.
I was curious, man.
Were you curious?
I don't know if they were all curious.
He asked.
Confirmation and then still pulled it up.
Well, now that you know, aren't you going to answer him?
Can you live up?
He said he can.
There's no way someone can live off that.
And I was like, oh no, that's my job.
And then he pulls up the channel.
He's still just like, there's no way.
No, no, no.
I was saying it after I looked at it.
I was like, oh, okay.
We'll play sometime.
Okay, Jeff, hella.
I think I want to bend the hella.
Yeah, not Iron Fist.
There's no.
Oh, no, Iron Fist.
Yeah, that's good.
That's good.
This is why you got to walk in.
They banned Gambit.
We can protect.
What do you mean?
I've been hoping you retired Badline.
They banned Gambit.
We can protect.
We absolutely do.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
okay who the heck come on lock in team lock in oh my god you
got your character oh let's go better carry moxie yeah very
carry you literally got that character now i better see you
like six days oh does that change the rest of our comp at
all if you're hawk right now no no you could play hawk out
any it's just easier to win against everyone else i think
yeah okay um i guess we we ban was it hello or jeff the
hello i think hell is more of an issue probably oh they just
don't want i mean unless you guys think triple support jeff
would be worse but no it's fine hello then and then we
protect venom if they don't ban we had we protect venom
and then jeff i'm a little rusty on the hawk ah bro stop it
He's giving himself a little backspace in case he gets
pooped on.
You've got to close your eyes right now and imagine yourself
playing the game, all right?
I need you to get that rust off before we even begin.
I like that.
It needs to happen.
Get warm in your mind.
Oh, they protected Punisher.
I guess that's Daltush's Punisher then.
Yeah.
And then Jeff.
That's fine.
We got a great Magneto then.
Yeah, I was going to say, just Mag.
I'll literally just...
Mag, Luna, Sue.
Take care of you.
You want...
Which one are you more comfortable?
with probably invis okay i'll go luna it's like it's like
whatever i mean it could go rocket mash wait i think you
guys i'm not it might be crazy me to say i think you guys
switch that up i think i think me yeah i mean you aim and
luna's more just raw aim and i think invis is just harder
like and has like a higher skill gap but honestly this
should be like i'm like 50 50 like they're like the same day
perfect if you're ready to switch back at any point let me
know just make the call i'll name more until then sounds
good All right, I'll give us you feel man.
I'll give us jump packs Grab the grab the armor
All right guys the wins not in the bag yet just because I
got yeah We gotta still try guys Tyler hype us up Tyler hype
us up.
We haven't won a single game, but that doesn't matter
They're all laughing at us.
They're all making fun of us.
Here's where we shock the world I'm fucking shivering right
now.
That was good.
Jump high cops off if I don't like it.
Yeah, it's unguarded.
I got it.
I'm just going to stand on it so I can get it out.
Yeah.
Lock in team, let's go.
Bumble.
Oh, there goes my jump back.
It starts with one, guys.
It starts with one.
The entertainment has arrived.
We got one.
We got one round, bro.
Yeah, exactly.
We're going to shock the world.
I thought we started.
Oh, wait, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
He missed.
And he has no jump back anymore.
We can make burns.
Pass him maybe.
He's no passive.
No passive.
Oh, he's just saved his life.
Wolf and Hulk are one on this right side.
Oh, yeah.
Wolf.
He's still one.
This is an insane con from them.
I can't lie.
Armory one.
The supports are one.
Okay.
Nice swing, nice swing, Tyler.
Oh no, I couldn't get him.
We got the point.
It's fine, it's a trade, it's trade.
I'm shooting Punisher.
Yeah, I'm so.
I'm getting focused on you.
I'm right, I'm right, I'm getting right now.
I got you.
I killed Luna, I killed Luna.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
He's fighting, he's fighting.
She had an ult.
She forced all I'm going to die in this.
Can someone heal me right now?
I'm trying to get out.
I got you, I got you, I got you, got you, got you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh no, it's back.
Yeah, if you can heal me, heal me, Doc.
Yeah, I'll bubble you.
I got you.
Yeah, you follow yourself.
Good, good, good.
I have all here.
We don't need it.
I pushed it.
I need your deck.
Everyone is right here, guys.
Hi.
Oh, we kill her.
Oh, you got her.
Dude, I think she was like gone around the corner.
Nice shot.
Yeah, I'm holding her on 100%.
I'll try to let you build a ult, but I have a ult too.
I might not be able to kill a pun with the ult, so we might
have to...
No, we use my ult.
We use my ult.
Use your ult first, and then if you don't kill him, I'll use
my ul.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll see what I can get.
I agree.
I'm going to let you build out.
He's jumping around to you.
I got you.
Double nice.
Half can maybe die.
I mean, he's just up.
Go for the healers.
Yeah, I'm too.
I'm shooting the Luna in the back, Dolly.
Hey, I'm on some guy.
I don't know.
You're on someone back there.
I'm shooting the Luna.
Luna on.
Their cap's low.
Cap's low.
Hey, man.
Let's get the cap.
And you.
On me, on me, on me, on me, on me.
Caps you.
Punisher and Maitis are flanking left guys.
Yeah, yeah, three of them, three of them left.
I got it, I got it, I got it, I got the health.
Nice, good old, good old.
We're going to have to use Lintel for Punisher and...
Yeah, use it for Paul, use your pawn.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, no.
Oh, it's okay, I could...
Maitis dead, Maitis dead.
Oh, I actually pushed him away.
It's my bad.
I'm ultimately holding up.
I got pulled.
Altusia's right side.
He's...
No question.
Frozen in the middle.
Just Zion point, you have...
Cablo, Cablo.
I think we win.
It's half a night.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And there's some wood.
We're coming back now.
I'm shooting Cavalry.
Capture Cavalry.
Just stay alive.
Stay alive.
Just careful.
Just play it back.
We're going to die.
They ulted nothing.
That's so good for us.
Magnetia, we?
No, no, no, no.
I'm cutting heals there.
I'm killing her.
Oh.
Got you?
We're all back.
Bombardier on the right.
It's all.
Yeah.
Slop, you slop.
Let's get yours here.
I got you.
I'm gonna give you a shield.
I'm giving you a shield for this ult.
I've done a bubble for you and I have bubble walk over.
Strange and lot.
No worries.
I've got a problem.
I've pulled him back.
I'm giving you a shield for this.
Got another.
Invis one.
Are they healed?
Strange one for your magnitude.
Yeah, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Thank you.
Invis one point.
Nice.
Oh my goodness!
Go team!
All we have to do is put money in their pockets for Hawkeye.
and we can win this tourney yeah we're playing game time
they pull triple support guys they're pulled they're
desperate now they're desperate even when you can't see me
that was an interesting punish roll from tush bro he was on
he was in narnia wait wait tyler tyler how are you going in
on their back line just wondering like what is your what are
you doing i swing then i press f okay okay yeah try to try
to climb up on a wall and then dive on them and then swing
out yeah yeah that makes sense actually you're about to be
leaving He's about to be he's about to triple his stats
right now.
I told you eight games tell me I thought you knew you only
play this character That's true And like even if you don't
like fully commit they're gonna use like Like so many
cooldowns just like scared
Should I when should I use my alt like when you want me to
synergize that with when when they're using an offensive alt
or like or like mirror their defensive old if they if they
pop early hedge want me to pop because i have yeah yeah if
you okay if they pop a defensive i'll talk yours defensive
you got it yeah it's either it's either it's literally just
whichever ones first on the strong left he's not gonna get
healed i'm i'm marking him over here a little bit i'm just
gonna i don't have my shield anymore moxie so yep there's
another one right there i'm really i'm really marking their
punish your back left if we can.
Like, he's not going to get healed at all there.
You shouldn't be healed.
Get out, Tyler.
Get out.
Let me know.
I have no angles to shoot anyone.
You're shaking me up on point here.
I'm getting bullied by the floor.
Yeah, I'm trying my best.
I mean, I'm going to use my own to keep you alive.
Thank you.
Kill the tanks inside.
Tanks inside.
Tanks.
i got you tyler bubble walk walk walk don't choose right
here punishers here help her i invades invades oh my god
that's so good back up oh oh you're so good you're so good
for that oh oh oh that was the elite level gameplay i saw it
we can stagger them just kill them you guys let's get out
get out you got nice old y'all are crazy bro oh my goodness
let's go it was beautiful yeah tell ya all right this is the
team bro this is the team we picked I like this.
Who is this?
There's mag here.
How did you get here?
Cat, cat, cat, cat, cat.
I'm still saving all for pawn.
They might rock it with it though.
Yeah, yeah, just save it for him.
I'll ult it all the way.
Walk back.
I'm a wall.
Someone on the road.
Oh yeah, I need help.
I need help.
Keep me up right now.
I didn't, I got hit by something.
Yeah, yeah, just down point, down point.
I got hit on the plank.
You captured more than half of the missionary family.
Keep going.
Okay.
I'm fine.
That's so good.
We got good momentum here.
Out of flake.
I like the cold.
I was at my lot too.
Just calm.
Calm when you're going in, Tyler.
We're not there actually.
We're not there.
We're not.
He's lying, he's lying, dude.
He's lying, dude.
The Punisher's just holding it.
I'm in.
The Punisher's going for you.
Come on, boy.
Hey, yeah, yeah.
I got you.
We're here now.
Rocket, Rocket Week.
Rocket Week, running back.
He's one, he's one.
That is nice huge.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice kill.
I'm on the mag.
I'm on mag.
With you, Tyler.
Kill him.
No bubble.
Stand behind me if you need.
Oh, he threw already.
Fight point, fight point, fight point.
Nice.
Air Mori 1.
Air Mori 1 on you, Tyler.
All day, baby.
All day.
I'll let you farm all day.
We'll let you farm up.
Yes, sir.
I'm in here.
You gotta yell louder.
Okay.
I will scream.
Heal Moxie.
That's okay.
I got Moxie.
Yeah, we should be fine now.
He has an ult at one time, by the way.
I, yeah.
Maybe don't.
Maybe you don't flake me epic.
Oh no, you're flaking yourself.
That's fine.
Luna, don't ult for the Punisher.
I got the Punisher.
You don't want me to?
No, yeah, don't.
I ult the, no.
You ult for Punisher first, Mac.
And then if you fail.
Oh my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my.
Okay.
I'm not gonna kill him though.
okay then i got it all nice good old good old yeah do you
break their rock oh my god i got hit by it it's fine oh yeah
that's fine they used too much they use rocket and the
thorell okay i'm 98 rocket thor end pawn oh yeah we're
chilling yeah yeah so i get insta killed by it um yeah i
can't kill that either i mean that was let's group this
group they just did so no uh you were not supposed to use it
for punisher you used for
Yeah, now you just match their match defensively or
aggressive or offensive We're all here.
Yeah, we're all here.
We're all here.
Let's go.
Yep.
Wait a minute.
I went the wrong way.
Yeah, okay.
Wait it.
Okay.
I'm going Good
Helping you Rock it rock it rock it I'm about to ult guys
Yeah, do it do it do it do it Okay cancel it out of it.
Oh, it's I got frozen.
I need his money I'm gonna try my guy.
Nice nice.
Thank you Punisher, punish you.
Please, please, please.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
The Deadpool got rest.
Deadpool, Deadpool, Deadpool, Deadpool.
Nice.
Give teamwork.
Oh my god.
Rocket, rocket, rocket.
I got you.
Here you go.
You have, yeah.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Focus, Max.
Right side, need tails.
I'm going to land you.
I'm dead.
He's gonna die.
Yeah.
They're porling.
Kill that all day.
Come on!
Oh my God.
Wait a minute.
Did you feel like you were cooking, Tyler, with the new
tech, with the swing, the new swing test?
I'm going to be honest.
I did it like three times.
I can't climb walls.
I don't know if the top walls are me.
I'm like, you know, stun locks are running backwards and
running.
It is a little goofy.
But once you get that wall climb, it is the move.
I died a lot less this game.
game because I was running away instead of just dying.
That's good.
That game felt 500 times easier than ever.
Yeah, I think we got the car.
Yeah, those guys were just...
Those guys were just as equally good as everyone else.
I think also because Moxie had Hawkeye.
Yeah.
The Hawkeye Jeff is definitely present.
No, no.
I think the Hawkeye is definitely helping us a lot.
Listen, if that's also, if that's Rusty, Moxie, that the
rust is gone right oh right now that now that they let marx
play hawkeye he's never going to be allowed again oh god
yeah i'm gonna take my dog out real quick so i need a snack
i need a snack bad yeah we got it yeah we gotta win i'm just
happy we gotta win guys i'm just guys i'm just happy we
gotta win That's all we needed.
That's all we needed.
That's okay, guys.
We can go now.
We gotta win.
We...
What?
Not full sweep.
Yeah, no Doom Q later.
Guys, we can't even Doom Q if we want to.
We have to.
We have gotta win.
war oh did i say oh yeah by the way i don't remember if i
talked about chibi-doki message me last night and apparently
she's really sick like she had to go to a hospital because
of her throat um i assume because like you know she screams
a lot so like i worry about her health but um unfortunately
because of that the doctor said that she should like rest up
and not use her voice too much um and uh So we're going to
reschedule tomorrow's collab.
Yeah, I hope she's okay.
I do hope she's okay.
But we are rescheduling.
We'll be rescheduling tomorrow's collab to another day
whenever she feels better.
So most likely tomorrow, either I take a day off because I
also need to rest my voice as well.
Or maybe we put, depending on how long I'm playing rivals.
We pushed God of War to tomorrow.
So we'll see how it is.
We'll see how it goes.
Oh, we were supposed to...
Okay, then.
Yeah, so...
Let's see.
Oh, yeah.
Apparently we're supposed to leave the lobby.
For those who are still over here.
Oh.
Yeah, because...
Yeah.
They invited us to a new lobby.
Oh, okay.
Good calls.
Yeah.
So, we'll see how I feel after the tournament's been really
fun so far.
Like, everyone's getting better and better, too.
The tournament's been really, really fun.
I'm enjoying it.
I like the vibes of this team.
Yeah, it's been silly.
Tyler Crashout.
Tyler Crashout is...
Tyler crashing out is like is like literally the the theme
of his own stream his own channel
let me disassociate for a little bit guys
I need to I need to disassociate a little bit I need to pee
too give me a sec guys
alright Thank you guys for all the super chats.
X-Factor, Phileon, WB, Jeff, Manny, Bite, Gail, Solid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's been fun.
It was really hard in the beginning, only because of
micromanaging everyone.
Because I didn't change the way.
I don't know if you guys hear me stumbling in my calls a
lot, because I have to try to change the way I say, stuff
because like they're like we do have like three new players
three newer players on our team so like i'm like what do i
how do i calm this especially like in the moment too you
know
yeah yeah they're warm up it was me figuring out it was me
trying to like figure out like how to calm too being like i
get oh
words words are hard also it doesn't help that brain is not
not strong today i think if i wasn't if i was not as sick
maybe brain will be stronger words out mouth now i'm back
you guys are in the lobby if anyone can invite me to lobby
it okay i think games are still playing so they're not gonna
start oh gotcha everyone's like someone up then yeah wait we
should figure out bad line wait before we get dragged in
who's the last team we're playing against tyler's probably
hitting the practice range right now making sure his venom
movement's good yeah i'm 100 out of it actually moxie thanks
for asking piece of of you know why would you say that
because we all know he is doing it anyway so you Why is it?
I'm going to speed up it.
I just did some practice tool.
Plus, I was on Google looking at combos.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wait.
What combo did you learn?
I was just about to tell you.
My, so first of all, I know my auto attacks now do
percentage health damage.
So the combo is get on a wall, F down.
Uh-huh.
Left click, left click.
Q, Q or something.
You slam down.
You press right click, you hit two left clicks, and then you
press alt immediately.
I was close!
See, I told you!
And you said I wasn't practicing!
Yeah, but the right click is the big thing, because if you
right click and your alt pop at the same time, it's a
one-shot, if it's damage-boosted.
My right click slows, right?
It slows, and when it pops, it does damage.
Max HP damage.
Gotcha.
Alright, anyway.
Good shit, dude.
Good shit.
Let's go.
That's how we play.
nine moxie because we're playing i'm trying to figure out
this team wait are we playing a super team right yeah only
team we haven't versed i think okay um well do we they're
playing triple support so should we their weakest players
are support players do we ban rocket i think so yeah we
first ban rocket and then do we want to keep invid do we
want to keep loki or not
because i can run invis luna again do they have a loki
player they do that was a good it worked the last game they
do they have they're running rocket loki invis yeah
their two supports are rocket and their their support
players are rocket loki and invis and they run they're
running okay yeah we could ban that kind of want to know
what everyone else banned versus them
no way dude these guys are so sweaty they private at all
their profiles just just watch their streams i know like
your stream mother fuckers like that
i'll look at i can pull up one of their streams okay they
they what okay they got hot guys strange wolf that was what
the enemy team banned for them
wait does that mean they want hawkaii because yeah but then
we'll see how they play that's good for us if we get hawkaii
hawkaii i'll take it i believe in moxie
dude all of them private in their profiles they want to win
win Yeah, no, they won't really want to win-win.
Yeah, they protect Rocket, by the way.
So we should just first ban Rocket.
Yeah, I agree.
They protect Strange and Rocket.
So we could ban a Strange.
Because Super is good at Strange.
They protect Rocket, Loki.
We could do Loki, Rocket, and strange okay we do rocket then
strange then loki and if they protect adder one we just add
another support in there because they run triple support
yeah zoil play strange that's probably why this is most
played by a lot they always they always protect either loki
or strange so protect rocket and then we can just first ban
rocket and then they would protect loki or strange for the
next one so we just try to follow that should we i'm down
ban the strange and then i'll go moon knight and just try
and farm off the clones we can do that yeah okay yeah we try
strange that's cooking just in like the second easiest
support that they could play because i know like Because
apparently Lydia is the rocket player.
So I assume like she hasn't learned the other supports.
Yeah, I've only seen her really play rocket.
And like there's no really...
The only ease...
Is their profile private?
Um, well, they've been first...
They've been first protecting rocket the entire tournament.
So I just assume it's for her.
Um, and...
And the second easiest support to play is cloak and dagger.
Mag that fully counters Cloak and that fully counters her
because I don't think she would if she never really played
Cloak and Dagger I don't think she would know how to hide
does she play Cloak?
I don't know like that would I would give her the Cloak as
the second play character for her to play because what else
would she play other than Rocket
whoa Moxie is the static from your end oh that might be yeah
I'm holding on for a stock oops oh
and so we're playing Super Yeah.
Wait, who won?
I think they lost.
Yeah, I think so.
Oh yeah, they did.
They lost to Erob.
Tyler won.
Hey, you're not the only team that lost.
We're not the only team that lost to him.
Yeah, Erob's 3-0.
Yeah.
So like super lost to Erob too.
That's not bad.
Yeah, that should be...
That's pretty good feeling.
And we come back too.
you guys have invites yet or no no not not yet i think i
think it's like we're they're waiting to kick someone out of
the lobby
all right guys we have potentially two more games two more
games and we're in or or maybe three more games depending on
how the second game goes Oh, I got invite.
Oh, invite invite.
Yep, I got one, too.
They're all here.
Yeah, I was just waiting for us.
Hey, we're back.
We're in the Tyler one, not.
We're on the right side this time.
What are you missing?
All right, this is the last game of the planes.
Red Robbins.
Round Robbins, yeah.
And then if we lose the next one, we're out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's best of three there.
Oh shit.
It's getting real.
No, it's not it wasn't it's not best of one Yeah, yeah, best
of one.
So so we could yeah, like maybe finals is the best of three
only.
Yeah, yes So we can literally get kicked out right after No,
when money's wrong mindset we could kick another team out.
That's true.
Yeah, yeah, come on I already I already DM'd all the
captains Hawkeye should be good Let's fucking go.
We're all ready, right?
I think so.
Okay.
R.
I wrote R for us.
Yep.
You guys are grandmasters?
How do we ever lose?
Rank just reset.
So, like, most people that are looking at...
Well, we also got two people not placed, you know?
Yeah, yeah, see?
Like, the enemy team has all their teams placed.
But our team has two people running.
play silver maxi i can't throw me in silver nah epic you're
at least gold plow i can get grandmaster in a month by the
way oh you want to bet how much um well you're a millionaire
so money doesn't mean anything
multi-millionaire oh you're right sorry yeah i'm a streamer
whoa why are you pocket watching by the way sorry who's
talking about pocket watching when you're were pulling up my
youtube earlier i was not looking at the view count i was
seeing yo does he actually do this for a living okay but
will you do a solo queue isn't that the view count though
isn't that what you're looking at no like i just want to see
what videos you do more than black ops i thought you are
more than zombie i thought you literally only did zombies
it's like 95 it's pretty heavy it's a pretty heavy ratio
pieces of all of you
pieces of shit that's what we are yeah we're gonna win this
one yeah yeah yeah yeah i believe you're gonna get more than
uh 20 accuracy this time tyler should i i mean what's the
downside of holding like i'm shuddering sorry what is the
downside of holding left click there's no downside why would
i want to miss 100 of the shots you don't take that's true
that's true that's true come on make she do you do the the
the you probably don't do the melee do you like the melee i
don't think he Oh, like, no, no, not your left click.
No, no, no.
Not your left click is not melee.
Yeah, yeah, like the, like, left click melee at the, like,
every time you hit.
Guys, I, I, guys, we're only confusing him more.
He's going to take more.
I'm like, I'm watching.
Gingy, he's just going to start overthinking, guys.
Guys, not five.
We're not overwhelming him.
Let's not.
talking about like he's not here.
He's like right here.
Dude, what the fuck?
First one, first one.
Rocket, right?
First one, rocket, right.
It's their Ben.
Oh no, Tyler, Ben, Rocket!
Tyler, Ben, Rocket!
Tyler!
Rocket, stay down!
Rocket, Amrica, back!
Rocket, slow down, yeah!
Okay.
Okay, Tyler, protect.
Okay, Tyler, protect, okay, we're gonna see what they banned
first.
They're not gonna be in Hawkeye, trust me.
Search bar?
Protect Holokai now.
No, no, no, no.
start looking for hawkaii yeah start looking for hawkaii
it's on the bottom row you tell me where he's at bottom row
bottom row on the dps section he's blonde he's got a purple
mask on his face okay protect your venom okay yeah protect
venom and then oh we're re-banning after that it's not you
yet they've got a wait wait moxie were we next again i
forgot uh strange strange or strange yeah uh protect venom
and then ban strange okay which heroes will get my cosmic
favor today
and then strange yeah nice okay why are we protecting now
we're doing vibes now what's my base protections okay
because like our second protect never usually doesn't matter
we can
protect anything that moxie wants to wants to flex me from
hawkeye what do you want to go bucky then protect bucky
protect bucky yeah dps yeah bucky they banned our top row
top row winter soldier yep oh we're done for they've been
iron fist what do we bend last uh loki loki Loki.
I feel like protect Bucky and then, oh, they protected Loki.
Okay.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Are we doing Moon Knight then?
And then we, yeah, we can do Moon Knight.
And then we, we banned Cloak.
Or Mantis.
They played Mantis as well.
So I think Cloak and Bag are on the support.
All right.
I feel like that would leave one pretty cool.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So because then she will have to play a harder support now.
She might have to play a Jeff.
most likely so I'm gonna switch to moon night yeah you swap
to moon night yeah all right and then we can do we'll do in
this Luna I think in this Luna is stronger than I mean in
this lucky is stronger but I think like we are very good
with in this Luna I wasn't here for when we were going over
like their comp fully Should I go Mag or Gurd?
Mag.
Mag?
Yeah, yeah.
Most likely, Super is going to go Mag.
Bye-bye.
All
right, guys.
If we head into the playoffs, 2-0.
I think 2-0 in a row.
Who's going to stop us?
Yes, sir.
2-0.
We'll be on a hot streak?
Yeah, we're there.
We're more versus the top two teams.
We're versus one of these that we just beat.
Oh, really?
You guys hear mine.
Yeah, the first and second get a buy.
No, we don't shoot.
Oh, thank goodness.
Because he might start, you might start hearing him a
little.
It's all good, bro.
No, I said like the third easiest support that she could
play is Jeff.
All right, so I'm gonna die a lot less this game.
That's why I still, I passed it.
Oh, nice.
Were you messing with it?
Between game?
Yeah, I was.
That's big.
All right, here we go.
Super block?
Oh, they do.
They do.
They have their own teammate blocked.
all you need to do is capture the missionary their low-key
might start like my dps so we gotta be careful oh really
yeah i think it's i think it's sleepy and i know sleepy
likes to thank dps as the key go all right here oh my god i
got it i'm going right i'm going right i'm going right so
that's what this supports i agree oh i can't get it for
speed what are you going to get emma grab yeah I'm trying to
keep you up.
Yeah, I can get on point again, but Emma's kind of bullying
me a little bit.
Yeah, I'm trying my best to keep you up.
Just you.
Yeah, Emma is just like, yeah, thank you.
Yeah, we have to die on point.
I'm going to just die here.
Their comp is super solid.
Yeah, they're running triple support.
Oh, I'm just getting melted, by the way.
Fall back.
We have a bucky out here.
up so easily.
I'm holding back.
I'm shooting punch you with you.
Yeah, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
You just go.
You just go down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're up one.
All right, I'm going in the.
Yeah, we're up one.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Hold on.
Breaking land, breaking land.
Go, kill it.
I got, I got, you got reset.
You got reset.
You got another reset?
Yeah, we should be good.
I'm on Emma.
I got, I can kick down.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma.
Emma one.
I'm shooting.
Okay.
Nice.
No, no, no, no.
Okay.
I'm using my alt for Punisher.
Actually, Mac, you try first for Punisher.
Yeah, I'll try.
It's gonna get Lance out at least.
Yeah, yeah.
And then Luna, you just do for other alts.
Just don't do it for Punisher.
What's Punisher's line?
He comes.
We'll tell you.
Shuri executioner, is that it?
I'll tell him if it's a Punisher.
Okay.
Luna!
Luna's in the left corner!
Oh, that's Punisher, that's Punisher!
That's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I'll see if it's fine.
It's good, it's good.
I got you four-year-old ends, Zephyr.
You're good, though.
I'm bringing Lance to top.
There you go.
Good, good, good.
Can we get in there, maybe?
I clicked, actually, guys.
Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, everyone.
I have Emma and Mag on me.
They're down too, we should.
Yeah, yeah.
Mag one!
Back one.
Heels, I need his back.
That's my hand, sir, sir, sir.
Here's my bubble.
Come on.
Heels in the back.
I'm trying to, sorry.
I'm trying to keep...
I need heels.
Right side.
I'm trying to keep Tyler up right now.
Yeah, okay.
No problem.
Oh, where's Tyler?
What do you mean?
What are you saying?
Where did you go?
I just want to get out.
I was for help.
I'm still needed.
dying here punch your movie diner he's one no help back no
we're still down uh venom and and invis so just chill for a
little bit yeah yeah we you guys can go up you guys have no
damage again
soon yeah we can walk up we can walk up yeah walk up walk up
if you need have no old care how am i gonna get killed
by Emma probably.
Nice good deals, good deals.
I'm boring.
On this side.
I can, I can, I can.
I'm about to keep, I'm about to keep him off.
One HP on another?
Nice.
Oh, I couldn't get them.
It's okay.
We have their hands on our side.
Loki's on our side.
One week.
Oh, what?
This fucking Isaac guy, this stupid shot.
Nice, nice.
He's pushing me.
I'm probably dead.
Use the snowflake on yourself.
You have to.
Nice, nice.
Epic just coming.
Oh, nice.
You're him.
Beautiful.
I have alt still.
Yeah, I have 90.
Yeah I'm over 20.
I'm on top.
Yeah, you guys just, supports just stare at me a little bit.
I mean, you are.
You guys did amazing there.
Emma is just trying to like bully me.
Emma, we can smoke.
Wait, so chill, chill, chill.
Tyler, if you can, just go on the back line, sports.
Break Punisher area on top.
Yeah, I'm pretty good.
I'm already good.
I'm old guy.
No, I got it.
I got it.
I got it for you.
Our support team did.
We got away.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You have to come back up.
Come back up through here.
Right side, right side.
And Luna, Luna, Luna.
Nice, nice, nice.
You have to come back up as soon as you can.
That's a good skill.
That's good.
Luna, if you can hold this?
Yeah.
Go the guy in the right.
I fell down.
Hi.
No, no, no.
Come up, come up, come up, come up, come up, come up.
You can come up, come up now.
Come up now.
Nice!
Let's go!
We need that too, Lily.
No, no, it doesn't.
It doesn't.
That's why it's like come up now.
Yeah, I get cons.
Go.
Wait, can you use what was the come up?
I wasn't that.
Oh, our Luna fell in the hole.
And I'm sure if my old, like, field if you're above.
Yeah, no, it doesn't.
That's why it's like, come up.
Cut it out of that hole.
Perfect.
Let's go.
I have all.
It's the cons I need.
Yeah, epic.
What your rivals are, dude?
I'll get them the all.
What's the rivals?
I don't know, bro.
You gotta, you gotta be ready, bro.
they do this one more time i need you to be they're gonna
keep doing this bro it's because i got two i got two days
notice bro how long did you guys get i know they literally
recruited when super announced it invited though probably
like two days like literally two days yeah yeah so i got
like a day or two of practice that's big yeah
i don't know what ults they have i think they have maga they
did use punisher right probably do yeah they did use
punisher they have their support ults for sure They didn't
use any of this.
Let's just try to focus their supports for Tyler's ult.
We might go to kill.
Yep.
I might engage with Tyler's ult then.
When I ult and they pop Mag ult, I'll try to hit a clone.
We just try to break lamp and kill the clone.
Okay.
I will.
I'm trying to break that too.
Oh my god.
We need help.
Yeah.
On the side.
Oh, we got a reset.
We got a reset.
I'm salted.
I can't reset.
I can't.
I got it.
and come back for he's going back there's an adam charrette
okay so they have adam flanking now yeah yeah yeah so adam
is gonna be flanking i was worried okay that's fine uh he
was doing the damage that he has infinite heals kind of
fight him from with our team bravo yeah yeah because he's so
tough you're like Disparikable one against.MPi pet bro.
Oh you're so good, good job.
I mess up the backland.
Emma, everyone, Emma, Emma.
She's 1, she's 1.
I don't want, I resources.
Emma, I'm all, Emma, Emma, I'm all.
Yeah, I have all, I have all, so you can't do it.
We're going to take a lot of damage Tyler in a second.
Nice hold, nice hold.
No, no, no, no, no, push up, push up, push up, push up to go
up!
They're going up friends, they're going weak.
Go weak, I'm weak, go weak.
Good point.
I'm weak.
Hola, Emma, Emma.
Baptista.
Luna turn left.
Nice.
They didn't use Adam ult, so they still have it.
Yeah.
They're Adam on the right.
I think it's because they saw you.
So they got skin.
That was really good.
I don't know how he got ult so fast.
They're Punisher.
Oh, because he killed people.
Yeah.
I can push back.
That Punisher turns horrible.
I'm trying to take some damage for you guys without taking
too much.
It's a lot of you.
I'm going to let you heal a little bit.
I'm letting you heal.
Tag going right or right side not that healthy Wait, can we
jump the mug can we jump the item one Adam has no more
heals.
He's weak He held it nice.
Nice.
Oh
Come back, Alexi.
Oh, there's a little little little Tyler.
I'm shooting it.
Got to go for lunatology.
You kill that you kill that Oh, I could just die on point.
You have to
Yeah, just die on point.
I'm out.
Nice.
That's not bad.
up keep going they stop adam up yeah they do 100 we just
have follow them a little bit or try to keep track and
they're gonna have mag out here they're gonna have soul bond
for their punish world as well most likely so i probably
will not be able to kill him that's fine we still have my
ult too for it okay i have ult too yeah tell me where to go
you can go now you can go now you They're really grouped up
too.
Back out.
I'm going.
Nice.
All right.
Go pun, pun, pun, pun, if we can.
He's so low.
I have to jump out.
He doesn't know where I am.
He got, he can't get it.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, push up, push up, push
up.
Left side, left side, left side.
Yeah.
Go straight to point, go straight to point.
Yeah, I'm on, I'm on.
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
I'll be red.
They have, it's not, there's not.
Punisher, Punisher, Punisher, Punisher!
Punisher, Punisher, I got a reset, you got a reset.
I got a reset, I got a reset.
No, no, no, you're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
I got you.
I don't know if I can get your reset for you.
Invis, Invis, one.
We got another repus.
We need to come, we need to come.
I'm on it, I'm on the point, I'm on the point, I'm on the
point, but I need help.
I have a Punisher on, I have a mag on me.
We're good, we're good, we're good, everyone.
All right.
Oh, we should have left them.
That's fine.
Emma's free side.
Be careful, care, care, care.
She's going to be there really early, guys.
You can come back to us if you need to, if you think you're
gonna fight her up there.
I'm with you, though.
Are you on main?
They're going main.
They're on main, they're on main.
Oh, ironman up top!
What the heck?
Ironman up.
Iron weak, iron weak.
Nice.
That's huge, bro.
That's so big.
They have no damage.
No more support.
They're going to be shooting, Leave.
They're shooting.
They're backline.
Yeah, I'm like I'm.
The one.
The one?
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
Good kill, girl.
Only backline.
They're Adams, Adam.
Adam theCUBE in my heal area.
But they might not, come back.
Mama, everyone Mag.
Oh, no.
Never mind.
No, man, they're like...
They sold out as well, this is good.
I'm pulling.
They might not even touch.
Yo, come back, Mag, Mag, Mag.
Push them out.
Push them away.
Need heals, need heals?
I got it.
For us.
Fun.
No, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, we double support.
Punisher punisher, everyone punish.
Oh.
Kneel.
TP waffle if you can.
Uh, strange or...
Yep, you're strange.
Oh no.
I can't find him in the list, where is he?
He's in the front, he's in the front.
Oh, he's banned.
We banned him, yeah.
Oh, we did fucking ban him.
No, not the double support at all.
That's so sad.
I could have literally bolted into potentially, but I just
saved for fun.
That's all good.
Yeah, we have early start here too.
funnel uh and they're gonna have soul bomb for it so i don't
be able to kill it i'm about to have alt as well yeah i can
just use it as soon as as soon as possible right i said did
you like not hear me when i said i got it or like okay um
next time if we both have support up um and it's like final
fight i go first i got it's fine we literally still win this
i mean that was one of us
if we use our ice powers together we can i was unfortunate i
said i first me first and then he altered right after i push
put my all out too that's okay i like that i think yes this
works i mean i don't know i don't know i think actually i
mean i'm gonna end up holding for a pun right now and we
could but they're gonna break it too i'll let you all first
i think it's like you play more on reflex so it might be
easier for you just talk just talk about it yeah while we're
I'll just let you off.
It was a good old.
It just was both of them.
He doesn't want to walk forward or go, we can go for it.
I have to reload.
Oh, that's unlucky.
The punch returns one.
I got the three mega near us.
Okay, time.
We're backing out?
Yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Go for it, go for it, go for it.
We're up one, one, one, one.
Watch out.
Yeah.
Slowly, slowly.
Yeah, I'm not going too fast.
I will hear her.
Inside, break till.
I'm gonna use it all here.
Go, go, go, go, push up with this.
Push up with this.
Yeah, yeah.
Invis, Invis, everyone, nice big.
Luna, Luna one, Luna one.
Okay, no more, no more, no more.
No more, no more, no more .
No more.
Oh yeah.
Let me build off of them.
That was really good.
Nice.
They used so much there.
They used, uh...
Oh world.
Only let Doki heal.
If you're going to flake someone, flake me.
If you break the map or not, I mean, it's fine if we don't.
Have a...
I'm going to play up here for a hook.
I'll wall them if you do.
No, no, no.
Help me.
Yel, yel, yel, yel, yel, yel.
Okay, we're okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, the mag's burst!
Yeah, Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag.
I pushed him by- I pulled him back!
I pulled him back!
Nice, they used to, I mean, that's good.
No, we're good.
That was good.
Tyler, are you good?
Are you good, Tyler?
Oh, no.
I can bubble you.
I can bubble someone.
Oh, boy, Luna.
Bubble Luna.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
This is fine.
We got our bubble.
Mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag.
Mag, mag, mag.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, me.
I pulled the Punisher back.
Nice, guys.
Well done, bro.
All right.
You can, I'll let you build alt.
I'll make me build salt for alt.
Yeah, this is good.
This is really good.
We they have Adam all here.
They do have Adam all um They're on we've nothing.
They're on two dps now.
They're on two dps when they add him We just got to play
slow.
No, no.
They're off Adam.
Okay, huge huge.
I still for fun Then they don't have soul bond.
This is way better.
I've been killing them too.
I'll let you kill Are you killed?
Oh, I pulled them back.
Oh, it's fine.
I did bubble myself earlier.
They is Fuck you pull I'm trying to body block him.
I can't get in the back there Yeah, it's a tough map Yeah, I
hate those map I got We're back my bad predator first one
Nice nice usual Just try to live to live Under under you
under your brothel Mag mag mag mag mag mag mag mag mag mag
mag i got mag nice i need heals give me me heals Thank you
They're not Portland you're not Portland i'm playing But
yeah, there's no strange no strange Oh,
I actually told him to ban Hawkeye so we could test out our
friends in this last game.
That's so smart.
I'm freaking out.
We're both fucking bragging, aren't we?
Let's go.
Come on.
Double digit thousand damage, Tyler.
That's how we play.
Oh my god, you pressed a four digits.
Oh, I told you guys I was cooking.
was cooking bro you could feel it let's go bro i saw you on
that first round i couldn't and he got over 20 accuracy wait
wait the supports got more final hits though uh-oh no one
goes off final hits in this game to decide you did well
that's not oh that's true moxie no one goes off final hits
moxie you're not as good i mean i go off how many against he
had he had a lot and tyler had a bunch of stuff happening so
i feel like that's a good game yeah yeah yeah that's good
we're getting better yeah yeah that's for sure every game
learning a little more yeah now now we can your arc's coming
i'm feeling good bro yeah we learned not to double support
all in the the round robin and for me to learn you know
exactly exactly
yeah more than one win now i don't care what you get
eliminated
now epic you play a lot of fortnite right yeah fortnite so
you're that guy on fortnite yeah i'm all right you know he's
got like uh one of the most winningest players in the game
thank you bro thank you bro damn i'm saying a little game
time on this a couple weeks of grind you would literally be
the best support i'd be i'd be too crazy if i had some time
but you'd be one above it's also like it's hard to like
practice even for these to have attorneys because like i
literally i'm not even high enough level to play rank so i'm
just playing like all i can do is play pubs bro just warming
up your aim and pubs you're one level away you're one level
who was uh who was helping you oh you're actually i'm like
tired now he's asking me if i know him i don't know them
watch him and quant uh quanti okay oh you're a little 15 now
like oh did i hit you are a little 15 you're about to be
your level uh you're about to be ranking next year when they
run another we'll see oh yeah you're uninstalling after this
tournament is that what no comment no comment he needs room
on the pc bro the more apps installed the worse his fortnite
game is it's a great game but i just don't i don't play any
other games to be honest i mean it makes sense that's yeah
it's valid and what are games do you play i just i play
fortnite like competitively so oh yeah just for tonight yeah
that's a full time that's a full-timber builder no build
yeah pc builds oh so you're like building hotels and stuff
yeah yeah that's me i'm like the sweat that like ruined the
game he's the guy that everyone hates yeah do you do the
condom skin too yeah I'm saying, but these last two wins are
massive.
Wait, no, we could win.
We're fourth place.
Sorry.
What is that?
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
That doesn't matter right now.
I think first and second got to buy.
Yep.
So that means we are the second best team left.
So we're versing the fifth place team.
Yeah, yeah.
Right below us.
Wait, who's the fifth place?
What is their record?
We just beat, I think.
We're up against them again.
No, it's not Super Steam.
Super Steam is with us.
He's two, three.
So it's either...
Oh, yeah, but we have tiebreaker.
you beat them oh oh wait a minute we should play again right
i think we should yeah we just run it back no wait no don't
we play no we play the fifth or sixth place team because the
first second get by third place place six we play fifth we
play fifth so who's the fifth super it is super oh yeah i
think it's super flats is last his one of he they went like
one of five or something be it are the only teams that are
below us oh uh so yeah i mean we just one of them i think we
just are running it back with uh if flats is definitely last
then we're definitely playing yeah so we're playing super
again and we just keep the same calm bear in mind it's not
gonna be domination anymore so wait it's not domination no i
i don't believe so i could be wrong when i was reading the
rules it not yeah yeah is there like any changes we should
make to i don't know is there like tech that we can put down
while we're waiting i don't know put some petty mines down
or something i don't know you need some kidnaps but i'm not
that good at kidnapping a strange okay if we could i think
penny would be great Yeah.
I don't have a penny in my bag either.
Well.
Like one of the only tanks I don't play.
Tyler probably can just pick it up.
No, no.
Remember what we said?
We could probably pick up rocket.
No, no, no.
We know what.
You didn't pick up rocket.
It just didn't go well.
You picked it up though.
No, it did great, Tyler.
It did great.
It's just your venom.
It did go good.
I was three, five thousand healing.
Yeah.
It was just your venom.
It's just leagues above everything else.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Wow.
He likes that.
it's okay guys i believe it's no way xc's ask i'm fucking
first place really big shit we should actually wasn't that
the game we actually probably yeah was the close yeah i mean
this is we're figuring it out everyone's improving we're
evolving as we go yeah this is uh great we were testing out
comps too so like now we're gonna ban bucky said it that's
good then we he doesn't know about the hawk guy oh the what
the hawk guy the the bucky the hell yeah good our bucky and
hello sorry i always get confused they don't know about the
hell i can't wait to hell of this game and win this game
yeah with our hell because also then i'll go hella as well
we'll have two hellos
It's the forbidden tech.
It's going to go crazy.
They do that in pros, in pro scrims.
Yep.
They actually go five, five Heller.
One support.
Rocket.
Yeah.
Rocket's on.
Oh, this might be a little break, isn't it?
We might have a little break here.
How long is there another team?
Is there another team playing right now?
Because they might be playing the third place and the second
place team.
I think it goes on simultaneously, doesn't it?
Oh, really?
But they really?
make us watch guys I'm guys this is gonna they said the
tournament it's gonna be a long tournament I don't want to
watch so it's a one-day thing but so this next round is just
like we just play one yeah but it's wait wait wait I just
heard something crazy could be he could be leaking on
purpose I just went to super stream because he's literally
the person who's hosting the attorney right so I think
that's a fair stream snipe like i'm watching i got it open
too right he said if strange gets banned he thinks he uh i
think he said he's strange goes van he goes wolverine and
goes sicko i don't know if going sicko is this could be bait
too i don't know what going sicko means i think we wolf diff
him if that is the case yeah and i can play invis and i
could just yeah i think it's fine if he goes true i also
think it's fine if he goes well it would be good my
support's got my back dude i don't mind yeah yeah trust us
trust us to trust you is wolf mainly is he just like gonna
focus on tanks or focus on he's gonna be on my head the
entire game brother he'll be on me tanks tank tank tank tank
it's miserable okay him with angela so we end up playing
that team again yeah i mean if we end up if we do end up
playing that team again i think we just banned support to be
able to force luna invis and then like uh bogers team so
they can't play that if we play like a bad map wait so i
don't remember what were bands were against against them
yeah yeah i
Yeah, because, like, they put Lydia on Sue, and I think she
was confused, because I saw her healing, and it was, like,
10K, 15K for Sue, and that's, like, really low.
So, I think that's fine.
There's good bands, good bands.
Yeah.
Yeah, so Rocket Fuzz, Strange Second.
We did get to focus her a lot.
Like, a lot of the time when their ults were done, she would
be, like, running backwards, and it was just free kills.
So, I agree.
I mean, keeping her off Rock, it's probably good.
She can't just, like, sit in the back.
to care really care about a low-key band because when they
had loki like it didn't really do much for it because we had
bucky yeah and moon night and moon night so like so the next
we could just we can do the cloak then we still do cloak so
it would be like rocket strange cloak again
gotcha then they have a wolf guaranteed but we're we're
prepared for that
what would be better on if if the wolf is annoying which it
sounds like we'll have it shut down anyway but would it be
better for me to be on namor or should i stick on the moon
knight uh i'm equally happy with like each of them i would
say i think moon knight's more like i could be right he's
more like raw damage and usually against a wolf that's
running in like if you just blow him up especially in a game
like this where like people aren't always that great like if
he walks too far forward and his tanks aren't covering him
at all like you could just burn his passive and then kill
him so the Wolverine like yeah like if he's frontlining like
the the what was it was it two units flat steam they had a
wolf and we like insta burned his passive because he's way
too far up and then because he missed his grab and then we
killed him first it is just like i'd imagine him to be i'm
just processing info i'm letting them probably but it's not
always the wolf sometimes like if your tank doesn't help you
uh it can totally it's entirely on your tanks and how well
you're supposed to look at you and stuff it's just like he
gets it like every I don't know if it's like 60 or 80 like
minute and a half like uh-huh um and the first time you like
kill him like you finish his health he gets like half uh
blue health and then he's killable and that passive is gone
for like it'll be gone for like the next fight as well so
burning his passive is is massive it's like the biggest
thing so if he's in a bad spot just if he's in a weird spot
he's your like you should shoot him every time because if we
burn his passive he has to play so safe okay easy life super
squishy then from that yeah I mean he's a normal DPS who's
walking like he's yeah and plus if we have if they do it
because we're gonna man strange if they have they have four
of our invis is gonna just i think take care of him
completely okay nice nice
this is my nerd you guys remember this is my nerds imagine
imagine it went what happened what they had the adam at one
point i feel like and then imagine what my team yeah he
altered and I think we won the fight after it's all, which
is, like, the world's got to be, like, the worst feeling on
Adam's side.
Hello?
Oh.
Hello.
You guys are going to be up first.
Super's doing a little breakdown with Uber and Mr. X right
now, but you guys will be the first match.
We're going to do this round one at a time, and we're
switching to Convoy instead of Domination.
So you guys are first up in probably about five minutes.
All right, bro.
Sounds good.
Let's get your boy home.
I'm just, hey, we're just going to let you know.
He's going home, baby.
he's going home but you know he's full-time casting he's
yeah this game i'm on the desk what can i say yep all right
thank you very much loser gets kicked off to this game and
then winner waits while the other team plays yeah yeah okay
okay cool and we win this that's uh so we win and then we
have a little little breaky break yeah okay but he said it's
a convoy what's that that's like the push the cart the cart
okay so it's a completely different play style.
Yes.
Yeah.
I think we'll be better at that, to be honest.
No, actually, we had this problem last time where we were
playing normal before and then playoffs started and we
fucking lost that first thing in the driveway and it wasn't.
No, it's because you were on Hulk, Tyler.
It has nothing to do.
Tyler, it's because you were, I remember you're Hulk, Tyler.
You didn't sit down at the time.
You didn't, you didn't have the nerve to say it then.
Now you're saying that a year later.
Yeah, yeah, you know this is the second time you know it's
not first impressions anymore she's right she's right you've
learned you've learned but we learned from it as long as we
keep protecting that yeah yeah yeah yeah first that's not
yeah and if they ban venom we still have fruit we still have
so so i could still go in on the back line on car yeah yes
on offense you're gonna be like it's super good still so i
mean
How'd you be doing the thing last game?
I used that strat in other tournaments now because of it.
What happened to Tyler?
I used it.
I learned.
Even at like running away, I was climbing.
Oh yeah.
That's big.
That'll keep you up.
That's the wave.
This guy knows tech.
Shots for shit.
Let's go.
We got this.
I believe.
And it would.
I'd never forget.
We never let it happen again.
never again
imagine if we're they give us midtown to that same map oh
it's Tokyo Tokyo okay that's fine
wonder if they get triple support again
definitely might i don't know Yeah, let's see if he goes DPS
because he did go.
He did swap to Bucky at the end, but I think he waited.
It was too late when he made the swap Yeah, yeah, yeah
I'm just glad it's not midtown Is that the map that like
transforms Tokyo?
Yeah, no, it's a spider in the front gate Oh, like the
little spider walking forward and then the spider-man will
try to pull you out.
Oh, that map.
Oh, yeah Yeah, we are.
R.
Here we go, baby.
Now the pressure's on!
Yes!
Finally!
Something to play for.
Fuck yeah.
Come on!
It means something now.
Let's go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now we try.
Now we pull up the actual 150%, right?
Yep.
Okay, wait.
So, so is payload just just one map?
That's it?
Yeah.
One push?
pushes the furthest because oh my god send these guys home
in five minutes guys let's go we could take we maybe we'll
hold them and then we have an easy push or they full hell
less offense or or defense we are attack we're attack yeah
offense so is i or they fall guitar you are leader though we
got it you gotta lock in on these bands here yeah we could
ask them to swap leaders can we do that it's all good it's
all good i got it yeah okay okay i believe in our bands are
rocket strange cloak yeah so rocket first and if they don't
ban hawkeye then we protect hawkeye yeah yeah we do give me
dead hawkeye well not me
we're just waiting for super to be ready yeah all right this
might be our last game or a second last game and then I
disassociate for two I miss it and I either I push God of
War to tomorrow or I disassociate for an hour and a half
come on bro we're just gonna get we'll see how it goes they
shivering terrified
oh shit no I don't want to play God of War for just two
hours That's the thing.
Because, like, it's a fucking long-ass game.
So I want to play that.
I want to get as much progress done as possible.
Because, like, every time I don't play God of War, I forget
the controls.
And I need this, like, ingrained in my head.
Because, like, I still have, like, 15 more hours of God of
War left.
We'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
Alright.
I'm still...
We'll see.
We'll see how this game goes.
Because right now, I'm, like, okay.
Well, okay is a...
very broad term.
Okay, it's a really broad term to be fair.
We're starting up.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Come on.
Come on, man.
Let's go.
Money's on the line, guys.
Big money.
Yes.
Big bucks.
All right.
all right which hero do you think you want to be today i can
see now yep
start with ben first battle rocket rocket dokey dokey on
mute dokey dokey hello rocket ben right right you rocket
yeah rocket yeah rocket man
nice i think i just like that's what we are doing like i'm
like a double confirmation for no hawkeye ban oh and then
protect hawkeye protect hawkeye oh they protected strange
interesting protect hawkeye yeah and then we ban cloak and
dagger right yep yeah we wouldn't band strange there so
who's me our third band we need to figure that out um what
are support they were playing they're playing luna well
invis i actually don't know what a third band should be we
could just do another matt we could do bad mantis or a jeff
band oh they banned the venom so your group protect group
protect group yeah
So at least, well, they run two tanks.
Uh oh.
Yeah, they did.
It's okay.
You still have your Groot.
Yes.
I do have my group.
Okay.
So we're going to protect Groot here.
We're after you guys.
Third Ben.
We could.
I feel like they're going to force around Mantis and run the
team up.
Then do Mantis.
Maybe a bad Mantis.
Yeah.
Mantis.
okay I like that I think they meant your buck you were
actually we're dead I'm gonna say it they gave you Hawkeye
over me venom by the way bro just saying I know I know
that's our there's levels yeah or they're just scared of you
Tyler yeah I told you it's I'm fucking annoying back there
I'm not kidding oh that's weird I don't like that actually
hmm but I also don't care I can play What do we want?
I mean, I can play anyone pretty much anyone.
Can you do Strange?
Emma's all right too.
Would you rather have Strange over Emma?
Actually, Emma would be better, right?
I think I'd bully the Strange and he ults no one.
We're attack side first as well.
Yeah, I'm well then.
I hope this man has not played like Strange for 100 hours in
the new season already because I have not really seen much.
No, he definitely hasn't.
He definitely has not.
Tyler, I need you to scream when you ult, okay?
If he flies over my head and I can't grab him in time.
Because my ult is like what?
It's like...
you do it because when you all everyone gets like like
combined into the all so it sucks all right yeah yeah yeah
yeah try to come up together you just you you got it rob you
if you see that old go down don't even hesitate even if you
yeah you miss then then not throw because well i think yeah
i don't yeah i think it might be hard to time of like uh all
combos here so just just vibe it just try and react yeah
yeah raffle if you can't also shoot shoot the clones like
yep yep they're gonna have strange uh tyler so try to get a
weird angle when you all or else you're gonna throw it right
into their big shield i'm sorry i got it i believe i'll just
give you comes up the whole time i don't think they have a
spider-man player so i'm not no fear yeah i did the turd
we're all where are they have hawk guy wait they have a hawk
guy I don't know, but I saw it.
Oh, it's a trap.
Try to hide that, hide that big wall now, because then they
can't grab you.
What?
Like, that big wall, if you're standing in a vicinity of it,
like they can't grab you.
Oh, sorry.
Grab him.
Come on.
Get the team.
Get the wall.
Good wall.
Oh, I'm all sitting.
Fine, fine.
Good back at the end.
Going up top.
Putting that shield in front of the Hawkeye.
Kill him.
Oh, Ty, push up, push up, push up.
I'll kill you.
I'll heal you.
Thank you.
Good deals.
Follow us.
Nice shot, bro.
We're down to the round two.
Emma's in a bad spot.
You're on three.
No, three.
No, three on card.
I'm on card.
Strange left side.
I pushed.
I pulled him back.
Nice.
We can have TP because he died last.
Yeah, we're good.
Beautifully played.
Okay, they're they're well before they're not a little
before so I need you to be ready with the pulls Yeah, I'll
keep my payload guys.
Careful.
Okay.
Yeah, keep them for fun.
I'm gonna save it Do they have anything they don't have
anything?
No, no, they don't they don't should I use it for Hawkeye or
should I just go you just go Just rip it so we have no no
passive.
Yeah, just rip it so we have an early kill Oh, I'm cancel I
got frozen.
I got frozen.
That's why that's my bad You guys are way up there by the
way Help me help me I'm helping I'm helping you.
I got you I got you.
I got you.
Dude, you're insane, bro.
Yeah, keep him up and we just win the whole game because
he's killed like three of them in the last two seconds.
Yeah, I gave him a...
It's fine.
Yeah, there's a...
There's a Luna left.
Luna left.
Pull her.
Pull her poor.
I couldn't see her.
Fine, fine, fine.
I'm just...
I'll pocket you, Moxie.
Airport.
Invis pushes, guys.
Grab them, grab.
That's fine.
You're fine.
I'm shooting him.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm putting a shield in front of you.
I'm going to ult this.
Let me change.
Let me keep you up.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's fine.
Push up.
Push up with it.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Luna up top.
Nice.
Good shot, bro.
What is this?
What do you want?
Let me know.
Let me get these clones.
Okay.
We're good.
Oh my god.
Perfect.
Oh, we don't have the combo.
It's fine.
I'm all against like a cancel.
just rip it okay that's all you get i i've legit just been
on on load okay i have all yeah that's good that's good i'm
all things oh i got knocked back can you are you here moxie
can you catch up someone i don't have push by the way uh yep
i'm here in this in this in this on the right on the right
yeah it's fine i'm looking at what we're gonna blow oh i
wasn't grab me.
It's all good.
We're reset.
We're done too.
Just walk back.
Walk back.
Kite out.
I'm going to die here.
This isn't you.
Just reset here.
We still have loads of time.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
We lost one fight.
We're fine.
Yeah.
And they had to use like three alts here.
You guys are going to have combo here.
I should be okay.
I'm not.
That's so annoying.
He was so far.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm going to push up with this.
I'm going to the left.
Can you play?
me flick me a different look this he has strange up by the
way i'm gonna keep my push up oh wait strange one strange
one nice nice nice i'm gonna be in the back keep walking
nice nice nice someone up right mox here you just go yeah
i'm just going oh my god i hate this oh i'm frozen oh i'm
playing a little down for the wolf just keep an eye he's
weak he's weak I don't know if he's passing around.
I have all.
Wolf top left.
Change, change, change, change.
Above, above.
Look at him.
I'm not.
That's fine.
Nice, nice.
Push up, push up.
Push up.
You can.
I'm about to go.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm trying to heal you.
I'm trying to get him to.
Go.
Okay.
Yeah.
Off me.
Fucking eight.
Yeah.
He's a nice guy.
Nice.
Let's go.
huge as they see now he's a fan boy he's just running at me
i'll just hit the game yes right you see this raising garlic
free that's super oh yeah he's a fan that's for sure by the
way oh well played yeah are we changing anything on no no
it's good even like moon night is good on defense that was
perfect yeah I Believe in us guys guys, I believe so hard
right now.
No, no, no hype up already happened.
Oh Keep the hype going.
I'm feeling I'm dying now Yeah, help us lock in.
No, we're already locked in.
I'm safe there
It's a cool down
oh all right so where's that spot to stand here here here
right right here like here here you just stand here so i'll
break the break the break the walls on the right yeah okay
uh you can put your wall i'm trying to you can put your wall
here like look left like against this like sideways so they
can't break it and then you just play on it you can't pull
your in uh you're like or anything you can't be like moved
like emma can't even grab you yeah you see there's like an
orange circle on the floor yeah you kind of want to hide it
no more last side cap okay i can maybe confess them i'm my
dab dead i got name worried i actually didn't even know
where he hit me from what the fuck the hawk guys in our back
line i got you i got you name a week name of one name of one
in that corridor you know yes oh no we have the full reset
as my bed i even see the name more running back i'm holding
them i got you i got you yeah run to the left the left no no
no oh good fight keep on the right far far far that's fine
keep running keep running to don't stop grinning oh he
stopped they pulled me in they pulled me in earlier you're
good that's why we have one more fight but without our lunah
though i can sprint back to you guys all right Namor is on
the top head.
Namor is on cartel.
Yeah.
Can't have a Namor.
I'm going up.
Nice.
We kill.
Not there yet though.
I can.
Someone touch someone.
Someone like off on here I guess.
I can.
Someone touch someone touch someone touch someone touch
someone touch again.
Oh, it's fine.
It's okay.
Yeah, I'm just gonna die here.
We just got die.
Pull die.
Oh wait.
Gambit's open?
I'll go Gambit.
I have ult.
You could.
They might swap back wolf if you do.
But you could.
I'll, I'll, I'll up first so then I can swap the gambit.
Go.
So let me ult first.
I'm going to use aggressively.
Yeah, can we play in the building?
Like on the left.
Okay, are you guys ready?
I'm going to go in.
Okay.
here i'm using it aggressively yep go go go go go go strange
stranger grabbing me in the old nice they didn't know for
that they didn't they didn't use anything did not okay are
we just using i'm just gonna i'll swap when i die i could
use mine first i guess yeah i guess for only use your oh god
they got a lot strange hawkeye we do when you're getting
ready uh strange little do we just lose if they gambit all
we have we have a little we just have to stay with should we
just lose like because they have a lot of them yeah yeah
beautiful beautiful tyler that was beautiful dude literally
perfect yeah i'm hoping i'm with you i think yeah i didn't
know you grinded this game yeah i'm on emma i got you i'm
emma hello look at that counter I'm not stupid.
I hear the sound.
No, that was the best counter.
No, that was insane.
That was insane.
Okay, they're gonna have strange old.
I'm gonna look for it.
Like, I'm gonna try to grab.
And then they also definitely have Namor and I think
Hawkeye.
So, yeah, they're just gonna.
Strange half, strange half.
Nice.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead on top.
You're good.
Watch out, strange.
I pushed him by the way.
I pushed him away.
I'm dead here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're down three.
I'm going to use this aggressively again.
I'm done.
Yeah, that was good.
That was really good.
You should probably.
Like, they're off gambit.
Oh, okay.
I don't need a swap gambit.
I don't want to swap there.
No, you don't.
This is better for us.
If you can...
You're on the floor, right?
There's a...
Watch out, watch out, raffle.
There's a guy in my pink.
Yeah.
I'm pushing.
Are you ready?
I'm going to push in aggressively here.
Wait, wait, wait for me.
Wait for me.
I can emmol from up top here probably as well.
I'm right at three.
I can even force...
i can be forced there all first oh i'm getting pushed it's
fine i'll do this here get the gamma all right i'm not i'll
do them i'm flying here i'm at this is winnable we can oh
name behind cap never miss i have hawk on this i've there is
a name or behind us
i'm actually going to tb back yeah you should i'm dying on
the card yeah i need a lot of He was there.
Anyone done?
Any of them done?
No, no, no, no.
We only got like...
We got Moon Knight out of TP.
Group Moon Knight out of TP immediately.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's going on them in three, two, one.
It's open.
Go, go, go.
Go, go.
Do both ults.
As soon as you get scammed.
Go, go, go.
Deal your ult.
Kill your ult.
Kill your Luna.
You should ult.
Oh, nice.
Follow it up.
Everyone go.
Push, push, push.
Those guys hit.
There's a Neymar behind us.
and try to look at him.
Look at him.
I got a shield in front of you.
All right,
just, yeah, live here.
Just live here.
I'm my old stead here.
Oh, no.
No, no, no.
Oh, no, everyone.
Oh, everyone, just give, just give.
I thought we would get out on the jump pack.
Jump pack and get all the way around.
We easily know this is the hardest point by a mile.
It's just, um, careful.
Nice guys, nice.
They're like that.
Push, that push.
Yeah, we're up.
We're up.
We're up, we're up, we're up one.
One, one, one, one.
I died.
Oh, you're right.
I met.
Yeah.
I need us.
I got you.
Oh, I fell off the map.
Namer's coming over here.
Namer, Namer, Namer, Namer.
Yeah, yep.
Yeah, I'm down.
Everyone in here.
Kill them, kill them.
They're coming for you.
Yeah.
I can't help you there.
Are you gonna peek me?
I can, maybe.
That's yours.
Yeah.
I have to reload.
I got you.
That was good.
I'm em ulting right away.
Okay.
I pushed him away, but...
A lot in this.
Hawkeye dead.
The whole team's in this.
I'm good.
I'm okay.
I got you, Tyler.
I got you.
Namer up left.
I'm in it.
I killed Namer.
Their supports are not here.
He killed them.
Kill the tank.
Yeah, yeah.
Emma low.
I think it's fine.
That's fine.
I need heals.
We're good.
Emma probably is ult.
I still need heals.
I need heals.
I have all.
Let me know.
Bro, you fucking die.
Use your all here.
Use your all.
Oh.
It's fine.
I'm dying on card.
I killed their Hawkeye.
Yeah, move.
We just, we have our team to come back.
Ruffle, Ruffle, you got to touch.
Ruffle, you got to touch.
Oh, I already turned around.
Alt it, alt it, alt it, alt it.
Nice.
I have ammo on.
I'm coming out with it.
I'm open.
Nice.
Run him down.
I have ammo.
I'm coming back.
We win this.
Look at Ironman.
That's a weird spot for him.
I did not realize he was there.
That was a battle for me.
I have Ironman on me.
Oh.
Oh, oh, walk back, walk back.
Uh, epic.
Just chill, just chill.
Cut it out, cut out.
Cause we got closer spawn.
We got closer spawn.
We just got- Emma's dead.
There Emma's dead.
No bubble anymore.
Can't fight.
No more.
You have to touch.
Everyone in.
I'm trying to touch it.
I was on.
Just water yourself out if you can.
Ah, I could try.
Alright, that was good.
We just held them to- We have three and a half minutes and
they have nothing.
Ah!
I kept dying, I got everything.
I'm sorry, that was so frustrating because I was like, oh
no, oh no, but it was so much hesitation, but I need to
remember he's new.
I need to remember he's new.
We have four minutes and 19 seconds to push, and they have
one minute.
We do that again, basically, but like, same exact thing.
We gotta like shake it off.
He is new at the game.
I was not sure if we were just getting smoked or what.
Cause I feel like we smoked them, and then I was like, I was
like, why haven't we won or anything?
Like, I feel like we're doing way better than they did.
No, we definitely are.
Yeah, no, we did, we did, yeah.
and i called it out super early before emma had him that's a
thing my old there was really bad that's why i knew i was
coming around the corner and their whole team was already
backed up and iron man was like he just went beyond the wall
and i just kind of wasted it am i fine that just standing in
the front thing like yeah i don't know what was to be doing
on defense by the way we were supposed to just um you have
to use the cover from the buildings here this building so
use the cover from this building oh i don't know your shift
wall should just go behind like like you can focus their
backline a lot with the with the shift walls or like cut
them off cut off the heels from their tanks and then so when
you're playing group you have to use these buildings come
here come back as like these buildings as like cover so you
literally like
really have any like i mean it's just emma grab nice nice
shot bro you're not smart that's what we might be able to
kill him quick it's not gonna get too aggressive but yeah
don't be i know i know i feel like namor plays like not
great spots a lot of the time like he's just off to the side
but he's not really doing much i'm like i got you i got you
i'll look at him i got him man you
lane.
Neymor weakened the left.
Clearly you needed some help.
Watch out, Tyler.
You're low.
Nice.
Be careful.
I'm trying to keep an eye on their Neymor flanking.
He's up left somewhere.
Yeah, if you could do that, that'd be huge.
Yeah, he's on left.
He's down left.
Yeah, I'm like messing with him a lot.
I think you should keep your flake on me, Epic, the whole
time.
Yeah, 100%, 100%.
Don't ever give it to yourself.
I got you covered.
Stranger's low, Stranger's low, Stranger's low, Stranger's
low, Stranger's low, Stranger's low.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
Let's go.
Fuck off me, bitch.
crazy not tell you about that montana there's no way he
starts doing that right now literally no chance time to
switch things up including which side you're on they might
go triple tank we'll see works for me i'll just farm out
yeah i'm not the type who fades quietly into the background
better we are better we're just better let us let us walk at
the first first round so you know how to position there
as soon as if moxie gets a pick right right we just bone
rush it okay yeah i'll have alt pretty soon as well oh it
resets never mind yeah yeah never mind it doesn't it doesn't
pull over i was just confident that i'd be able to farm on
them i guess
wait you thought you had all yeah you thought yeah i was
like it's all good i'm gonna 75 like Guys, our Moon
Knight's...
He's about to hold out a small...
I think you're going to get it quick.
I mean, use that...
Use it literally the second you get it.
Just throw it with an awk and try to blow something up and
call it.
Yeah, I mean, we should just kill them.
Is there Strange, the one that's 15-16 right now?
No, that's the Hawk Iron Man.
Moxie, you're a bully.
Listen, that works for us.
It's true.
If he's a bully, I'm a bystander right now.
Yeah, it's bystander.
We're allowing it.
We're allowing.
We're going to change.
Strange change in the air.
He's weak.
I can't see you for the heals.
It's okay.
I'm getting attacked by wall.
Sorry.
I don't know.
You can push up, Tyler.
You can push up.
Push up over Emma.
Like it's five.
Huge kill.
They're not support.
I got you.
They sold on already.
I walked too hard, but we got this.
I grabbed a Luna.
I'm right near.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm helping Tyler.
Adam, dad, Adam, one.
Emma one.
Get him over!
Yeah!
Come on!
Tyler, you kicked Super out of his own tournament!
Yes, sir!
He even disband me, you piece of shit.
Have fun watching Super?
Bro, you still got three hours left to cast.
Bro, that's gonna be rough.
Let's go, dude.
Yeah!
That's my team!
That's us!
MVP!
Yeah!
36, bro.
Holy shit.
Yeah!
dude thank god moxie's so good at hella because i'm closing
i'm putting my screen away right now and you fried on hell
of that game yeah bro and then when you when you swap to
like squirrel girl too in the middle of the game when you
swap to squirrel girl in the middle of the game that was
fucking insane that was it we play bro if i was another team
i'd both keep in your squirrel girl yeah yeah yeah hundred
percent it's not like our game was the only one that's being
casted we're just doing it for the people who aren't like
full watching and they're gonna be like dude we got a
bandit's hawk eye and someone's gonna be like i heard he was
on hell yeah like the like the chat hoppers yeah dude no we
were i listened all right guys i get it all right all right
thank you
ggs guys ggs i think we either play now we wait i think who
do we play against do we play against necros or xqc are they
reversing i don't know xqc i think i think it would be
necros because xqc would face the uh xqc and necros are they
because yeah we play xqc oh okay that's good i i like that
we got to give them their first loss wait do we do no they
already lost ones i want to ask you it may as well be us
obviously it's gonna be us let's go i wonder how many teams
even gave even gave them like a a single map loss like we
might be the only team that took a map off him um what
what's the what's the band line that we did for him because
i i don't remember i mean we got we're gonna watch the whole
game before we play so we could like oh okay we got time we
got time yeah we could get the paper out if we want all
right i'm just glad to be here and i doubt they're gonna
roll them as hard as we just rolled them so it's gonna be a
good amount of time as well yes sir
Oh, well, we'll see how it goes.
Now I can disassociate for another couple of minutes, or
like 10 to 15 minutes.
Yeah.
All right, guys, let me disassociate real quick.
Let me just...
Guys, if you guys want to hear it, look at the...
here this is where they're casting it i'm just gonna i'm
gonna disassociate now did you guys just help me you guys
just helped me pay for my puppy with that win let's go wow
what puppy is it i got a little mini uh american shepherd
and he's the cutest thing ever i'm three days ago and that
was like i think i paid like 22 or 23 for everything and
like i mean that was that we just paid him off all right
we're winning the tournament we've got We might have puppy
bump he's laying in the back right now knocked out But he
knows he's paid for it.
So he's happy.
Is that like that's like the same thing almost exact dude I
yeah exact same thing.
They're just like they're bred to be smaller So they're like
technical name from like the kennel association or whatever
is like American, but it's literally like just a smaller
Mini Australian since I was like five really are you like in
love with they are I've heard so many things But when I was
looking for a dog everyone was saying the Aussies are so
great.
Yeah, like a lot of energy too right they do they definitely
do bro this is the first time i was like maintenance you
know but it's like worth it i think once he's not a puppy to
be great but he's yeah we're playing and i have in the
background he's like peeing on my floor and i've had to like
throw right i'm gonna like throw right games and i told i
told i was talking to chat about like what do i do for like
this time for this journey i was like he can i it's the only
time i'll probably ever have him in the crate in the
background because he cannot be running around and have me
looking around I'd rather I'd rather him poop in his crate
on his little bed than and throw and then throw a turny game
off it.
Yeah, a turny that's paying for him as well.
That's what I'm saying.
I can't I can't allow that.
He's gonna get a lot of treats if he doesn't poop in his
crate.
Hell yeah.
Now that I know that we've got puppy buff, it's over.
No, that's big.
That's big.
You gotta try for real.
Yeah, you weren't trying before, right?
Because I was trying to drag you guys down.
Yeah.
he was the he was a double agent for super steam yeah
i'm like so tight because i might i might i'm good moxie i
might push a bro gotta work tomorrow i think he's i think he
did a bathroom break gotcha
yeah i'm the group he'll tie up oh amir as well never mind
it's all right now we relax guys if i'm not talking it's
because i need it i need to disassociate now i'm tired for
real i have a little headache a little small headache i'm
i'm happy everyone's improving so much too ever since we
figured out our comp we're all improving so fast I just need
to micromanage Epic more.
I'll just yell at him.
I'll be like,
Yeah.
I just need to micromanage more.
Yeah, the comms are better.
He improved a lot because Epic doesn't play Rivals.
He went two more sets.
He has like 10 hours on Rivals.
And...
Is the XQC thing a best of one as well?
Yeah.
Only finals, which is best of three.
And I think it's still convoy.
Yeah.
I'm just watching the match.
Yeah, the tournament has been really fun so far.
That's funny that we, like, kicked Super out of his own
tourney.
It's literally his own tournament.
We kicked him out of it.
or
it's the name yeah yeah send him to the caster table i'm
just happy we we are not last the curse has been broken the
rivals rivals content creator tournament that's not a vtuber
tournament curse has been broken i feel like every creator
tournament it's like I've been cursed and step by step guys
step by step
thank you Tyler 1 thank you he broke the curse
alright are you starting yet I've just been oh they're
starting They're starting, guys.
Gosh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Super got sent to the casting coach.
You sure did.
Now he's got sent to the corner.
He got sent to the chair in the corner.
Now he has to watch.
Wait, I got it.
Wait, what the fuck?
yeah
what the fuck why did i look like that
oh it's the tooth that's why i was like what the fuck is
that corner there i was like wondering what that fuck was i
was like do i have a double chin but it was the tooth it's
day I was like, why do I have a double chin?
Alright, I'm watching this game.
Actually, I want to pee.
He's in the Marvel Rivals Hotel chair with creators.
Yeah, he sure is.
Alright, I'll be right back.
I go pee now.
Alright, I'm back.
I'm back.
Oh, I should have put on a text being like, watching um um
where is it where's my text so I could be like watching game
okay not walking my dog watching game before watching game
how do I phrase that watching game uh our match our match is
That I'm watching game.
Does this make sense?
Does this...
So I'm watching current tournament matchup.
There we go.
I'm sorry.
My brain dead right now.
I'm actually brain dead right now.
I was sleepy coming in.
I'm sleepy now.
yeah i don't even know what to bad for xqc
bro if we play this team the squirrel do we play winner this
no no we play xqc all the way to finals okay that's cool
then because if we do play winner if we do play one of these
teams uh that deem so cool to squirrel girl will not be
seeing the light of day that was gross yeah most likely
we'll play he just staggered their team really bad like they
were all backing up to live and he like did a double jump on
her and shot a couple nuts and killed like three so i mean
it was kind of like yeah it's kind of like he's not playing
when we've when we play him if we do mean thank you for the
controller on um x is like a tank he's like a chips thank
you thank you he's either brute or strange which isn't bad
for us i don't think at all um okay so does it like if we
watch their bot and like see what they like don't want no
not all that's that's the move we probably will do that
again all right someone do that for xqc's team i'm not gonna
lie one of y'all gotta do that because i don't know what i'm
looking at no it's fine i i believe in and you cole that's
your job i can do that yeah job done yeah just give us the
info and moxie and i will cook yeah maybe yeah i'm tapping
in too tapping okay i like that i like that work oh it's
kind of way better on convoy maps now yeah but xqc's team
doesn't have a squirrel go play right or did he i don't
remember oh yeah xc yeah i don't think so i don't remember i
remember we banned i'm trying to think we banned close they
had to they played hella they played hella namor and then xq
was on Strange and they rent triple.
Yeah, and we banned two of their supports, right?
Oh, I see, you're right, yeah.
Because one of them was a, was a one trick on one of the
supports, but I forgot which one.
Oh, Warren was the Squirrel Girl.
Oh, yeah, we first banned, we first banned Squirrel Girl,
remember?
Yeah.
Yeah, so we should just first ban Squirrel Girl.
Oh.
I feel like, I feel like he did alright on Name More.
Well, he was, um, what was it I know like they have I don't
actually don't know I don't remember what they actually
played we should also look at what they played against other
teams too that is inky wait give me a check uh give me a sec
guys whoa okay guys super delayed in the from super stream
it looks solid Calvin Calvin went tank dead for a lot really
and then they just had worn on yeah if squirrel wasn't
banned he forgot i had that squirrel and calvin went tank
deadpool and they went mantis
what he's doing well give me a sec i got
oh i'm back no no then i'm encouraging him he needs to know
not to be be needy I'm trying to teach him not to be needy
guys might use this time to oh my gosh this game might be
faster ending though
I should I'm gonna go actually I'm gonna go um the them and
give him a walkies i'll be right back guys and also get
water too i'll be right back everyone sorry my brain is slow
right now i'm like cool down mode i'll be right back
hello hello you sent the boy home yes we did uh yes we did
mr xqc you guys ready gonna be i told you by the way we're
sending him home bro hey you picked the wrong one to host
this son of a no no no he's hosting longer now he's doing
his job properly now.
That's right.
He gets more desk time.
It's what he wanted.
You guys waiting about five minutes for feelings?
What is that old?
Yep, we're ready.
All right.
Lock in.
Yes, sir.
That little looks crazy.
I've never seen that.
Do we know our bands and stuff?
No fucking idea.
Oh, no.
Okay.
I'm going to pull up X again.
Just look.
That's more just watching that game.
You see how Minecraft right now?
This is real.
Is he fucking speedrunning minecraft right now yeah he's
playing micro that's crazy in between the game i he doesn't
need this money he doesn't need this hey who is xcc yeah his
head's not in the game like us bro we like that what is
going on bro he's just been scrolling streams it's not in
the game true
dude huh yeah i mean i guess we got a band that squirrel
girl it's annoying oh okay 15.
So we didn't need to play Jeff last time, right?
Because we banned her rocket and they, I think she, I think
banning rocket is good there.
We should then I'm probably gonna try to guarantee play mag
and have something for the Jeff or else we're gonna be in
hell.
Because they're gonna triple support and we're not matching
it, right?
No.
Okay.
Then I guess we just, we just gotta have counters for their
stuff then.
I just go back.
What are we thinking they're going to be running?
Um, I mean, they've been...
Well, when Squirrel Girls banned, they make Warren go Namor,
and they go Hella with it.
And then if it's not banned, they go, yeah.
And then when it's not banned, Calvin goes Tank Deadpool.
I still were up.
Is Tank Deadpool?
Like, is he like, is that like a super hard thing to play?
I literally don't know how to play against it, so I almost
feel like I'm...
not that it's either i'm not but yeah i don't know i don't
think he really knows how to play it either well if he
played this game the last game that they won he got 14
finals on it um the game before he didn't do so well either
but he might have gotten against like an easy team yeah
maybe um no it was space's team and he had 14 finals and got
mvp and the next ice was 15 which is one on score girl so he
definitely i think he definitely knows what he's doing And I
don't know if you play it the whole game.
You might not.
I'm not really watching.
But, um, so what are we doing for Bandline?
I'm trying to think.
The Squirrel Girl, I just think, is so annoying that, like,
it's worth banning.
Like, if he thinks he's that good at it, and then maybe we
could, um, like, ban a Hella and Namor type of thing.
One of them, like Hella.
You want?
If they don't save it.
Oh, yeah.
So you don't want to focus on the supports.
we could too well the thing is like if we ban that rocket
she plays jeff and we lost two of them with her on jeff uh
but i'll be barely yeah barely true was this a team that
banned mag against us no it wasn't no i think i mean we
could that is the team up even it depends on what map we're
playing next is the team up good against whatever convoy map
we're on oh no because if we're on the ban hello how um wait
okay uh raffle waffles you here yep yep yep what's your do
you know how to name our old jeff uh no but we could go into
practice right now we could yeah yeah it's genuinely one of
the easiest things in the entire game it's like when he alts
you just throw your old like you just old and he'll eat you
and you kill him afterwards every time you can you can get
it a hundred percent of the time it's like a suey it
literally is he well it would just know well you get eaten
but like you kill him and then you're immediately on eaten
oh okay so it's like it is like the counter practice it join
up on the yeah here join up on the game yeah yeah and then
i'll get him in here and let's mess with it it's okay that
i'm looking yeah i sent i sent you an invite oh nice okay
yeah let's go practice range i'll go uh i'll go jeff i think
because if we ban the rocket, I think she does go Jeff
triple.
And if I don't have to counter that with Maggle, then I
could potentially counter Hello or something.
And that could be like huge.
Wait, where is the invite?
I can't find it.
Is that the, no, right side?
If you go on the right side, there's a practice above the
map.
Yeah, and then practice on the right.
Yep.
All right, I'm in there on Jeff right now.
I'm going to get my ult.
Turn on friendly.
Oh, yeah.
Friendly fire on.
So I'm Naimo.
I mean, you could also do it on Moon Knight, but...
You could do it on Moon Knight, too.
So no matter what we do, it's probably that.
Here, come down left.
Yeah, you just Moon Knight, the E.
I'm shooting.
Come left, come left, come left.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Oh, no, no, he's looking at me.
It's fine.
You're looking at the wrong guy.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry, wrong, Jeff.
This is just more open spot and less hectic, so I was going
to be like, yeah, I came in here.
But grab your ult and then on the thing.
Yeah, I have ult.
Okay, now I'm literally just going to ult, and when I pop
it, I'm going to try to eat you.
I'm not surprised that I see one against Flask.
I think Flask just had too many support players.
Sorry.
In three, four support players or something.
You're old again.
You throw in the middle of where I'm eating.
No, no, no.
So like, you'll see, it's a quick thing.
You should just hold your ult out.
Like, literally hold your ult out right now.
I'm gonna eat you and you just throw it.
No, don't throw it.
Wait, am I wrong?
Is that how Namura works?
No, it is how Namura works.
No, no, no.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, I get that.
Well, I'll explain.
So this pool that I'm dropping is now where Jeff's coming
up.
This is where Jeff.
Yeah, this is a heel pool.
This pool that I'm gonna be on your right, is where Jeff's
going to eat.
So you throw in the middle of it.
I'll do it now.
Too late.
Oh, so I need to not be in the pool.
No, you can't be.
No, no, it doesn't matter.
Here, ready for this?
I imagine I'm eating you.
You have your old, right?
Or imagine Moxie's eating you as Jeff.
Are you close to him?
I'm going to go.
I'm going.
Yep.
He's dead every time.
You could, now it's a little tougher because if the Jeff
doesn't eat you, you have to just aim it.
But again, get your old.
You have it?
Well, if the Jeff is going to eat, i'm gonna stand next to
our name more then i'm dead every time there's nothing i can
do about that if you hit that we will win the game probably
for free because that jeff was getting some ults on us last
time i want to say that we couldn't counter um because we
did yeah we just you just you're literally all you're doing
is waiting for that second that second pool no matter where
it is yeah and we all should honestly stand on purpose so he
can just ult himself so it's easier when they're jeff ults
but yeah i mean super simple you seem you got it even when i
didn't hold on you.
So I think we're, I think we're fine.
You could pull one of these off.
Okay.
Yeah, you got it.
I mean, it's, but yeah, if you do that, or even with Moon
Knight.
I mean, you just Moon Knight through the Ankh or just Moon
Knight ult the Jeff, like, can you, can you help me one more
time?
I just want to see what the timing is like for,
okay, so I hear a ding, ding, ding, and then it eats.
Yeah, there's a little, the bell is, the bell is honestly,
like a good indicator.
Wait, but is the bell your skin, your Jeff's skin?
No, I think it's just Jeff.
Oh, okay.
because i don't know if you're using a special skin for it
because each jeff has a each jeff skin has a special thing
also they're saying we're red if we're ready what were we
first banning we're first banning squirrel girl yeah nice
okay okay i'm happy with that first banning squirrel girl
here we go and then what's our second band guys rocket our
second band rocket okay i think we could do we could do that
they probably they might save rocket but if they do they
save rocket we ban cloak because then we don't have to waste
the mad god on the cloak all i
mean did did lee and lee that do like she well do you want
to see guys they're asking uh yeah no latency sure i'm fine
yeah i'm fine with that i will be on ping so hopefully that
doesn't affect my timing of the no you'll be fine it won't
be bad i play with that i play monoi buddy's place from
dubai and he's lying like 250 perma and he's like oh my god
come on baby holy oh wow oh wait wait so what is our second
band then moxie you don't want to ban cloak uh second one
rocket right oh yeah but they protect rocket that's what i
mean if they protect rocket oh true we'll figure we'll
figure it out we'll see if they do i guess okay so first
band is who squirrel girl squirrel girl where
Who am I going to banish from this match?
Oh?
Oh, there was a fuck something up.
That, give me.
Oh, now they know what we've banned first.
Scrims.
What happened?
Oh, no.
Oh, it's the wrong map.
They were playing Tokyo again.
Unless...
Oh, yeah.
Tyler is midtown.
That's the map that you played Hulk on.
Okay, no door opening.
Keep it shut.
Huh?
Don't worry about it.
It's alright.
It's just my PTSD.
Do you have a kid?
A ruffle?
Oh!
That's not that you played a Hulk on it.
That's what you said.
Okay.
I didn't hear...
I didn't hear what you said.
I got you.
It's your redemption arc.
This is...
What bad game we just lost.
No, no.
This is literally your redemption arc, Tyler.
This is like, we fight...
We fought XQC on this exact same map as well.
Oh shit, it is!
Yeah!
Let's go!
Squirrel, we've got him.
Squirrel.
Yes.
Yeah.
We just banned our...
Our captain just banned himself.
Oh, hell yeah.
Yeah.
Aura.
Oh.
And then protect Venom.
What?
Who left?
Is that bad?
That's weird.
We play that?
Why is my whole chat spamming GG?
Is it Hawkeye's name?
Is that why?
It's okay.
Ignore them.
Oh, we're gonna.
So they're doing the Nemoa Hella combo.
Then we have to ban Hella then, didn't we?
We can.
Yeah, I think that's a good call.
Yeah, ban Hella so they don't get team up.
Yeah, screw it.
This is a good Hella map.
I feel like we should ban like Rocket.
But this is a good Hella.
This is a good Hella map.
Remember Midtown?
Yeah, but I think like it's a lot more effective Rocket.
I mean, I don't think they're gonna save Hella second.
Okay, Rocket then.
Yeah, ban rocket.
I swear to God, if he saves Taya, this is on you, this is on
you, Moxie.
They might save Groot, too.
That's on you.
Oh, they're going to play Groot.
What's our last ban then?
Hello.
They bet it's either Hello or Rocket.
I swear to God, Moxie.
Yeah, it's going to be hell.
Well, we don't ban Groot.
They might.
Like, they're going to protect it.
I swear to God.
I think they've been protected.
Oh, yeah.
thinking about it oh okay they they can't run hello anymore
yeah okay we protect protect something else we protect what
do we protect bucky bucky you said you're not gonna run it
well he either plays hella or plays deadpool oh the
deadpoint memoir is not a good team up though it could be i
think i think like the thing is is that band group too yeah
because they're gonna go mantis they're gonna yeah that's
true band group yeah do it i like that okay all right we'll
just have to deal with hella and the more then we're gonna
be venom and i'll go emma or mag would you guys rather have
i can bully this strange more and he's definitely gonna play
strange on emma but either one is fine you want me on the
moon night on the wall i think the more because if she's
playing jeff roots band too yeah and they've had his You're
playing Namur, I think.
Oh, yeah.
Personally.
Oh, Moonite's banned.
Okay.
All right.
They did their research on you, bro.
You just got targeted.
Listen, I'll take it.
I'll take it.
But if they play Gambit, then I'll play Gambit.
But I agree.
We're going to the finals, baby.
Let's go.
Come on.
One goddamn payload game in your pathetic lives.
Just fucking win it.
You pieces of shit.
Or attack so I can swap fast.
I like that.
You're pieces of shit.
But we're your pieces of shit.
Yeah.
Yes, sir.
We start on attack or defense?
You said they can attack.
Back.
So, yeah, so if they do run Gambit, I'll swap the Gambit.
Wait, who should I put the Snowflake on?
Moxie.
Put Snowflake on me.
And then you can't press F because it takes it away and puts
it on you.
Yeah, I'm Daredevil on this.
The red guy.
Sorry, if you guys said anything I missed.
Do you guys want mag or do you guys want?
I would rather.
Are we actually Daredevil?
I think so.
We do mag then.
Run mag.
I mean, like, unless I see what...
We'll do mag 100%.
If things aren't working, speak up, guys.
By the way.
Yeah.
We're constantly figuring it out as the game.
I'll say something if I think it's not working.
They have hella.
They have hella on the top right.
Yeah, they're going to hella more.
Yeah, I'm going to go switch.
Maybe.
Yeah, hella on him on top.
Those of them.
So we need a one.
Jeff had to drop.
Hey, heals are bad up top.
No bird.
Careful, careful, Raffle.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, just play main.
All you gotta do is just play with our team main.
I'll be on the flanks.
Okay, okay, sounds good.
Can I hear you?
Yeah, I'm back in the straight.
You don't take your flake off of me.
Yeah.
Jesus.
They're hard.
Look at strange, look at strange.
I'm gonna cut his heels.
I couldn't pull them.
Nice.
Strange, strange, strange, strange, strange.
Strange, strange, strange.
Strange, strange.
I pulled him back.
He's low.
Nice, nice.
Nice.
No, no, no, no.
Strange, strange, strange, strange.
Strange, strange.
He's pushing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
I have Alt here.
I'm going to let you build Alt now.
I'm going to let you build Alt.
He'll heal, Tyler.
Yeah.
What do I have Alt for?
Uh, should I hold for Helm?
I can hold for Helm.
Or I hold for Jeff, right?
No.
If we have Neymor, that happens.
Well, I'm gonna pull one.
He might have it early.
I'm looking for the support.
I'm looking for a bucky.
Okay, I go first.
I go first.
Okay, three, two, one, bucky.
Beautiful.
Oh my God, kill that, kill that, kill that.
I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Oh, nice.
We have, we have, we have, we have.
No more, no more, no more.
No more, no more, no more, no more.
No more, it's fine.
We're fine.
Strange, strange, strange, strange, strange, strange,
strange.
All right, it's that beautiful, beautiful, guys.
Who is this?
Alright, nice.
I have ult.
Alright, let me heal more.
Did Jeff, I'll just let him know?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Save it, save it, save it.
That's you, bro.
That's all you, I believe.
You're pushing your, you're talking.
You're talking.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I'm bad habit.
Are you, you're probably going to hold for...
Walk up, maybe?
Yeah, I'm walking up with you.
Yeah, I have my ult.
Just let me know.
Yeah.
I think you hold for maybe strange, like pop it off strange
ult, maybe?
Or to counter an ult.
We can comment as we go.
Yeah.
Wait, guys, do we need...
Yeah, I got someone for us.
Let me heal mostly.
I'm holding for cloak.
Watch out, they're going to have it.
Okay, I'll get, I'll get, I'll get, I'll get, I'll get, I'll
get, I'll get, I'll get, I'll get, I'll get, I'll get, I'll
get.
I got frozen before I can do it.
Okay, it's okay.
I might hold for Jeff or cloak then, whoever comes first.
I'm trying to heal you, Tyler.
Come back.
I'm in, I'm in the ult.
I'm in the ult.
Aw, he was low.
That's fine.
Just, yeah.
Just die here.
Just die.
Don't use anything.
I am like
I'm not there.
We go back in I'm not here.
I'm not here What you can have a strange comes strange It
plague me if you can Got one got you got you Because Jeff
altered shall I use my all right here strange in the back
everyone on strange it back please straight straight go i'm
trying to i'm trying to for you he's one he's one nice nice
nice dude oh my god that's insane i got you i got you tyler
yeah i bubble jeep moxie keep going you can keep going if
you have to nice pull oh yeah i pulled him back i pulled him
back jeff jeff three point three point we can walk him down
walk him down hey yeah i'm pushing pushing pushing pushing
push cart push cart tyler you can go up you can go up tyler
okay that bubble actually so good.
Portal, portal, portal, portal, portal, portal, portal!
It's my speed, yeah.
Portal, portal, portal!
They're on point, they're on point!
There is it.
I'm fine here.
Oh, slow, Chuck slow!
Chuck slow!
And more one.
Uh, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
They fade out.
Strange low.
Jet flow, jet flow, jet flow, jet flow.
I'm halting this, I'm halting this.
Honestly, where is it?
Strange, strange, strange, strange.
Strange, strange.
Ice.
Dead pool, dead pool, dead pool, one.
Ice!
Okay, let me build alt here.
Oh, Luna, let me build all.
Just on the Olympic.
I'll take damage.
Yeah.
You stand card.
Yeah, you stand card.
Hey, Rolf, that whale was fucking perfection.
That was beautiful.
Oh, they're on hell out now?
Junkie counter.
Bill Jeff.
Yeah, we only have two.
Oh, yeah.
Well, we're good, they're just getting trying to build a
little old.
I'm just getting old here.
Where are they?
They're resetting.
They're strange when I have old as well.
No, he used it.
He used it.
Yeah.
You can did it.
You can walk forward my tech and double you.
Yeah, I'm good.
I'm carting here guys.
You can push up.
You can push up, Tyler.
Good thing.
Good thing stuff, though.
Luna's in a bad spot!
Luna's in a really bad spot.
You can look here.
I'll pull someone.
I don't know who I pull.
Oh, hello, hello,
hello.
Oh, no way.
You're fine, you're fine.
I got you.
I need help though.
I need help.
If you can heal me?
I'm Ultimate.
Nice.
I still need heals.
I can't get anything.
Okay, that's fine.
I'm going back now.
We're dead.
Happened.
I didn't heal so you can't heal me.
Run back, run back, run back.
Try and do.
Might be dead.
I can give you a shield here.
We're literally bullying them so bad.
Like, they're not even able to get anything going.
That was good.
We got, like, a full walk, too.
Someone's barely pushed her, huh?
Give me a second.
I'm here.
I'm letting you guys.
You guys can build all of me, too.
I'm taking some damage while I can.
It's fine.
I got all now.
have to like build all snow they they don't have they go in
top right oh no oh i pulled him back oh a great pole great
pole she's one oh unfortunate i think we cut it out yeah i
keep looking up strangers here tyler if you slam on them and
slam out like just wait for us to be back up so far remember
you're here i'll go in i'm on you hill yeah we're walking up
we're walking up you can you can start something okay yeah
you start you start we're pushing them now and he's gonna
have I'm gonna use this aggressively.
Go, go, wait.
Oh, yeah.
I need a fucking single heal.
Nice.
Nice, Matsu.
Someone's gonna be on point, like, stalling.
Strain, Strain, Strain, Strain, Strain.
Focus on Strain, Strain.
I got you.
Never mind.
Worth it.
Nice, nice, nice.
Um, we're about to have Lunal and we're about to have, the
second you get a ult used.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
You're gonna come out with ult.
I'll bubble, I'll bubble myself and one other person.
I don't have, okay?
Just a cat.
There he is.
I don't have, I don't have.
Kill kill kill kill.
Hilt kills, killed, killed Kilt got him!
On the right, Lunar Close ain't one.
I don't have it.
Yeah.
What about two?
They used three of them.
Yeah, Arioo sir, sir.
I'm going to die here.
I'm just going to die here.
Yeah, I'm dying too.
We have Lunar too.
It's nice.
Thanks for that.
Thank you so much.
That's so good.
Yeah, let Doki heal that epic.
Okay, Doki's going to have all of them.
I don't give up so easily.
Yeah, we have all to advantage here.
No, yeah.
Groove tactical.
He has that vehicle moving again.
Can I let Invis heal a little when we walk out?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm healing it.
Hella's top left.
So shoot out that Hella closet if she can.
I will if she peeks me.
Not peeking, I think she's staying on the right.
Oh my god, I'm hit.
God, I'm dead.
We're 30 seconds, it's fine, it's fine.
You still have another fight.
You can just back up.
I don't want to build them.
Just play around corners, play around corners.
You might hard push this though.
Yeah, they're hard pushing this.
Try and save them.
That's fine.
Yeah, Epic's one.
Okay, okay.
We're all here.
I'm gonna yeah, I can use this aggressively.
I'm gonna use my aggressively.
I think we need epics aggressively or anything?
Oh, epics?
Okay, epic, prism.
Go go go go go go.
Yeah, use it.
Use it.
Yeah, I'm gonna open their cloak.
I'm gonna open their cloak.
Nice.
Oh my god.
That's you're here.
You're the best player.
Focus on strange.
That was insane.
That was major.
Bro, the second that whale mark popped up, I mean it was
over.
They were done.
Nice!
Let's go!
Box, I need you to lock the fuck in, bro.
You know, you hit it twice like that.
You need to lock in.
Hell is a tough one, bro.
You're better than it, bro.
You're better.
He is better, but that is a tough one.
We're walking up, man.
It's different.
I kind of want to go cap and like just run down time.
I don't know if that's crazy or not.
Yeah.
I mean...
ever you think if you think that's the move you could do you
want to do you want to triple tank or do you want me to go
dps and we just don't have a tank i'm just thinking like
we'll get slammed with their hell i'm just thinking i could
stall like how long no i mean we waffle can maybe we have to
do triple support triple tank i don't think we're gonna be
able to make that work i don't know i don't know we want to
try that we don't i don't think so we like so do what works
do what works yeah yeah am i staying on namor namor yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right yeah i don't mind that idea though
if you end up i'm gonna do that i just think we can't we
shouldn't risk it on best of one yeah that's fair actually
if we make it to the finals we'll risk it i think if he can
stall on that like if you if you think they're like doing a
little too fast or kind of yeah that's what's kind of yeah
we are i mean look at the stats we are we are built as right
now yeah let's keep it up uh hey raffle don't try to like
flank because they're gonna mark you really hard if you play
yeah just be careful you should play on on our team yeah
play main and shoot their squids and like you're you're
gonna be good yeah we're going top left i can shoot her a
little bit with you yeah i see that i'm literally focusing
her so hard with you yeah i mean bubble i can give you oh oh
my god oh he's one he's one got him got him I don't know.
I have Hell on me.
Yeah, I'll get out of there.
Yeah, yeah.
Hell walking, yeah, yeah.
Epic, play bottom.
Play bottom, Epic.
Yeah, yeah.
Play bottom and Shubain.
Okay.
I'm just fighting the hell.
She has the full support up here too.
I'm gonna die on card if we're dying.
Yeah, I'm going here.
Yeah, I'm almost back.
I'm staying on card.
Actually, we're almost back.
I think they can back up.
Yeah.
I might...
Yeah, I couldn't peek for the longest time.
Okay, you shouldn't block deals, but I have bubble.
I'm one, I need help on my right.
I'm good.
I need like...
Oh my god.
Are we just getting completely shit under?
What's going on?
I think we should just down cart.
Yeah, yeah.
I have all, I'll use it aggressively.
I'm dead.
Yeah, that's not my...
It would...
Do we need it to be top?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm TPing.
I'm off too, okay.
Okay, that works.
I can go in with a lot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's gonna go, it's gonna...
Come back, come back.
Yeah, come, come.
Yeah, come.
He does need heals now, he does need those.
I'll look at him.
Kill the Jeff.
I got it.
Chill, chill.
Nice.
Hey, dude, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Yeah, hello in there.
Hello, hello, hello.
Yeah, no, altus, altus, Luna, altus.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm burning hella with you.
Burn hella, look up.
I'm burning him.
I burned him.
Yeah, hello, no bird.
Hello, no bird.
We have no alt now.
We have no support alt.
Okay, just chill, just chill, just chill.
We'll play part.
Tyler, if you can just try to live.
That's good I can't see him.
I can't see him.
I got my guy.
My guy.
Yeah, so keep backing up You need your cooldown effect.
That's huge.
I'm good.
I'm pushing on the left.
I need deals.
I couldn't do anything.
The hell that pushed me.
Pushed both supports.
Okay.
It's fun.
But that was a good song.
We did well there.
Yeah, just die, Ruffle.
Oh, okay.
I don't know if you'll survive.
No, no, no, no.
Die, die, die, die.
Okay, okay.
I can heal him.
Oh, no.
Oh, he doesn't know the g the fastest sprint ever luna get
the out of there is this just a long run is that good yeah
all right die then you can't sit there and just yeah all
right i'll hold ass good yeah we're chilling this way all
right i have alt when i'm back he'll have his good all here
too yeah i'm up to now i'm with you guys we have to save the
save the name all for the jeffy yep keep marking there how
like she is flying really good yeah on the top i'll let you
heal now go go go go nice nice no more else no more else no
more else there's a hell up behind us there's a hell up
behind us there's a hell out of us nice you heal this you
heal this yeah we didn't really use too much there we only
use namor and uh whatever venom so we can play top we won't
play top remember i'll first i'll first you know yep i will
do my best okay doki olds first not epic yeah yeah oh i got
dropped down
can you see it nice big a strange friend of old he's like
jumping out yeah i bubbled you i can make sure everyone's in
there okay it's fine just not on cart i think there's
another touch just keep dying cart are we even gonna die oh
yeah i'm trying to die here kill their jaff somehow yeah
they got down cart nice okay we're gonna be kind of they're
portling they're portling they're trying to keep us off i
don't think
I don't think he will.
That's you ping here?
That's you ping Hex?
Yeah.
That's fine.
We all just go left.
Or we can wait it out.
Right side.
Come right side.
Raffle.
Raffle right side.
We gotta be careful.
I'm gonna I'm gonna heal this.
I can heal this.
That's good.
Go in?
Yeah.
Let's go on the back line, Tyler.
Nice.
Point, point.
Make sure you're not.
Make sure you don't see nine.
Yeah.
Yeah, I am no.
I had to.
yeah the strangers they're like pushing the back line hard
we are getting on i think we might need to swap something
yeah what's that working guys come on talk talk talk talk i
can go emma i don't know if that'll do anything though for
us here we need the mag though for the cloak it's not
killing it anyway they broke in that time too i almost had
it i would have killed on the third dash i should have
finished this round um so let's just take early fights we
staggered on the second yeah we don't have support all the
stuff we take an early fight with uh with you're a bucky
yellow yeah we can yeah i need to i need help top right i
can't see you i got you i got you a shield i got your shield
i got your shield that's all i can do we have to take this
early fight or we're giving them free fishes yeah we don't
have any support else by the way yeah yeah got you i have
all here i'm gonna ult this here here I Can't use it Do I
have ult for this?
We have a counter I don't know if it's gonna hit him No, it
is We kill, we kill, we kill We kill I'm gonna pull it back
I opened when I said it but Oh, yeah Just you guys gotta
kind of just I we're not gonna have supports whenever you
guys I'm gonna go I'm gonna swap to I will have touch I will
have touch I will have touch This can be good we're gonna
stall forever Raffle, can you go Punisher?
Raffle is a Punisher.
Yes, yeah, yeah, okay, okay.
We're good here.
We have touch.
We have a bunch of touches.
Are we going?
I'm on touch.
I have touch.
Gotcha, I got you.
Can we focus the hella every single person?
Look at hella.
Yeah, yeah.
She's the only person killing.
It's 1 HP.
1 HP.
Thanks.
No.
That's the best I could do.
No, you're good.
I mean, that's stuff.
Get there, Tyler.
yeah there's no way damn no just iphone 8 user completely
pissed on us guys i'm not gonna lie this guy is smurfing the
fuck out of the game he's so i don't know like what can
change to stop him moxie told you the pan hello i told you
what happening we just have to be aware of the he's just
going in the flank that's all he's doing and he's flanking
the width okay so so should i just run at that one guy the
whole time you can't we can't mark it he's not he's not on
the flank alone he's bringing the other support with him so
should i just should i stop going for supports and just go
for this guy i don't know what to do i'm asking a question
we could okay wait moxie are you always going after the
hella i could come with you as gambit uh yeah okay but then
epic you have to be able to heal the front line because i'm
just going to be flanking with moxie got it i i think raffle
like do you play punisher or no yep play punisher like i
feel like the name was not okay switch to Yeah, you're all
that's all you got to do.
Yeah, yeah, and your all doesn't get eaten by Jeff Yeah, so
when you press all that when they jump when you press your
old good guys when you say shoot man You mean just like Just
play main their strange old shoot their squids Okay, yeah,
let me shoot break you till and shoot their team Okay, I'll
just try and like hop just no flanking no flanking Yep Yeah,
give snowflake to moxie Yeah, I'll bubble you as well when
you're uh yeah let's when you need it yeah i'll come with
you moxie
i got the anti on them shooting hella if hella is visible
i'm shooting her for the rest of the game yeah they're kind
of stuffed in that room up top tyler you gotta like he's
outside again you gotta what tyler say it's uh it's just
play main yeah play main
the name or no no bubble they're all on the top i'm gonna go
back top uh dokey okay
they don't heal her and she just is in the open the whole
game your kings are all night oh no he's unlucky um get out
get out out out out i can have a touch i can have a touch
they have 10 seconds i mean you'll get a touch regardless
but watch out epic just chill i can touch i can touch too
all right i have touch i've come down come down come down
I have touch as well.
Just drop it on the floor.
I need someone.
I need you to someone else to touch.
No, no, just, okay, it's fine.
Yeah.
Go back Venom.
Oh, we should have farmed my Gambit off.
I will have touch.
I will touch his cap.
Okay.
I have Gambit off soon.
Oh, we should have farmed my Gambit off.
Oh.
Yeah.
I'm blocking you off.
Three, two, three, three.
All right.
You want me to switch back to Namur?
for the defense or stay on i don't really feel like i'm
doing a huge amount as punishment right now i feel like
you're doing some work on punishment but if you want name
more yeah okay i i can do either it might be easier on
defense maybe i don't know i don't even know that could also
triple support um do you think i think we won't be able to
build support colds but is it worth triple tanking and just
one i mean triple triple tank triple support i mean do a
hell mary right now i think that might be that might have to
be the play raffle do you play any support which support do
you play broker dagger no i play luna rocket and rocket okay
luna can play sue and then uh epic might have to go in viz
yeah that works yeah yeah do it let me just do this is good
i mean by your life as much you can tyler who wants to play
there's no heels coming it doesn't matter exactly we're just
getting on the entire time this one i don't super winnable
they don't have much time at all like if we can somehow
build gambit all we have to fight in here then though yeah
we have to play down here come here come with us come with
us all the supports have to play here all the supports have
to play yeah like here and then tyler yeah yeah tyler you
try to mark the top left or play touch card and get out okay
wait wait okay you have to play near us you shouldn't uh
okay perfect let's let's play by you guys we should have a
ton of and they shouldn't really be able to kill much with
hell yeah their hell is going top level gotcha
oh my i'm just again every time bro don't in okay
honestly it's good just long card hell is still behind hell
is still behind i know i'm trying to i put it yeah the i
mean i have a tp i have a tp coming back no we have tp we
have tp You have to go, you have to touch now.
You have to touch now.
I got touch, I got touch, I got touch.
Okay.
I can give you one too, and I can give you a second one now.
Keep, I can't touch.
Oh my, you guys gotta walk through the back or something.
I got, I got it, I got it.
But.
It's nice, it's just Hella.
Up, agree.
I did save.
She did save, we had Hella!
High time.
She was right.
They had a bed full summer.
It was too...
He completely killed the entire game, bro.
That's actually not...
I don't know what that champ does, but...
No, that's...
Hela is strong on this map.
That's why I wanted the Hela Band.
Not a speaker.
You beat me.
He was confident.
Whoa!
I was so confident.
We watched the VOD.
I was like, Hela Band, Hela Band, Hela Band.
And they're like, no.
Guys.
All right, they had a Mantis play.
It makes sense.
They had a Mantis player.
who they're going to run the group team up with all right
they just had a 2v1 every time on the side that's just how
it goes yeah it's brutal if anyone else oh how's the save
anna i was gonna like tank i could have gone mantis and pop
like pocketed you but i think we had to have you on tank
though it was just we just had yeah yeah yeah yeah who it is
guys okay it's not ggs it's just It's not our map.
It's not.
Oh, this stupid fucking map is shit.
Yeah, this is a cursed map for us.
Ah, damn.
Is there not any more maps to push payload?
There is.
But they purposely picked this one for us.
GG's though.
At least we're not last.
At least we paid for Claus's puppy, bro.
At least the puppy.
Not last.
4% or 4k, right?
Perpartisan, I think.
3k.
300.
3,300, oh my God.
33, 33 or something like that.
All right guys, GG.
GG's.
Nice fight you guys, get to see you next year.
Fucking start practicing maybe a little bit guys.
Oh, well, Tyler, when I moved that portal by the way.
I did, I, we even probably, we spent all that time doing
this, what happened there.
Good spot, it'd be like, yo, portal down.
And I was like, ah, you forgot the money.
Moxie, the road would start that, Calvin I would pick you
down every round start and would sit there and wait for you,
bro.
Yeah, because he's the nose.
He knows I'm fucking doing shit.
Yeah, he's better than you just out shoot him or something.
Nothing's not that easy.
Out shoot.
Well, dude, he was out shooting apparently every time.
Well, yeah, he's two people.
Oh, Moxie's dead again, guys.
Hold on.
Fall back, fall back.
You come back and get sniped again.
Oh, fall back, guys.
What's Moxie?
Like, do we have to do it three times, man?
Yeah, it happens.
Guys, you guys got the name or I'm in.
or got the mantis like that's just fucked i did say bad she
did say bad and you put it in on our mocking she did she was
pleading well we saved the venom i was like well we don't
need to care about i was begging everyone to please ban
hello ah she did say it we have nobody to blame it ourselves
i'm not about i'll just listen to you i'm a noob my opinion
doesn't matter yeah yeah and i don't know what any of these
people play i They privated the profiles because they're
push-ups.
My shit's open.
You don't respect your teammates?
Yeah, but like, come on.
It makes sense to ban Groot as well.
There's upsides, downsides.
Oh, bro.
Whatever it is, what it is, man.
It is what it is.
Wait, but why?
Wait, if we ban, we don't need a ban Groot.
We had Gambit.
We could have just cleaned it.
I wasn't.
I was never mentioned.
They banned Loki.
Because I was passionate about my hella bad.
I didn't think I need to mention it.
they banned guys whatever blame it on me i it was my fault
fucking hell good job moxie we're taking blame good job no
that's some fuck ass see guys it's none of our faults except
for one phrase no we should have banned mantis honestly we
should have banned mantis no we should have been hell on
period the mantis got 20k damage because he was that mantis
was sitting to hell I think the mantis was more of an issue
than their hella.
The hella looks good because the mantis does so much.
Yeah, I mean, she's damage boosted, perma, like, yeah, but
if, but then, like, the only reason, the only person, wait,
I did say bad mantis in the first matchup for XQC to...
Did we?
Yeah, remember I said mantis is, like, one the strongest for
triple.
We've been in it?
First time?
Yeah, we did.
Oh, okay.
Why don't we listen to her?
Well, dude, I, but Loki, I feel like you could have been
more aggressive with us.
Oh, oh.
Doki.
Doki, no, sorry, Doki.
Could have been way more aggressive with us to get that ban.
I was.
I was like, you should ban it, you stupid motherfuckers.
I'm not fucking around.
Like, say that.
You're going to fucking ban the camp around my plane.
And then I said, I said, okay, if they run hell out, that's
on you.
That's on you.
Yeah, but if it's aggressive, like, okay, it's not on me.
responsibility yeah fuck is that ducking responsibility you
guys didn't listen to me so i was like i told you so i told
you so odd that is what it is bro dude and also in that game
thanks for going wrong why was nobody saying anything like
you just tell me what to do i was trying to help you're
doing you're doing fine there's not much uh well we found
grute and then you then we didn't Tyler, follow, Tyler go
rocket and follow around you with the hell and fight it with
you or something.
Just pocket rocket, dude.
How are you putting some practice before you sign up for a
tournament, Tyler?
Oh, wait.
They had other players as bad as me.
I don't know.
It is what it is.
They're good players.
Outcarriage you, Moxie.
Wait, Moxie, was Tyler's first pick, though.
He had so much confidence in you, Moxie.
You were his first team.
Your team.
I didn't, yeah.
What would it do?
I didn't pick you!
True!
I was not the worst player in this.
Wait, who was... who was named them?
Well, I'm watching back your portal.
That's what I want to see.
I don't know all the people here.
Yeah, but you said you were not the worst player, so that
means you know who's the worst player on our team.
Somebody has got to be worse than me, is what I'm saying.
They all play fucking support, though.
That's a thing.
They're pussy.
All the bad players play support Oh my god.
Oh my god, Tyler You shifted up and right?
I didn't happen.
I didn't see that.
Everyone needs to watch back Tyler.
I'm leaving this portal.
What?
Please.
What did you do?
I didn't know how to place it.
I probably said once.
Well, yeah, you didn't, I didn't tell you to press shift or
right click either.
Because I was looking at my abilities.
I couldn't tell you what was the portal.
I couldn't remember.
Fucking hell.
You had one thing you were told.
I was right behind him when he did that was so funny.
He was like, no, come down, come down.
Did that port-up change anything?
Oh, probably not.
Probably not.
Yeah, they were shitting on us.
I mean, I don't think so.
I, it was just like they had the better comp in the end.
Look, it was going good at the beginning.
Then something happened.
Wait, Moxie, why didn't you want to, why didn't you try to
hella diff him?
I'm not hella diffing someone with a man.
Because isn't hella, but it doesn't hella counter Bucky.
I caught up with Matt.
is for you well i don't play hella talk we didn't you guys
didn't communicate anything ever mark you didn't speak in
game i'm fucking shooting no dps is the igl like it doesn't
happen like i mean i can just say what you want bro he was
mad at you and you're said that you took it what about these
shooting me from across the map so you lock it hella she
said that she and i'm saying hey mark the hell on the top
left mark the hell i i This is the last run where I was
begging you guys.
I said it on a task on on third point What can I do?
What can I do?
Oh, you said Markella.
Well, what am I gonna?
Yeah, Markella.
I don't know.
I said it on attack third point twice three times when he
killed me the first time and then we walk back up Well,
actually you you died I did this I actually ran.
I was like I like ran into sick.
Apologies for that guys Yeah, and you didn't press me
either.
You didn't press me either.
I would see you say I'm to kill player so we shouldn't have
any expectations on him bro this isn't like a league man
you're dying whatever it happens i gotta pick not with time
steamroll time yeah and we did the same on attack that's how
we snowballed i got a couple hooks hooked them in punch them
into us we got two picks and snowballed i'm saying so you're
the key players you gotta make the plays and when it came in
the crunch he didn't make them and he did that's what i'm
saying all right then there I played better.
I played like shit.
I'm not saying I did it.
I just expected better, Moxie.
Next time you don't disappoint me.
Okay?
Is there going to be next time for him?
Will you first pick Moxie again?
Please.
Please what, Moxie?
Please what?
I don't know.
I don't know if I get an invite to this next tournament.
Who knows?
Probably not.
What if Moxie becomes captain?
He first picks you, Tyler.
Oh, oh.
You ain't going to pick me.
That's okay, bro.
okay i'm good bro it's all g it's all g i mean we had fun
low key these guys are fucking pussies all right it always
happens every tournament three sports they're that is kind
of that's all i gotta say now that it is meta that is the
that is what happened only reason i've lost so it's three
supports is that why it's so strong so the bad players are
just playing support yeah because support is like super like
because it's like people just don't die and they just rotate
like funneling that's what i knew it i knew i was like going
back there and i was like wait they're all just killing each
other what the fuck you're never you're never gonna kill
them unless we're like doing damage i was trying to shoot
their chest all the time i mean you do you like i don't know
what you could have played well see would you play you hope
wouldn't be good into that we bank root also and like you
weren't you probably didn't want to go rocket again and We
banned Rocket.
You could have been Cloak and Dagger.
It would have been good.
If you had like a mag in you, like I could have gone like
Mantis, I could have helped Moxie.
How much would it be for you to solo queue the Grandmaster?
Okay.
How much would it be?
By the way, this game's like pissy.
Yeah, how you, if it's so easy, why don't you do it?
It's easy, but I don't know.
I don't know.
I'll talk to my team about it.
Well, you're so easy.
Why don't you do it?
Are you scared?
This game is not hard at all, though.
What are you saying?
Are you scared?
It's not hard.
Yeah, but you were able to play Overwatch Rink.
How come you're not doing Rivals Rink?
Are you scared that you won't make it?
I got a lot going on.
I'm in eight different things, Doki.
You hear me?
I'll do a Tetris tournament later.
It could be your ninth thing.
Buddy, so does everyone.
Yeah, yeah, we all have many things going on, but we're able
to play Rink.
You think you're the only guy who has things going on?
How many kids you got?
Got him, got him, got him.
Hang on, shut the hell up.
you got kids i am a top 50 player right now in league of
legends you hear me hey but you're top 500 mickey mouse
overwatch top 50.
well you're unranked in rivals hey let me hop on rival let
me hop on leave you hold on i'm still i got time okay i'm
leaving guys i go to fucking bed ggs it was ggs nice to see
you guys here nice playing ggs guys not last not last i mean
we made cool 20 yeah yeah yeah geez everyone not fun this
game and you guys were you guys were great teammates so yeah
no you had a good time that was great like i literally think
i mean dude i thought our whole team was really good like we
were playing really well like the name worlds were great the
heels were fucking great and that's from the two people who
like don't play the game like that so literally couldn't
have asked for more in that department yeah it was just that
hellamantis is absolutely fucked and if we had a single yeah
person that could have like if tyler could have played a
main tank and i could have went man this or if tyler could
have played any support that wasn't rocket that we banned we
actually bro i also like yeah i feel like should we have
even like pro i don't know i feel like the rocket ban was
good it was good i feel like maybe the only thing we
shouldn't have banned was squirrel girl what wasn't he they
were using it every game yeah they were using every game
though and they were winning every game over hella yeah but
he didn't yeah but he didn't like do that he doesn't do that
bad off squirrel girl it's not like he's one v9 on squirrel
girl yeah but it's not but it's not uh but him as namor was
not really doing much versus it was literally just hella so
no hindsight the hella band would have hit like crack and we
just banned their fucking rocket who just sits in the back
and plays jeff and we can't kill because they're triple
support like it was bad yeah like well yeah we didn't we
talked about it but we didn't like press for it and the idea
of the group a made sense uh in our head at the time yeah
and jeff did less than the rock it all too because they
could have just steamrolled us with rocky all every time
yeah we killed a few times as well jeff vault's kind of mid
i don't know yeah it's just another little because they had
the hell literally just the hell of mantis is just too
strong because we didn't is like a pocket character is that
just like her job yeah okay that's why like um moxie
couldn't do anything because it was literally 1v2 every time
and then because we're playing double support i can't pocket
moxie i have to be aware of the front line i guess maybe
that means the next support i should learn would be mantis
so i couldn't if you could randomly learn mantis that would
be insane for this that's a good triple yeah that's why i
kept saying like we like always target mantis for triple
support because mantis is so strong and triple because all
she can do is pocket especially in tournament like this
where it's quite likely there's gonna be a dps that's
cracked and then just like a mid pocket on a cracked player
is just that cracked player just stomps the lobby yeah and
hella can't fully counters bucky too so like moxie couldn't
really do much um because hella is a bucky counter man this
is like really my main right now too like i didn't play
hella yeah it was just a unlucky matchup i'm moxie i'll
learn mantis and on hell a deal all right but the thing is
will tyler pick all of pick us again he picked me again for
that performance i feel like reason to not i feel like we
did all right we did all right yeah yeah tyler and our my
record improved more we got knocked out first last time yeah
no we didn't really we doubled the price pool of what it
would have been and first place is unlikely i think really
because we I feel like that necros team like is gonna go
insane with Deadpool yeah well to be fair yeah but we got
smoked by necroses but we were figuring out our comp to be
fair we're like this is almost decided by the pickbounds oh
always yeah I think maybe we just didn't we also it's just
that people are very limited with their hero pool so it's
like rock paper scissors yeah and with the fact that we have
a lot of support players in this tournament and triple
support is meta it's just this team didn't have technically
didn't have three support players no that's actually i mean
i'm literally i put in to be a support player i put tank and
support but i've been like playing support for like two
seasons straight now like on all the characters it's just
unfortunate that we didn't have like anyone who was like a
main it's me i mean i didn't care i could play main tank for
sure it's just not uh i i figured because of how supports
how strongly they were and how much time i had on them i was
like if i put in for support like that could be huge like
how many good supports are in this yeah unfortunately did
not work out that way it also is not awesome that i'm not
gonna say hey it's not awesome that tyler only plays venom
that character is is a joke in triple support that's true no
it is like if he could we should out him on Groot or
something.
But, but no, no.
You sure seen, no, no.
Moxie, did you saw how he- He was asking what the Groot alt
was?
Yeah, did you not?
Moxie, did you not see how he played Groot?
He- No, I see now we played Groot.
He didn't place walls when he ulted.
I want to tell him, but it's all good.
Yeah, that's why I was like, I put it.
We put him on.
He had a good old though.
He had a good old, but, but like, he was literally with the
support, like, with supports the entire time.
He didn't walk out.
I was like, Tyler, walk up, please.
yeah no maybe we should just put him on rocket he said no i
don't know i i trust him on venom more he's gonna his venom
is so good i know his rocket wasn't bad we only had him for
one round like oh it was all right it is all right it is
what it is we could analyze this but we're not going to be a
team together and again after this we should have we should
have had him in between like learning rocket full throttle
like just this is you in the mines he's not gonna do that i
mean bro they watch clips no he would have done bro they had
uh hey yeah what's going on hello well you know what's going
on apparently you guys are still here yeah we're chilling
dude we're a team yeah i was only with that left guys we
weren't we weren't talking about you to say yeah we were we
were reminiscing about how amazing we did yeah and how
amazing each of us were during the tournament there was a
lot of focus actually tyler on how deep your pool is of the
character wait moxie do you want to repeat what you said to
us about why you thought we lost yeah just repeat that real
quick you want to say that who yeah moxie you were so
passionate Yeah, Venom's ass!
Yeah!
Venom is just a bad character into triple.
And these pussies always play triple!
Every turn of- I was okay with swapping!
I tried the triple healer.
I don't mind playing the triple healer.
I didn't care, actually.
Yeah, but like...
We need me on DPS and Raffle doesn't play tank either, so
it's a problem.
Okay, so it was just fucked up.
It is, it's- Wait, but Moxie, you picked this team.
Yeah, dude.
You sabotaged Tyler.
made some uh you sabotaged him actually did say though no we
we need a tank but they they picked the guy before we tried
we tried but i i feel like we i feel like it was a decent
decent squad yeah one squad i think we had tempo and we had
like something happened at like it was just hell out of us
up the tempo yeah we fell down yeah really that pocket was
too good i kind of hits calvin had 31 final hits and then
moxie was 20 i think yeah no it was hell it was just a hell
of thing bro i i feel like he's right we didn't help we
staggered and snowballed that's kind of how it goes i want
to go cap i think running down time could have been all
right on you went cap though and then you how does that work
like like i just touch cart and like we just need to be
better about dying together or like dying on cart yeah we
staggered like they're eventually gonna get the point but
the time goes down to zero and then like the next like we
just win with alts i don't know i think when attacks we
should have made let me farm gambit all and then just mold
it down i forgot about that strat the ring yeah we should
have thought yeah so if it was group versus group would have
been better if it was maybe we could have they had a man no
we could have banned mantis and then just let xqc play group
because i could have played gambit and just clean everyone
well is is Groot not that strong then because he uh he would
have been way better than me on Groot way better no he would
be I would he would smoke grass on Groot but it's yeah so
what would have happened I think we we were just we were
just we're gonna do go go practice and tell him fucking
Grandmaster then come back like what yeah yeah Tyler I
believe in you Tyler they took you as a captain against like
Necros and like other people that like are like full-time
like Necros hit rank one today like yeah but he did
placements and placements is like rng though it's still rank
one it is rank one but like like beginning it's a mickey
mouse rank one but it's still rank one yeah it doesn't
matter he's good i mean that's like the they put like a pro
or like a very very good player top 500 player versus a
tyler yeah some some of the captains were top 500 players so
it was stacked against you
but i believe you can get gm solo q and rivals i think i
think you did nope i believe you can do it how long if you
guys had a fresher account yeah would it take you like in
hours like well there's placement matches now maybe like
wait like gold or platinum you should do placement matches
five hours isn't the most you can place into off a fresh
account like gold i think it'd take you like yeah but you
gain you gain like 40 plus i think if you win yeah i guess
if you win every game or like most games that would probably
be that you should do a stream tyler where you do placement
matches to see where you go i gotta get to placement it's a
problem how many levels level 10 right or no level 15 15 10
level 9 i flick like 10 hours it's someone on the account
guys that's his account sharing not bannable no one no
nobody needs to know no but yeah it's quick play i mean
quick play is the best way for you to learn other characters
other than venom dude i actually so by the way it's actually
impossible to see what these guys are on screen like i was
like in the backline i was like wait who's this wait who's
this wait who's this oh yeah and they're also wearing
different skins too is there a way to shut that off yeah
they all have no skins Yeah.
Okay, I should.
Are these skins, right?
Or is there...
Oh, wait, there's...
I know there's cosmetics.
I'm pretty sure, right?
Yeah, ults.
You can get rid of ults and stuff.
Nah, you can't change the skins.
Yeah, just visual effects for ults.
Oh.
You just gotta know.
You gotta know which blonde woman is which.
That literally, literally, that's what happened.
That's literally what's happening.
Yeah, that's the hardest part.
You gotta know which blonde woman.
man with this game i feel like all like the older players
who like come back they all play the older characters older
characters don't get better the new characters come in and
they start getting like like a must-picks not true hell has
always been good well like hell like yeah but then you see
like gambit then you see fucking like we got owned by angelo
that one map yeah it does suck People literally just stick
their third, their, like, person who doesn't play the game,
they stick them on Rocket and they beat us.
And it's like, like, yeah, it's crazy that people just can
win off that, kind of.
Like, we got our support holds down so well, too.
Like, if we could have just done that the entire turn, it
would have been pretty, pretty good, probably.
Yeah.
I think that's a marble rivals thing, though.
I think they got a...
Well, the triple support has been meta for, like, three
seasons now, so that there's nothing they can really do,
unless they, like, gut support.
I mean, can they just, like, limit it?
Well, we could.
They could.
If we replay the attorney right now, we would.
Yeah, I think so, too.
I think so, too.
Let's send some emails.
You beg them?
Rematch?
Be like, please, let us go aboard.
This out of three right now.
Let us...
These guys are pussies.
Ask them to wager us for the winnings.
Yeah, no, let us verse the first place team just to show
them.
True.
Ooh.
Just be like show match us first the first place team.
So that means if we win, we should have been first place.
We just versus the other team in our, who got the same prize
pool.
Let's put all in.
Oh, they take our prize pool.
We take theirs.
Oh, wait a minute.
Okay.
So that would mean that we were going against the last place
team, right?
We were fifth or no?
No, we were fourth.
We were fourth.
We're third.
Third or fourth.
because we got we got semis oh right right right yeah not
last not last not even second last whoa that's true that's
true we had a clean record yeah middle of the pack i'll take
that what i'm saying is they banned my moonlight main and we
lost it was a risk they respected my moon night and it cost
us i'm sorry team was it the first time you didn't play it
um i did one other game of name all but that was the first
time they banned the moon night yeah fucking pussies peek
bullied on our fucking yeah our new players were not
supports i guess like epic was support but like it was
harder wait we had both new players off support well it's
you and yeah we have yeah but like uh the other teams new
players are support players mostly i was saying that it's it
i just yes this is what it is but i mean come on it's it's
it's harder for us for sure when i'm playing thing for sure
especially like in other games if if the if you put a new
player on a tank and league legends oh my god the game's
over i just it's over so like you guys are probably
struggling like a with me it is what is guys no dude it
wasn't it wasn't a struggle it wasn't a struggle it's just
that hell of man we were just that is such a strong thing
and we just don't have a third we didn't have a third
support yeah we just couldn't do triple support because it's
just it was just more like a comp restriction for us because
i think our team was the only team that couldn't do triple
support mirror but we beat teams who were doing triple
support which is a huge like in rank it it's always triple
support wins triple support against others like because yeah
because like in rank the best comp is triple support if
you're losing you go triple support it's just okay they did
have fixed that for sure that it's like yeah it's so hard
though because if they nerf if they nerf the supports then
the dive is just insane no gotta be so you guys don't
complain on stream about that no everyone complains every
day because the reason it is even a thing now's because deep
supports are overtuned to shit because they bitch about dive
also also it's like the curicle situation where all the best
skins are people who buy skins are support players so then
so they gotta support players happy yeah and low elo is not
no one cares about it that much yeah the casuals that's like
the majority of the players like they just play whatever the
fuck they want them iron man scarlet witch yeah they'd be
banning different things like penny and spot a man yeah but
yeah triple support is just a huge problem overall i don't
know the only way they can like do anything is to fully gut
support as a oh just limit the rules like yeah people but if
they limit if they limit the roles though there's too many
supports that actually suck that people want to play like if
they limit the roles then you're stuck with people on adam
and you can't help like you just are kind of fucked you just
i mean they can do it they can but people will be mad people
it's like an overwatch when they introduce roll q and then
they brought backs like they brought everything back i think
people just get really mad i never played overwatch what is
the reason they don't do that or would it be people say it'd
be bad if they did it goats oh it's because goats was
introduced where people played three supports three tanks
and then it was like triple support where goats was the only
comp that can win against anything and then they had to
introduce roll queue because they couldn't do anything about
it got it well also when supports are asked no one plays
them and then every game is just five dps and no yields oh
yeah that's true i'll remember or or you get a game i once
had a game where i had six support players not great.
But it is what it is.
Maybe in the new season, maybe in five more seasons, triple
support will finally be dead.
I saw like people when Deadpool came out, people were
running quad support two tanks in high Elo and winning.
Did you see that KG tweet, Moxie?
No, I didn't.
Now he was winning games with four supports with Deadpool
and two tanks.
I believe it.
That shit's scary.
whose team fucking won oh my god wait whose team won i'm not
gonna lie metaphor is a snipe i know i tried to get him but
i didn't know he was top 500 when he played yeah he's a
sleeper i had a a that's the iron fist yeah erob just picked
the fucking highest rated person he's a little bitch no
metaphor wait moxie's the highest rated person too yeah but
he was a second round pick
should have been a first is what should happen so he got two
first round picks that's true he got space and metaphor him
he was trying to pick me honestly out that would be fucked
yeah but you picked metaphor you wouldn't have got moxie
tyler oh that sucks oh wow wait who would have been your
second pick then if it was so if pick was moxie into
metaphor that's it yeah and then would you be your third
pick would have been collazo you would have been stolen doki
you would have been stolen moxie before second pick came out
was moxie or aura mori oh so you're good geez top uh top 500
strategists calmer as well oh calmer that's what we needed
didn't we beat her though yeah her team was last we slammed
them yeah we did i mean picking that that's just picking a
support man and then there's and uh and already too many
yeah like you you never you should never pick like one above
all for like support first you need to pick like dps or tank
first because it really is every player who doesn't play is
uh because this tournament already had like too many support
players so you had to get the highest ranked dps or tank
player i think the draft was good the draft was good it was
just it took us a while solid yeah hey by the end uh we were
i mean we ran them down we were destroying them first half
and obviously they switched some things and but like we
figured it out to some extent like we didn't figure it out
again but we figured it out to where we were winning games
if it was best of three we would have beat them for sure i
think we would have fixed something yeah all best of one is
just best of one is just all right is it over they haven't
last tournament as well uh the best of one like you just
don't have that attempt to like learn from the matchup and
yeah yeah you can't adapt right yeah it's whoever it would
have lasted forever if uh they had a best of three leading
into the final two i think like semis would have been fine
with best of three though yeah they could have i think find
best of three and then because it's just one more game i
wonder if we did less if there was a way to make the round
robin less like less teams yeah i guess yeah this is like
people's favorite turn yeah i feel like every time like this
and the last time they hosted this were like people come in
my chat and they're like this is the best uh fairy to watch
that rivals like puts on is it i don't think it's twitch i
don't think it's twitch rival no no no no marvel rivals like
but yes it is it's like there's like they have mrc but like
i don't think people like watching that that much wait the
actual training wait so do you uh so dokey boxy and who's
taught who's that before they awesome are you guys overwatch
mains or excuse me my rival mains i am no yeah i'm not i do
variety i play rivals off stream more i'm just there for the
game you know i'm i'm i'm just there for the passion
I literally, like, Moxie would be like, why is she playing
off-stream?
Wait, Moxie, do you play this?
Rivals, yeah.
I don't play League anymore.
I don't know what you play.
You play Overwatch?
You guys play Overwatch still?
No, not really, but...
No, they fucked up the top 500.
I don't know if you heard of it.
I have not touched that game since this game came out.
Top 500 and Overwatch played a win.
So it's like how many hours you put into the game puts you
in top 500.
so like there's like masters players that are like top 10
right now because all they do is just play the game i
thought that's fortnite does league have that as well or no
there's no way to leak is league top 500 play to win no i
don't think so no no no right now it is because the new
season fucked everything up yeah that's what i'm saying but
it'll get fixed uh but no it's not at all okay yeah i don't
think it's like it's like it's like plus 18 minus 18.
oh yeah he's not saying that because he's top 50.
Wait, are you top 50 right now?
Yes.
Oh, shit.
Then you have plenty of time to grind rivals.
You already got what you need.
I'm actually dying, by the way.
I dropped because I watched the girls for like six hours in
the morning.
And then I stream.
So usually I only stream five hours.
I've been streaming like 10 and I'm only sleeping three.
Oh, my God.
So it's actually not viable.
It's actually not viable.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, no, childcare is hard.
You guys got kids?
You ever thought about getting the nanny?
Nope.
This puppy I just got that I was talking about is I
basically feel like I have a child.
I'm waking up a few times a night to sleep.
My puppy.
The nanny, maybe coming up.
That'd be lit though.
You say, you said, what'd you say, a nanny?
We don't have any family bias.
Oh.
It's all about.
That'd be huge.
What age is your oldest?
21 months.
almost two-year-olds and then we just got a four-month-old
oh so she can talk now right yeah the dude the two-year-old
talks yeah she's a big girl oh wait who did she say dad
after first words first words so most of the time it's dad
it's always gonna be dad 99 of the time it's data just they
have easier time saying that mouth movement so it wasn't
that i want i'm pretty sure that's what that means yeah you
won yeah you won
number one parent right there number one yeah every time you
every time you lose a rank on the on the league rankings
just know that you're gaining a rank in the parent rankings
that's what i do literally i swear to god i had kids none of
this matters by the way oh yeah you used to make me so mad
now i swear i don't give a are you gonna yeah the kids of
your life dude are you gonna
was that a yes or no dude that could have easily been a no
like a fuck no like do not make these like force these kids
into that lifelong addiction
i don't blame you at all if you didn't that would be yeah
but they could be like the best you could train them you
could yeah you could like start them off young and they
could be the
could be like i don't play league but one can play support
and the other the other one is like top lane or something
like that yeah you just need to make your mods yeah dps and
a mantis you just get the get them pocketing though imagine
you guys are delusional a little bit yeah i'll say this
though kids are like a early age or a cheat code i swear to
god you you could teach them anything and they remember it
like right away are you teaching them korean no we don't
know yet so so it starts at three is when they remember
stuff like a three-year gap or something but i don't we
don't know what we're doing yet so possibilities actually no
you should teach them korean start young you know because
why korean because wait where does that come from oh what
the fuck you said that to him I was like, does he speak
Korean?
I was like, well,
that's all the best league players, isn't it?
Tyler's response wasn't even like crazy either.
He sounded like he was going to.
Oh, I did not because language is teaching a language.
Oh, yeah.
Can you do it?
How many times throughout your day do you guys use a second
language or would need to?
Like twice.
Probably all the time.
My dog knows Chinese.
how did that happen i just oh um he i scold him in chinese
because it's more aggressive i just be like stop but i'll be
like why no give us a preview in chinese i'll be like why
moa moi and then he gets like fair enough yeah and then he's
like i would listen to that as well yeah and then he he
walks away he's like oh i'm sorry i'm sorry they're valid
Yeah, because he's a bark.
He's a weener dog, so he barks really fucking loud.
So I'd be like, what?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, if you are planning on teaching your kids a second
language, what would it be?
Always Spanish for us.
It's like, it's pretty big in the States nowadays.
That's true.
It's probably the best, like, second language you can learn
if you had to pick one.
I did 200 plus, sorry, two years streak on Duolingo learned
fucking nothing.
Really?
Didn't miss a day for over two years.
years i mean i know like no don't think it sucks things that
i deleted it was a hard delete but i had to do it i was like
this i'm just doing wasting my time wait how wait you didn't
remember anything or it's not like i have like more than i
had when i started but like if someone came up and spoke to
me in spanish i would look like a idiot that program is a
troll no it is kind of a troll you have to supplement it's
the most normie bait it's the most normie bait i've ever
seen Yeah, I have five years on that.
Five years for one language.
Did you retain anything?
What did I say?
No.
Well, I'm not going to ask you to speak because you just
said it's horrible.
But what did you do?
It's just multiple of languages.
Yeah, wait, Mox is really good at learning languages.
Yeah, I remember you were recommending me channels and
stuff.
Yeah.
Are you actually?
That's what I'm doing in third time.
How do you learn languages?
I'll link you something.
Yeah, he's gatekeeping.
That would be sick.
I would love to learn other languages.
He's gatekeeping to the public.
I've heard of people doing other ways too, bro.
But after that Duolingo experience for me, I straight up
haven't even thought about it in a while.
Like, so demoralizing.
I've tried a Michelle Tomar, the guy that does the, I think
he does French in a couple other languages.
That feels pretty good.
But I'm like, super basic level.
I've only just started trying that.
But like, I feel like everyone just says, like, immersion is
the best way to go.
just gotta watch netflix in the target language yeah and
also have someone to talk to as well in that language yeah
that's like the best way to learn like your dog yeah moxie
what is my chinese dog bro it's goaded it's goaded that's
why you know it's goaded what have you like be be so serious
like have what have you learned all of them all of them what
what is that they're that good i'm telling you it's no guys
i'm just saying erob's team band hella against well yeah
they see it now they see it now yeah they learned from us
they learned from us we're gonna these guys these guys took
no no we should have private their profile like all of them
had private profiles like yeah but they can watch streams
yeah but we can't watch their whole profiles how many hours
they have on what and do this i don't think there's wild
cards that's true i mean they were just targeting you moxie
it didn't really matter to us so we private our profiles
they would just want a you god yeah i should have privateed
my shit yeah they wouldn't have had a clue yeah against xcc
your fucking duo yeah he robs rocket is nasty i should see
bandit actually xc see bad
wait it's kind of crazy to ban a rocket to ban like a rocket
player only plays rocket wait erob seems they can't play the
else yeah what do you make sense what are you saying the
erob team beat necros's team yeah they did they shoot on
them actually whoa necros has won the last two of these two
so but yeah and you see how it's a triple support team
versus a triple support team yeah i think that space guy's
pretty good i don't know who yeah he is he's was in very
good he was on my team last time he was my he was a tank
main and he igl then i was the supporting tank for him and
we did we got second yeah he's a top 500 player in overwatch
and in rivals no he's that guy he's that guy he can get rank
one if you wanted to at any time yeah but he don't care yeah
he's already done it okay we got moxie in the beginning with
like a sinatra or whatever yeah he did a roommate squad bro
they were literally just three stacking i remember the nyxl
stacks those were torture people i don't know if it's true
people used to say they'd literally banned the three
stacking in hailo because of them yes because they would
just run people's lobbies it would be three yeah i can't
believe you could three stack in rank that's so stupid you
can't anymore like a high like once you're past uh once
you're in celestial you can't but gm you can and honestly so
like i don't know that ranks all over the place bro yeah but
you could technically six stack to gm or to celestial if you
want you can't six stack in gm you know six times gm or is
it three stack only four stacks oh yeah they keep changing
the numbers i'm not keeping track of it anymore i wish you
could still three stack in uh celestial but i mean i get why
you can't yeah because you can run one support one dps and
one tank and then just abuse that are you hoping erob loses
or what tyler i mean the thing that you lose to you you
would have hoped wins the whole thing means that you lost
the champs that's true yeah i mean i do hope xcc
they're uh whipping the shit of them and not only that we
were we were uh i mean we really could have beat this team
like we played them twice it was beat them both times fuck
us oh bro that swap was just too too good when did he swap
to helen after first half i think when we just ran them down
probably yeah um first half they swapped off one of their
supports to mantis and then he he just told i think he just
told her to follow him that's very yeah yeah i was gonna say
we they held up the entire third point up we just ran them
down their triple support was not mantis it was like invis
uh jeff and something else dude it was in this girl in these
turnies genuinely i think the i think the band was solid
like i don't think i feel like playing a game against the
fucking good squirrel girl who knows what they're doing when
people don't play this game on your team like you're just
getting tapped by nuts the whole time and needing heels and
positioning's notice xqc's team is mostly x over like not x
but current and x overwatch players
dude moxie your mic is uh your mic is crazy i'm only my bad
my bad so i'm like a thousand yards stale holding it down to
say something any longer i was gonna my bad you're good hey
at least guys at least we we beat super's team and he had to
sit out that's a win in mind we made him sit in the chair in
the corner wait dude epic send me uh send me pictures of
your dogs if you have them we'll see them yeah i do i would
love to they're so i have two right now i have maizee is a
blue merle and then milo's a red merle so oh yeah you got
both the merles milo's a red merle you said yeah milo oh my
name's milo as well that's crazy nice or you just called him
a dog that's actually messed up it's not the first time dude
i wanted the uh your real name is milo yeah w i like that
hell yeah no dude i went in for the i went in for the black
try all out people all the all the people all the breeders
were literally like dude the red murals and blue murals go
so fast people are like obsessed with them people are like
fancy yeah they're like super cute is it colors and stuff is
it purebred is yeah i think so wait i think so is it
purebred just they're from a breeder i don't think do
breeders i guess breeders sometimes yeah purebred pedigree
yeah you should get like a certificate if it's a purebred oh
yeah they are they definitely are let me see this yeah
another one and that's expensive dog if the tournament paid
for it maize is real pretty i like that i i was coming
around bro by the end before right before i got him like a
couple days ago i was like maybe i was like i kind of like
the other colors too but i had a corgi just before and he's
a black try and he was the cutest fucking corgi ever so i'm
just biased to the colorway man i don't have a great one of
milo but there's them together oh you hate milo so you hate
milo that's crazy i'll be honest but i'm gonna be honest my
maizee's cuter i get it but maizee is bro but that's still
cute those are still adorable dogs and i i i fucking love
this little guy i mean i would die for him already and i've
known him for three days.
It's pretty even.
The two teams.
Yeah, I was gonna say the same thing.
They kind of.
Yeah.
iPhone 8 user.
I gotta get out of here though, team.
That sounds good, bro.
We win the next one, you know, this squad.
We'll just have to run it back.
Yeah.
Would you pick us up again, Tyler?
All right, I'll see you.
Sorry, what you said?
No, I'm watching this match oh like absurd the fucking who
what pov are you watching i'm not watching e-rob strip you
can't play cloak and dagger for wait you knew how to play
cloak and dagger tyler no oh okay obviously how do you know
he kept saying how do you know he kept it yeah he knows how
not to play apparently
they're pretty evenly matched i think it's because they're
both running triple support too because it's like I
completely agree.
Actually, it's literally just.
I mean, no one's going to die.
So I didn't know that was a thing until you said it, and you
guys talked about it.
This is because that last game, I noticed it so fucking
hard.
Like nobody was taking any damage from anything.
I'm surprised you didn't, you weren't able to like, I guess
it's because the games before that were kind of not as like,
like in the last two weren't as intense, but I'm surprised.
You didn't like notice it before because if triple support,
if they're a decent team and they heal each other, like solo
venom unless someone's shooting with you is going to do
nothing.
or dive into you're just going to be like in the back line
building old and giving them all that's the that's literally
what it is that's what it is you're not gonna good luck i
mean you gotta catch him so off guard they weren't really
healing there jeff i will say sweet nita was just floating
in the back and i was just almost killing her on mag the
entire game i felt bad with my comps because i was like
they're probably all over the place because we're focusing
someone on cart and then i'm like guys their jeff is like i
don't want to say like like just like sitting there in the
open not getting healed for a while i was i had i i i was
going in the back i don't know who's dps and who's healer so
it's just see people in the very back oh they gotta be
healers i would just go on them yep i mean venom can be like
the only i think the only way venom's like i mean i wouldn't
even play him in a triple support in the first place but the
only way he's good in the triple support is if you are like
doing the old uh like the old tech the one shot combo and
you're yeah and you're insta and you're also like comboing
with a support old potentially something to get kills
because otherwise you're just gonna alt not kill anyone be
in their back line not killing you like it's just so tough
venom's really he's good it's just uh it's just he's got
meta right now if if the tournament was last season you
would have been killing it last season was venom meta you
would add moxie probably on daredevil or do you play
daredevil a lot moxie i played daredevil yeah just like it's
got nerfed this season too yeah is he that much I mean, he's
not as scary as before, but he's no longer a permaband.
I didn't think he was like, I mean, he's obviously good, and
if you combo them, he's good, but I didn't think he was as
strong as people were, like, as afraid of him.
No good daredevil is fucking scary.
No, it's so annoying.
Space is yelling at Erop on his own.
Really?
Yeah, he didn't hold it down for him to hear, but...
Nah, space is so good, too.
I'll be honest if EROB grab EROB was gonna grab me first and
but if you did not grab space like he definitely would
Easily win every whatever other way so he should have
grabbed space instead No, no, no, you're always gonna pick
me.
Oh, talk.
Well, uh, yeah, the DP space is playing tank He has 600 HP
doesn't really like need to think like I'm like I'm like two
shots away from dying No, space is like hard at you Like
hard hard IGL.
Yeah, the best IGLs that you have to get is either a tank
player or a support player.
I mean, I tried, but.
No, I was trying to.
It's really tough.
Yo-combs were good as well.
Like, don't be too harsh on yourself.
I wasn't getting healed the, like, last game.
Probably way too deep.
You were way too deep.
No, you were, like, in Nania.
Yeah, but I kept on a swing up in the air.
Like, hey, I'm in the sky.
Heal me.
I don't know how it works, though.
I think you were, like, so deep that, like, the angle was
off.
for us yeah oh my
a pro too so yeah space is every team he's ever been on he's
he's like the main igl like he just was he a pro pro in
overwatch yes he was in overwatch league he's got more time
in this game just in scrims than i probably do in the whole
genre so that i didn't know that that makes a lot of sense i
i mean i wasn't around overwatch at all like i literally
never played that game i think i played overwatch too for
like two hours but this game how similar is it at this point
like does it feel the same there's a lot of no i've not
there's a lot of people who are good at overwatch and can
still be pretty mid at this game and it also feels so slow
in overwatch now too i think rival is that a good thing or
bad thing it really depends on how you feel about the game
people sometimes people complain that rival alt builds too
fast because the thing about rivals now is just if you're
playing in pro it's all about alt rotation like whichever
team rotates their all it's the best because it's just the
battle of all it's not the really the battle like whoever
yeah there's like no neutral fighting anymore yeah it's just
whoever builds their old first because the problem with
gambit which is why he's on instaband is whichever team
builds their gambit all first oh yeah wins the fight and
people would do that cheesy thing where we'd be like don't
shoot the teammates don't don't shoot the enemy we should
have just done that we were just no damage and one we
probably would have won i figured i remember that right
before the game was like before the over 10.
i was like fuck i've just that's actually tragic because if
we said it there's no way they would have able to like
recognize that we were doing it in time so how does that
work what is the um basically the luna doesn't heal i just
heal everything because then i build gamut alt first and
then enemy team can't counter and counter it because they
have triple support so no matter what because we any damage
to the emmy team and then we just take tank damage and we
were attacking first so we could have just done it yeah like
you just literally can't lose in your if you use it yeah and
i figured it out first because i was like oh i should go
with moxie because he's getting 2v1 that was my initial
thought because i was like okay if i go with moxie he can
maybe get a pick and like kill hell up if i was with him
yeah that's that's just so tough man like he hey band is uh
hey band is best character and we just against this meta
moxy would you have been able to play that as hawkeye what
would it mean like if if it doesn't matter if i'm on hawkeye
i'm it counters any of that like triple support bullshit
yeah i'm the only person like who can kind of play it well
enough is is hawkeye banned and so look you then No.
I mean, if I'm on the enemy team, probably.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
No.
If we find out Moxie's on the enemy team, yeah, we just bad
Moxie.
Yeah.
In rank.
Because he's like the really the only hot guy player that
people are afraid of in rank.
So he just one shots all supports?
Yeah.
As he hits.
Fully charged headshot is a is an insta kill.
So it's like Widowmaker.
Yeah.
Practically.
Projectile.
Sounds like it.
yeah like it's like they banned hawk guy and literally was
the only thing that counters triple support so there was
nothing we could do besides match yeah we would have had to
match that probably would have been the best yeah but i
don't think we could i don't i think they were definitely
the better we had a mantis we should have we should have
early on just been like i mean it's so kind-sighted but we
should have early on just been like yeah let's do uh uh, on
triple and just force it and he gets like good, like just
improves the whole time.
The thing is is triple, uh, dude you need two tanks.
You need two tanks because you just don't take enough damage
to get any of your, like Hey, man, we get, we get Mr. Raffle
Waffles on Mag.
I go Groot or something, and, or he goes support and then we
have the two tanks still.
I mean, we should just, I don't have found a way to force
it, I guess.
Yeah, but it was too late in the, too late in the game to
force it.
No, 100%.
Yeah.
I've never played tank in like any, never played it in
Overwatch, never played it in this.
So my understanding of like the rhythm of how you play tank
is just not there.
I've never like figured out what you're meant to do.
I just wander around like, uh, okay.
Honestly, we genuinely, even with our comp being not like
meta at all, we could have won.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think so.
Like, I think it's just a hella ban.
It was just that one ban.
one game and then we probably find from there maybe probably
it could have gone phoenix though as well like if they ban
he goes hit scan and gets pocketed on phoenix like it's not
as much of a problem but it's still annoying i think phoenix
is less of a problem than hello i am all 100 but moxie
probably doesn't win a one against the pocket of phoenix but
moxie plays phoenix though barely i've seen you play phoenix
in rank we literally got to we literally climbed for like
games in a row yeah but i said i'm not like a hit scan i
play all i'm good because i can flex not because how are you
how are you so good at hawkeye but you're not like a hit
scan because to me that feels like similar like very like
it's the same skill it's just leading instead of hitting but
you're leading really well yeah i just play project out
character i play bucky play namor storm the like melee
characters dude i can't i remember the first time i came in
your stream and i knew you were like a hawk eye player and i
remember you i think you you got your hawk eye band it was
like fucking probably eight months ago or something you're
your hawk eye band and i was like wonder who's gonna play
and you were like oh i just my aim's not like that i'm just
not a hits game guy and i'm literally like what the because
i asked i was like like i'm surprised you're not playing
hits game you were like i'm just not good at hits game and
that made no sense to me you remember it very well i'm also
on i was also on a bad monitor back then i'm i did not think
setups are that op like set up sir i was on just like a 10
year old 144 a 144 hertz oh that's a game changer 500 god
damn well i want i'm still on 144 should i be on 500 you
need to get those max frames bro on the zombies is that
actually like that makes a difference yeah it makes a huge
difference oh that's pretty crazy i'm gonna watch yeah no
way if you guys have if you guys don't have at least an olad
like an olad is crazy as well no i actually improved my game
it's not even like gameplay wise it's like your enjoyment
being on the pc is gonna be like maxed out oh damn yeah okay
i know the swap from a 60 to 144 what was exactly like that
are you taking a swap it's like 44 to that is the same
probably 144 feels nice yeah yeah it feels like that no way
i'm sure no no no when i made the when i made a swap i had
like a vtuber rivals tournament and i won the tournament
with the with the new monitor it felt like i'm not kidding i
have locked three characters in my back because i bought and
i played like gambit too i would not yeah i would not be
able to go compete against pros like in hit skin if I did
not have this monitor damn okay I wouldn't it's not that I
would be diff it's not like I would be diffing them it's
like I can keep up wait Tyler why do you not have like a I
guess yeah you don't really need it in league I feel like
but he plays games that I think I play a lot of other shit
but I don't like changing my shit I've had the same monitor
for like 10 years yeah I feel that I'm the same way 144 like
and I didn't really back 44 was the peak by the way.
Oh, I have that same.
Oh, dude, you need to upgrade.
That's true.
I'll upgrade it.
I will buy one tomorrow.
Now that you guys are fucking.
No, no, you should.
You should get one.
Monty, what do you have?
What do you, what one do you have?
I have the MSI.
Me too.
I have a code.
Do you guys want to use my MSI code?
Yeah.
Send it over.
Yeah, I have a partnership with MSI.
Wait, bro.
If you have the same monarchy, you said it in our little
chat.
I mean, I use, I think I have a, i have an aces like uh i
think mine's like a 360 hertz the monitor is like seven or
something dollars yeah yeah is that the same one you have i
think yeah yeah same one because like we yeah he had to buy
his i got it for free oh yeah i'm not i'm not that kind of a
big deal okay yeah i'm not a big deal like okay oh i see
that affiliate link okay yeah it's my affiliate link let's
go all right guys i'm headed off here ggs again that was
Thank you.
Yeah, T.T.
T.T.
Tyler.
Oh, dude, that monitor.
Yeah, that monitor looks cool.
That's good.
Yeah, well, what do you have, Klazo?
Um, it's, I think it's about same price.
I want to say I paid like 7,800 for it like a year or two
ago, and it is, I think it's 360 Hertz.
Asus.
Yeah.
I don't know.
ROG Swift, one of those ones, but it looks, uh, it has more
of like the full border, but it's beautiful, dude.
I remember when I first got it, I was on Fortnite.
think you're what you said was the biggest thing like the
enjoyment of being on the game is like it just changes so
much i really wouldn't have thought though because the jump
from 60 to 120 is like yeah 100 i 60 feels so bad now but i
i thought that like once you were kind of pushing past that
you just stopped seeing it but i guess no big myth you just
you just can never go back 100 right like when i went from
500 hertz i can't speak on that because like i had the worst
144 four hertz so it might have been like everything well it
might have been everything it might have been the panel plus
the hertz yeah like it was like game changing like I was
literally mesmerized it's like I wish I only bought it
earlier the is it the like the response time is that what
they call it is that like that's lower so it's just like
faster refresh rate and it's less like the colors like the
colors of your monitor is like oh that's the oh yeah the
OLED I think OLED is a big game changer.
I don't know how big difference like 240 to 500 is.
It's probably not that much.
Yeah, that's probably not crazy.
The OLED is the craziest thing.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I think I'm on a...
It hurts.
Some old piece of ass right now.
Dude, your zombies will literally...
I have to imagine.
Call of Duty would be so much better to play on a...
I'm going to be terrified.
They're going to look too real.
Literally right when you unbox it and plug it in, you're
going to be like looking at your screen.
you're like wow this thing's beautiful the one thing is the
the thing that stopped me from doing it for a while as well
is most people game on like 24 to 24.5 like inch monitors
almost strictly and like this is 27 i think and at first i
was like i don't know if i want it but like dude it's who
literally who cares i mean it's so worth it do you just put
the screen a bit further away like on your desk is that oh
yeah i mean or sit yeah or sit a little further it's it
feels honestly it feels very similar and it just looks
beautiful
and everything for the strats bro they're so into it oh my
god it's crazy they're so it's for everything why didn't we
do that they are they are locked for this who's bc hiding
profiles is crazy like we should i think if we that's got to
be that's got to be bad next time yeah like like they could
read us all like they read all into us i remember i looked
at like zoils his was like end yeah and then like i checked
like mid-match i'm like oh like i would have never known to
ban that he has 200 hours on strange and like five on the
next oh thank god like like and all of them have looked
through our shit they're like okay well well like if we
don't save venom they obviously are gonna ban venom yeah
that would be for sure tyler has 2.3 hours on venom 50
minutes on and then two minutes on anything else one minute
one minute zero yeah i wonder if people just wouldn't have
banned his his venom no they would they would knowing
they're playing triple support and just he's like not able
to do much like i wonder if they were just kept them like
fuck it no no no you don't understand no you do not want him
anything other than venom you know someone that put him on
put in my character not venom oh guys it was moxie literally
farmed him marcy out hot guy farm the of him oh yeah i mean
we could have won i mean no you did what you were fine oh i
was muted no there's nothing you do with that then at the
end of that game i just don't play oh my god i was gonna say
but you know you do not want tyler on anything but venom
because like he went off venom and then moxie literally
farmed the out of him uh yeah yeah definitely or whatever
because like he just doesn't have time enough because when
he was on hulk all he did was just to the back line and just
died because he had there was no escape last year yes yeah i
mean i remember that tournament i i fanned out his venom
yeah you ban that's why i was like you know he has to be on
venom because he had the most knowledge on venom because
other than that he back capped us on venom and one of the
dominations on that last turn i remember so we were
literally so confused we're like where's tyler and he's just
the point just starts getting ticked and he gets it and he
misses his swing and just starts walking away and we killed
him but it was i mean it's hysterical dude i want to get him
in the range like give him run i don't think he knows that
like if you damage near a group wall or the group wall
attacks it true like he just pressed alt and then just
pressed left click right click he saved the he saved uh i i
would have had probably three or four more kills on offense
on one of the maps but he kept he every once in a while he
throws big wall right in front of me i was like i can't do
anything that's what i was like dude throw that to the side
like you know you know what else would have been crazy like
we loki would have gotten owned that last match if ruffle
didn't hit that name or alt on that oh my god yeah that name
or alt was so fat dude that was loki cinema like we would
have lost that fight right there we would have gotten her
held third point because they had an extra support alt on us
yeah that that other that all basically destroyed the
support world it just sucks because triple support they just
out rotated our support olds by the time they hit the third
support out like what the fuck do we do and like Namor isn't
a match to us alt like either it's like well you name or
alted but they still have 10 more seconds of cloak alt yeah
yeah I guess that's what's fucked up about supports I think
through the whole tournament I was so I did like maybe like
four hours of practice yesterday to just like learn like i
basically learned dps yesterday like i i'd only really
played support prior and uh i just figured that there was
going to be more support depth so it would be more useful
for me to be on dps and the thing that i was worried about
in the tournament was the with higher level players all my
alts would just whiff every single time but i think we had
pretty good alts energy ultimately we had the one double
support alt but it didn't matter and then yeah
counter the Jeff at the end but for the most part I think
they I think it was sort of adding some value which I was
and we still killed him also we still got Jeff when you
missed yeah it didn't matter because it's just on the edge
of my ring so just did less damage to him and he just really
just held up I think it just is a bailout bro if your third
support stinks and he dies they have two more yeah yeah like
the game the fight's not over and by the time those extra
support Alts end the third support has walked back to the
fight basically.
Yeah, literally.
Yeah, just it's brutal I like that we weren't playing Gambit
even though he was on band sometimes just because I feel
like it helped Moxie or Mike's pooping itself.
Oh, bro.
I'm keep holding that I keep holding down my own push to
talk because I'm like I'm ready to talk But I didn't say it
say it say it.
No, no, I agree.
That's all I want to say.
Oh, okay.
Oh, okay gambit only because they were running triple
support it really didn't matter no yeah true because like if
we ran gambit like and we run into them they just pop a
support all and that just fucks us over it only works if
they if um if we have triple support with gambit like triple
support gambit low-key uh and then third would be whatever
but if you just run duo support gambit against triple
support it's just it's just ggs yeah There's just no count,
like, you can't really, you still can't counter it.
That would be rough.
Yeah, it's really, like, the only way is to, like, like, we
outplay them until they just walked the hell out, and then
we just couldn't do anything about it.
I also wish I could see, oh, man, now the private thing is
so cheesy.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
The way that you banning this game, is it like, or the, not
ban, sorry, nerfs?
is it like each season they'll do a big wave of nerfs or
will they do mid-season they do mid-season nerves yeah but
it's like very it's very little the mid-season it's like
okay so they save it mostly for the other wasn't the
mid-season one the one unless i'm wrong the most recent
mid-season one was that not the one where they like buffed
everyone or maybe that was season five they do that every
day every season to be fair yeah but that one season they
didn't nerf anyone like at all i've lost track this the
release season so fast because the seasons happen so fast
too and that's like the hard part how long do they last like
a month two months a month oh my god that fast yeah like if
you look at it yeah it's a month there's 27 days of the
season left and literally the season started today yeah what
the hell that's so quick yeah so it's like you
remember yeah no wonder they saved the nymphs for the for
the season changes because it's like it's so soon i still i
wish this german had deadpool mandatory i think it would
have been even funner more fun i thought they were going to
and then i looked it up and i didn't see it in the rules and
then you said it and i was like am i fucking dumb like
because i think we would have we might have had like it'll
be cooler for comps for sure yeah i think we would have
Maybe.
Just because other people have them and they play them.
Like that dude that we lost to plays, like clearly has good
hours on it.
Necros clearly has good hours on it.
We would have been forced to put, have any of you guys
played him?
Maxi and I both had early access.
I played two minutes.
I played against him for like two hours.
That's something.
That counts.
I don't know what our disabilities did.
That's what I mean, bro.
He does stuff and I'm like, should I be peeling for this
idiot?
Like he's dancing.
bro i also like couldn't even kill him as like a dps like
unless i just like i don't know he's just like that
character's crazy yeah i was talking as well he was just
like very well i think definitely for sure like i think if
super does another tournament this he should just ban triple
support like no team can't run triple support that would be
something i would take that maybe they got to be more
careful about who they like i don't know Yeah, it'll be
harder because majority of content creators are support
players Or like even out the captain.
I think even I think captains need to be evened out a little
more I think captain should have been the same Elo That's
the biggest thing you have a cat necros being a captain and
he's actually crazy But the thing is that like they just
want the biggest content creators as captains to sell the
yeah Yeah, it's a big it's big name like yeah, people are
getting hyped up because You know the biggest captain is the
captain makes sense just stinks yeah i guess they try to
even out by doing the they should make it so that snake
order thing this time around they should have done it where
like the high the high rank captains cannot pick the first
like cannot pick like one above all is there uh did they
give is that did necros have last pick intentionally like
was that like uh yes that was okay because last not giving
snake is kind cool they they did uh it was randomized who
got the order in the snake and necros i think was second
pick in the snake so he just had like second pickings of
whoever he got you got you dude i feel like i feel like i
normally do and can complain about these turnies but i don't
i think this is this is the closest thing i've ever played
like we could have won against we could have lost any match
and it looks like that's happening necros lost and we're
talking about how good he is as a captain like how it's
unfair he's not in anymore um yeah i mean this is at least i
have to complain about i think it also depends on which
captain did their research on the players there very true
because i think flacks accidentally recruited four support
players yeah yeah the flats did not do any research yeah
that's why his team had like a yeah that's why his team was
like one five or something or more he was like flexing like
support yeah is i'm already normally a support player yeah
yeah right oh my god dude that strange movement was insane i
haven't seen that yet you could b hop with the shift now
yeah what like oh my god yeah you shift forward let go of it
and then you like b hop you just b hop and pop old mid b hop
that's disgusting i kind of like that but that is scary do
you reckon it would work if they did only one one above all
player per team like total or are there just too many one
above all players in the tournament for that to work I think
every team had one above all yeah every team some teams had
two yeah it's just that fact that some teams had two and I
think like I think one team had it was like eternity and two
one above all's right or they had like two one EROB's team
had has space and then they have yeah they had two one above
of all players what is marmot is that metaphor why is he why
is that his name bro i don't know who he is who is he i've
seen the name before but i don't know who he is really
either like what does he stream i don't i don't know who
this streamer is she's gods oh he's a cod player yeah he was
challenger league and he went prone cod oh oh he was just
he's just a all-rounder then just and he's a one above all
in this game yeah yeah when you played he's just that was a
tough one when they ran punish i won't lie oh he's a war
zone player okay metaphor art
bro i gotta learn widow yeah yeah i think so i feel like
maybe dude like i feel like that's like lethal when like
triple triple supports her thing I'm a mean mantis now.
So you get, we have this turn again.
You learn Widow.
You might have a permapocket.
Wait, is Widow good?
I thought that she was like growing.
Oh, she's, she's a, I think she's like good in tournaments
like this where like people are out of position and like
random shit are being played more and triple support.
When you're starting on this map, because you can get
instant pick first.
That's what I, yeah.
So you just do what they just did of get three shots off and
then switch.
Yeah.
so it's just to see if they get the first pick okay and
because then she can just swap back it's like the it's like
king's row on widow with widowmaker
i hear that and it literally sounds like you're talking a
different language oh it's like in overwatch where they play
king's row with the the england map you just repeat the same
words yeah it's like on high rise where you go for the
collapse yeah yeah exactly whatever that is whatever the
fuck that is.
Oh, you don't understand what I'm saying?
I thought you'd go Overwatch shit.
No, I was saying I've never, I've never played Overwatch.
This, I looked, this game came out and I remember not like,
loving Fortnite at the time and I was like, I am going to
force myself to understand what these Overwatch people like
about that game because I would watch it and be like, this
is just like how anyone would watch a game like this and not
know what's going on.
You're like, this is miserable.
Like, I can't tell what's happening.
Oh, and then you watch it the wrong time.
yeah i mean yeah i would watch like an overwatch journey and
be like i literally could not i've never been more lost in
my entire life um and then this game i was like i'm gonna
force myself to play for like four or five days and i like
got so addicted you like break through the oh yeah it took
me like my first like three sessions i was in hell i was
like this game sucks and i will never play this game and
then every dad get on again with the same mentality and i
think i just found out the role a little bit i was playing
starlord i was like i can i understand what i need to do now
i understand the game modes and then it just you know from
there you just keep going i guess no this game is so this
game is so insane i love it i do too like i usually shit
talk games i play for this long but i still like it a lot i
will say i'm just not a huge fan of the triple support
lately i think it's just the meta has been still too still
for me hmm what were you saying oxy what you say about this
game oh i'm watching there every character feels so
different wait they won xqc1 yeah yeah xc1 and we lost him
and we only beat him yeah that means like we lost to the
champions and we couldn't our our match would have been
closer than this one in the final i think so too if we were
in the other bracket our match would have been closer we
need to take a round off as you see as well right we well we
did did we take a round we didn't take a round we took a map
off we took one map yeah and we got to ot in the push the
card and these guys didn't even get anywhere different map
this map kind what yeah it really was just down to down to
picks i suppose i mean she just had the perfect triple
support and also calvin yeah he had it even bought calvin
well ggs i had a lot of fun regardless yeah i like playing
in the last tournament and playing in this i've i agree with
you guys the structure is so good like they're so fun to
play in at least i find i find them so fun to play even
though i'm like kind of don't know what i'm doing a lot of
the time but like you were cooking too much to say that i'm
not kidding yeah no no you have way too many great plays to
like if you played this game played this game like i need
some coaching when you coaching me i gotta i gotta get out
of silver oh i'd play with you i'd get on my alt and run
games if you want hell yeah be fun cod is like cod's having
a weird year where everyone just decided as a group to not
buy the game this year um so i've kind of got an open year
ahead of me i'm trying to figure out what to do so if rivals
is the place to be then i'll play some rivals i'm super down
let's run it up man i'm dead yeah cod's been uh heading down
that path for a long time i feel like yeah the last year was
actually really good like i had the most view i'm like
mainly youtube more than stream i would say i had the most
views i've ever had last year um but yeah this year it's
just everyone just gave up Two million subscribers with just
zombies?
Yeah.
Oh, now I understand Tyler.
You're doing the same thing.
There's no way.
I was just like, oh, what?
You guys aren't buying car no more?
And then I looked it up and I was like, oh, my God.
How do your videos do this year with everyone saying they're
not buying it, I guess?
What was I sorry?
Like, how do the videos do in comparison from like last year
with you saying everyone like isn't really, they're kind of
like almost boycotting it.
I'm getting like 10 to 20% of the views that I was getting
last year.
Oh, wow.
That's tough.
Yeah.
Like it's like a big, like we did, did a hundred million
views in Q4 last year.
And this year we've done like 10 mil.
Oh, wow.
That is brutal.
Yeah.
I mean, it's not.
I mean, it's absolutely not brutal.
But that's, that's still, you know, I mean, you know, they
still do really well.
Like your videos still do really well.
another cod zombies and it'll be up i'm kind of terrified of
that i need a break i'm like that's the thing though as well
is cod's been doing it's been the same cycle for like 20
years at this point right so everyone's just a bit tired of
the same old yeah same thing so there's no zombies in this
coming cod and no zombies in the cod after that so like cod
2026 and cod 2027 will not have zombies so i'm like but i'm
a free agent looking to roam around wait gooning is ruining
your life yeah that's true that's true what i'm you know i'm
just how can there be cod without zombies it's called
without zombies like every other year oh like the trailer
cards are they they used to be more for the last five years
straight they've had zombies every year they've just like
forced it in yeah um but yeah there's gonna be it's gonna be
like the the next card is probably modern warfare 4 and so
that will have like spec ops or something like something
like that to be fair someone made a good point in my chat
right now too like it's it's just like these last like year
or two have been a pretty good year for games as well like
yeah i remember a few years back people bitching literally
not before fortnite came out and then for a while obviously
i'm biased gotta play that game but like and then for a few
years before rivals i feel like people were just like the
fuck is there to play like single player games have been
doing really well uh rivals did i would say decently well i
feel of people they were like thank god there's a game like
yeah it was a wasteland and then rivals was just like
actually good no 100 i mean it was there's been a lot dude
and that mixed with people getting frustrated about god like
i mean understandably so frustrated is it makes a lot of
sense i tried some warframe at the end of last year people
were really telling me that warframe would be fun because
i've played a good amount of destiny so they're kind of
similar but was it good not good sounds like you're gonna
say it well no i i enjoyed it a lot it's just a big time
commitment that's the the main thing is you just can sink so
much time into those sorts of games there's infinite
infinite grind i guess that's the same with with something
like a rivals or something but guys it was been a nice talk
i want to call it here now that the tournament's yeah peace
and out understand guys that's all i gotta say yeah hey i
think we did i think we did swell especially not being one
of those pussies playing triple support yeah yeah we didn't
push yeah and not hiding our accounts not having yeah we
didn't even hide our account we let them we're looking at
our weaknesses and strengths yeah and we didn't put tyler
one on rocket true sure that was our biggest downfall wait
before before we go moxie you not want me to i can't i don't
want to show this on stream this language thing i should
just keep it to myself if you want i don't care it's fine
i'm out though yeah love you guys let's get some more games
wow that was fun that was really fun i'm tired now i didn't
think i was gonna hang out after for showdown but it was
pretty chill tyler one is so chill off stream um it's pretty
pretty cool he's a pretty cool guy when he's not streaming
dude he's a pretty funny guy when he's streaming and he's a
pretty cool guy when he's not streaming me it was cool like
listening to him about his family and stuff and like his
girls um and i'm happy to be on that team and i felt like
that team was really fun it was a really really fun team
overall yeah good vibes good vibes i was like that was the
one thing i'm always nervous about ish vibes but good vibes
we had really good vibes overall yeah hey guys well um i
guess god of have god of war we don't have a chibi collab
tomorrow so i'll just reschedule god of war for tomorrow
then and just relax now because i'll meet you i hope you
guys had a fun time watching um i saw that tyler's chat
enjoyed enjoyed me so that's good i thought i'm always
scared of i was like i hope his chat is nice to me but it
seemed like his chat thought i was funny and i'm like yay
youtuber funny um i'm just like i'm like overall funny you
know i'm not just like i'm like i'm like overall funny yeah
that's good i'm that makes me happy um and uh i mean they
okay tyler what's fucking hilarious guys he's actually
pretty fucking funny um like he does good content shit he
knows what he is he's like the heel basically um but anyway
guys as always everybody i'll just raid the god of war
stream but then i'm putting i'm changing the time to
tomorrow but as always everybody stay hydrated posture check
it up i'm around to get that blood flowing me stay up from
me head to bed cause you deserve it i also think like you
know um our team did good overall like we everyone had to we
had like three new players.
While other teams had like one or two new players, we had
like three new players.
So it's like more so like, and their new players were mostly
on support too.
So it's like, it's definitely a lot harder.
And I think we were like one, we were one of the two teams
that never played a triple support too.
Like, no, we did try, but we're like, we can't.
Like, our team comp does not allow our team our hero
restriction um it's support easiest yes support is the
easiest role to play for a new character because there's two
there's like three support characters that you can play if
you don't know how to aim essentially there's three
characters that you can play if you're just not an aimer and
um and the and then we also staggered a lot because our new
players didn't know how to die on point which was also like
a little bit of a problem um But we were able to, like, we
did really well, too.
We did really well for it, despite, like, despite all of
that.
And I'm proud of my team for it.
I'm proud of it.
We all started talking a lot more, too, as well.
Jeff, Cloak, and Dagger, and Rocket.
They're basically beginner-friendly characters for people
who are new.
I think XQC's team had, like, two new players, or one new
player, essentially.
Yeah, one new player.
Aspen and Warren are both top 500 players, too, and
Overwatch, so they learn really fast in general.
And I know they play rivals, they play rivals, like, too,
before in the past.
So their team was hard.
I mean, we got really close.
And Calvin.
I forgot Calvin.
Calvin's just good at every game he touches.
He's just a prodigy when it comes to aiming.
And XC is a good tank player.
He is a good tank player.
surprised that he won um I'm not surprised he won because
like overall his team is very strong um and um they all
performed really really well and um my team performed really
well because we got really really close matches against him
yeah we got really close matches against I think if we were
in the second bracket uh I think if we were in the other
bracket against EROB we might have had a chance maybe i
don't know maybe i think because like they didn't have a
player like calvin uh yeah they didn't have a player like
calvin they had a punisher player but not like calvin level
of insanity yeah but overall that's my take on the
tournament very fun tournament uh very fun yeah but erupt's
team they got rolled on the second map we pushed all the way
um we pushed all the for our convoy.
But EROB's team struggled on convoy against...
Should have banned Hela!
I know!
I was like, Hela, Hela, Hela!
And then they're like, Oh, I'm gonna ban this!
And I was like, What?
That's on you!
If they play Hela and we get shit on, that's on you!
I...
I did...
I warned them.
I warned them!
I was so aggressive.
Come on.
I...
That's on you.
They didn't trust me.
Moxie trusted me on all the bands.
And then the one band.
The one band that I was like, you gotta do it, man.
You gotta do it.
This map is so good for hell yeah.
And then he was like, nah because he was like doki what do
you think doki and i was like yeah do that
brady thank you the super chat thank you thank you
um but it was fun it was fun my brain was so tired
micromanaging though it was like because like I have to,
because like in the other tournaments, when I IGL, I'm
playing with people who like have played Rivals before or we
like practice with people.
So like I don't have to actually like change the way IGL.
But for this one, it was, because like, when I'll be like,
oh, oh, you know, usually like my other support would know
what I mean.
But then like, I think like he got, he was confused about
saying he should ult or not.
Yeah, So it was like, I had to like be super specific and
also be like, I have to like, at that one point, I just
called them Luna because I was like, I keep forgetting your
name.
I'm sorry.
Oh, yeah.
And I also mentioned the band for Mantis.
I literally, oh my God.
I literally mentioned the two bands that we should do would
be Mantis Hela and I got ignored.
I, I got ignored.
ignored the two bends the two bends um but but in the end
yeah I told I warned them I warned them all I prophesied but
the team was super wavy it was it was fun I had fun time I
really liked our post-match to our post-match um talk where
we was just vibing and hanging out and just shooting our
shit and i learned more about i learned more about like
tyler one and like everyone else as well too that's cool
apparently xqc's team was like scared about my loki and
stuff being like oh my god she's carrying i think my support
my my support gameplay was pretty pretty carry i think i
think i I feel it, felt.
I think so.
I didn't do that.
And I got to show my MSI.
Yeah!
I get to show my MSI thing, too.
Yeah.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, everyone, for coming.
But I hope you guys enjoyed watching, everybody.
I really do hope all of you guys enjoyed watching.
And, uh...
And had a fun time.
I had a fun time watching this tournament.
I thought this tournament was really fun.
I went in just hoping we didn't get knocked out first time.
Or lose every game.
And you know what?
We didn't get knocked out first.
We didn't.
That's a win.
I was worried.
I feel like I'm usually cursed when it comes to content
creator non-VTuber Marvel Rivals tournaments.
Like, if it was a VTuber Marvel Rivals tournament, that's
fine.
content creator marvel rivals tournament i felt like i've
been i'm cursed in a way where like it was like either last
or we don't either last or we get knocked out first um no
for marvel rivals no i've like had a yeah we've i've had
super bad luck yeah um with them and i'm also i've been i
was like tired i'm still sick too so there's that too so i
was just Really nervous.
But we did really good.
I'm so happy.
Yeah.
We did really good.
Oh, we did really good.
And I knew, like, I was like, Oh, my God, my Tyler
Weinstein.
Yay.
I knew it was going to be really fun.
But yeah, anyway, I'm fucking, I'm yapping a lot.
But it's because I had a lot of fun.
So I just want to yapp a lot.
I just had so much fun in the tournament.
So I just, I just want to keep yapping and everything.
But GG's.
GG's to everyone we fought.
GGs to my team.
Everyone did really well.
Everyone learned so fast, like three of our players, three
of our players had less than 15 hours.
Like, less than 10 hours, actually.
Three of our players had less than 10 hours on this game.
And they did really well in the environment that we were in.
Like, we literally had...
It was just me and Moxie that had...
Like, I guess Colby, too.
But it was...
Yeah, Colby, me and Moxie had experience in, like, battle
royale slash shooters well not shooters but i guess like
moxie and i had experience with hero shooters and everyone
else had like experience with shooters in general but um
everyone learned super fast too anyway bye bye guys i'm
going on another tangent i was gonna go would you pick them
for the next tournament i mean yeah i feel like if we got
the next tournament it was this team yeah because like we
all have chemistry built in like we all have chemistry built
in now so most yeah i mean it would be a big advantage going
in anyway i go now bye-bye i i would have kept talking if i
don't go bye-bye everyone bye-bye no god of war tonight but
tomorrow i swap it to tomorrow bye-bye